IN RESPONSE TO COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT NON
ESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH ALL MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
IN PERSON THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FOR OUR REMOTE OF
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU. USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME WE ARE TO
SPEAK A POP UP WILL APPEAR
ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON
MUTE PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE
BEFORE YOU'VE BEEN SO BEGIN
SPEAKING. OUR IT PERSONNEL WILL
PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU
ARE DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE. YOU CAN
BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU ARE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE
HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
IT WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. OVERALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ALRIGHT
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. THE
NUMBER IS. 844-291-4185 THE
ACCESS CODE IS. THREE THREE
EIGHT ZERO FOUR SIX SEVEN. FOR
IS ON HOW TO TELL. TO WORKS.
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE FOR
HAVE YOUR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
I'M SURE THAT WON'T HAPPEN.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WERE ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
BEFORE WE BEGIN OUR- LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM MR HACKER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ZERO ZERO
HERE TO YOUR GROWTH NEWMAN YOUR-
QUORUM CORUM HAS BEEN THIS. I
TODAY WE WERE HAVE PART A IS
VOTE ONLY IF WANT. TO- AND THEN
ISSUES. FOURTEEN TO NINETEEN
OUR DISCUSSION AND OF PART B.
ISSUES ONE THROUGH SIX OUR
DISCUSSION ONLY ALL VOTE ALL
VOTES FOR BOTH PART A AND PART
B. WILL TAKEN WILL BE TAKEN AT
THE END OF THE HEARING ONCE WE
HAVE COMPLETED ALL DISCUSSION
AND PUBLIC COMMENT. NOW PLEASE
REFER TO ISSUE FOURTEEN ON PART
A THE HIGHWAY SAFETY PROGRAM.
HERE. OKAY AND THAT IS CAL- YOU
MAY BE WHEN YOU ARE PLEASE.
THANK YOU SENATOR IN MY THROUGH
CLEARLY YES YOU ARE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU MUCH FOR GIVING CHECK
YOU ME MY NAME IS STEVEN JACK
I'M TO FIND OFFICER FOR. I'M A
NUMBER ITEM I'M PRESENT
EVERYTHING FOR A YEAR LIMIT
TERM INCREASE OF TWENTY FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING. TO FUND
A PILOT OF THE NEW HIGHWAY
MAINTENANCE FOR SAFETY PROGRAM.
CALTRANS WOULD YOU THIS FUND TO
IN. A TWO YEAR PILOT UNDER THE
EXISTING MAIN PROGRAM. IS NEW
IN. WHAT ALLOW US TO AND- IN
TWO MAIN- SAFETY.
COUNTERMEASURE ON HIGH SYSTEM
WITHIN A VERY TIME FRAME. UNDER
THE NORMAL PROCESS WE INCLUDE
THESE SAY MEASURES AS OF LARGER
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS. THAT
MIGHT BE FOCUSED ON STATE
PAVEMENT OR BRIDGE REPLACEMENT.
IN UNDER THOSE SCENARIOS IT CAN
TAKE A NUMBER OF YEARS TO
DESIGN AND ANOTHER FEW YEARS TO
CONSTRUCT THE PROJECT. UNDER
THIS PILOT WE WOULD FOCUS ONLY
ON THOSE CD COUNTERMEASURES
SUCH AS- INSTALLING WARNING
SIGNS RESTRICTING FOR
PEDESTRIAN ACCESS. OR A- ICICLE
ACCESS AS WELL AND ALSO TO-INSTALL WRONG WAY DRIVER
PREVENTION COUNTERMEASURES IN
BY PHONE ON JUST SAFETY OWN WE
CAN DELIVER THOSE ELEMENTS TO
THE HIGHWAY SYSTEM IN A VERY
SHORT PERIOD TIME OFTEN LESS
THAN ONE YEAR. THESE ARE VERY
QUICK HITTING AN IMPACTFUL
PROJECTS THAT WE NEED TO SEE
TWO OF BECAUSE ON THE STATE
HARPER SKINNY ON THE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA. THERE ARE NEARLY
THIRTY SIX HUNDRED PEOPLE WHO
LOSE THEIR LIVES EVERY YEAR AND
MORE THAN FOURTEEN THOUSAND
SERIOUS INJURIES ON THE
TRANSPORTATION. OF THOSE TEN
DEATHS THAT WE SEE- EACH DAY
ABOUT THREE OF THOSE ARE FROM
OUR MOST VULNERABLE USERS THOSE
WHO WALK OR BIKE ON THE
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. SO THIS
FUNDING WILL ALLOW US TO- TO
FOCUS ON SAFETY COUNTERMEASURES
IN A VERY QUICK WAY TO BEGIN TO
IMPLEMENT OUR RENEWED FOCUS ON
SAFETY TO ARE JUST ADOPTED A
STRATEGIC PLAN FOR CALTRANS.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF.
COULD WE HAVE A FINANCED DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THIS.
JAMES MORE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- JUST TO SAY THAT WE
CAN COVER THE PROPOSAL WHICH
WILL ALLOW CALTRAIN STAR
PRACTICALLY QUICKLY COMPLETE
IMPORTANT SAFETY PROJECTS ON
THE TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
THANK YOU AND THE L. A. ILL.
ANY COMMENTS OR- MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND- SENATORS FRANK
MANAGES WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- OUR OFFICE
HAS NO CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL WE FIND IT REASONABLE
TO AUGMENT THE MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM ON THE SAFETY FRONT.
OKAY THANK YOU. POLLY ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE. THE GREAT
NO OF WELL I YOU- BEING WITH US
AND MAKING THIS A PRESENT TO.
OF WE ALL ARE VERY APPRECIATE
OF THE WORK THAT YOU ARE DOING
TO. EIGHT MORE MORE SAFETY FOR
EVERYONE ON ON OUR- IN OUR-
SYSTEM THANK YOU THE SAN
RECOMMEND TO HOLD OPEN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE WERE MOVED
ON NOW TO ISSUE FIFTEEN. TH.
HEY THIS THE I. OF SO WE HAVE A
CAL. THE MAKING OF. THANK YOU
SENATOR ANY FOR THE RIGHT MY
NAME IS STEVEN CHECK WITH
CALTRAIN- UNDER THIS RECALL. WE
ARE REQUESTING TO YOU SEVEN
POINT TO ME DOLLAR. IN FEDERAL.
FUNDING OF THE NINETY FOUR
MILLION RECEIVED UNDER THE
CORONAVIRUS A RELEASE AND
ECONOMICS SECURITY ACT OF THE
TERRORIST ACT- THIS IS MY SPACE
SET FOR ROLE AREA FINE FROM THE
GOVERNMENT. WE WOULD USE THIS
FUNDING TO SUPPORT MEDIUM SMALL
AND RURAL TRANSIT AGENCIES. TO
COMPLY WITH THE GENERAL TRANSIT
FEED SPECIFICATION AND
CONTACTLESS PAYMENT STANDARDS-
THIS FUNDING WOULD ALLOW US TO
BENEFIT BE HUNDREDS LITERALLY
HUNDREDS OF SMALL TRANSIT
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA. BY
STREAMLINING PROCESSES BY
SIMPLIFYING REPORTING AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY BY ROLLING OUT
STANDARDIZED SERVICES IN
TROUBLE PLANNING IN CONTACTLESS
PAYMENT AS MENTIONED AND AN
ELIGIBILITY. SO WITH THIS
PROPOSAL WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
LEVERAGE THE BUYING POWER OF A
SINGLE STATE OF THE STATE- AND
UTILIZING GLOBAL DATA AND
PAYMENT STANDARDS- WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE SAFE AND
SCALABLE ALTERNATIVES TO CASH
PAYMENTS. TO PAY FOR BUS
SCHEDULES. THEIR SCHEDULES. AND
WE WOULD ALSO BE ABLE TO DO
AWAY WITH IN PERSON L. WITH
VERY. AND BE ABLE TO DO THAT
FOR AS WELL. WELL WE WOULD
BRING THIS BENEFIT TO SMALL AND
ROLL COMMITTEE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ITSELF. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- FINANCE DO YOU HAVE
ANY COMMENTS. POLITIKA
DEPARTMENT FINANCE I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT WE CONCUR WITH THE
PROPOSAL- THIS REQUEST WILL NOT
ONLY MODERNIZE SMALL RURAL
TRANSIT AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE BUT ALSO HELP RECOVERY
FROM THE PANDEMIC IMPACTS.
THANK YOU- AND THE L. A. L. ANY
COMMENTS. THE MORNING CARE
EUNICE ROAD THE L. A. L. AND WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY CONCERNS WITH
THIS PROPOSAL AT SEVEN POINT
TWO MILLION THIS REQUEST MAKES
UP ABOUT 8% OF THE CARE IS ACT
FUNDING THE STATE HAS RECEIVED
FOR SMALLER AND MORE RURAL
TRANSIT AGENCIES. FIND THAT THE
REQUEST IS REASONABLE GIVEN THE
NEEDS OF TRANSIT AGENCIES
COLLECT FARES SAFELY DURING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR MAR.
YES YES GO AHEAD SENATOR NEW-
VERY QUICK QUESTION I SUPPOSED
CALTRANS. UNTIL EXTENT THAT THE-
FOR THIS WAS COVERT BAND PEN
DOWN AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN THE
AN OF PANDEMIC INSIDE. HOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT THAT CUT CONTRA
PAY- CLEARLY IMPORTANT
INDEPENDENT BUT IS IT IS ALSO
EQUALLY OF. ON IS THERE A OR
THE BENEFIT OF AND BEYOND- CODE
BECAUSE. THANK YOU SENATOR IS A
GOOD AND THE ANSWER IS- CONT US
PAYMENT IS ONE BENEFIT THAT
THAT CERTAINLY WE CARRY A TO
THE- OF. YOU KNOW IT THE BILL
TRANSIT EIGHT ARE DO IT- NOT
BECAUSE IT'S THE COOL THING TO
DO BUT COURSE IT IT READ. THE
OVERHEAD COSTS AND- AND REALLY
MAKE IT EASIER FOR TO. TRIPS
AND PAPER. ON ENTREE. THE
SECOND BEEN OF THIS IS BRAD
EVEN THE ONE. IS TO- TO MODERN
THESE SMALLER TRANSIT. WITH
THIS IS GENERAL FEED. AND OUT
WHY MORE. OF THESE AGENTS OVER
USE IT TO THE VERY. EXTRA WHICH
IS TO PROVIDE A SKETCH ONLINE-
WHAT WE'RE AIMING TO DO IS TO
BRING EVERYBODY UP TO THE
MODERN STANDARD WHICH IS. A LIE
OR REAL TIME GGF S. INFORMATION
AND WITH THAT. YOU CAN PICK UP
YOUR PHONE YOU CAN GO TO GOOGLE-MAPS AND SAY I WANT TO GO FROM
HERE TO HERE. IT CAN SHOW YOU
ON YOUR PHONE- WHAT BUS TO TAKE
WHAT TIME THE BUS WILL BE THERE
THE APPROXIMATE COST OF THAT
THAT TRIP- IN- EVEN AT THE- AT
THE. POSTED LEVEL IT WILL EVEN
SHOW YOU HOW LONG THAT TO TAKE
THE GOING ON AT MOMENT. SO IT'S-
A WAY TO- TO BRING THESE BY.
PERMANENT TO THE SMALLER
TRANSIT A- GOING FORWARD. I THE
MEASURE THANK YOU FOR. RIGHT
MORE COMMENTS REQUEST FOR MARK
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE NET UP
AGAIN WE REALLY PREACH THE-
DOING THIS THINK THE EFFICIENCY
THAT A BRING THE MA IS OF AND
POINT- TO THOSE NEED THE
TRANSFERRED SIR. I THINK WHAT
YOU WERE JUST MAKES. A WHOLE
LOT OF SENSE AND APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK ON THIS THANK YOU. OF
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION HAS IS
TO HOLD OPEN ON THIS AND WE
MOVE NOW TO- ISSUE SIXTEEN-
PROJECT DELIVERY WORKFLOW FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY SUPPORT- WE HAVE
THE- GO AHEAD WITH THIS. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE RECORD STEVEN
TECH WITH CALTRANS- SO THIS
REQUEST IS OUR ANNUAL ZERO
BASED REQUEST FOR CAPITAL
OUTLAY SUPPORT RESULTING IN A
NET INCREASE OF ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS. AND FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT POSITIONS FOR
PROJECT DELIVERY WORKLOAD IN
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
FISCAL YEAR. THIS PROPOSAL
INCLUDES INCREASING WORKLOAD TO
DELIVER THE PROJECTS UNDER THE
SENATE BILL ONE AND ALSO FOR
ASSET MANAGEMENT REQUIREMENTS.
TOTAL WORKLOAD RES USING TOTAL
WORK REESE REQUEST- ARE AT THE
TRADITIONAL LEVEL OF PERCENT
STATES THAT CONTENT PER MARK
GOING CAN. PROJECT DELIVERY IS
RISK. FOR THE DEVELOP OR OVER
OF ALL WORK ON STATE. IN THE
CAP OUTLAY SUPPORT PRO FROM RE
NECESSARY FOR PROPER DESIGN
EMPIRE PLAN. RIGHT OF WAY ACT.
EASEMENTS AND SALES OF PROPERTY
CONSTRUCTION ENGINEERING
CONTRACT MANAGEMENT AND OF
COURSE PROJECT MANAGER. IT'S
THE LARGEST PROGRAM IN CALTRANS
IT MAKES UP ABOUT HALF OF THE
TOTAL STATS IN THE DEPARTMENT.
THE RESOURCES THAT WERE
REQUESTING HERE WILL ALLOW
CALTRAIN IS TO PRESERVE AND
IMPROVE ON THE HUNDREDS OF
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IF NOT
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS. OF
INVESTMENT IN THE STATE HIGHWAY
SYSTEM AND THAT IS REALLY THE
FOUNDATION OR EIGHT EIGHT
FOUNDATIONAL PILLAR OF THE
STATE'S ECONOMY ALLOWING FOR
THE EFFICIENT MOVEMENT OF
PEOPLE AND GOODS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THIS IS YOUR ME WITH
THIS PROPOSAL WILL BE ABLE TO
GET. TO OUR- TO DO PRO. INTO
OVERSEE THE COULD OF BY ON. IS
WHETHER FOR BY US OR BY OUR
LOCAL. GREAT THANK YOU VERY
VERY VERY MUCH- WE HAVE HERE.
FIND YOU HAVING TO COME. JAMES
MORE WITH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WE CONCUR WITH THE PROPOSAL
WILL PROVIDE CALTRANS WITH ALL
THE RESOURCES NECESSARY TO
COMPLETE ENGINEERING ANOTHER
WORK FOR PROJECTS PLANNED IN
THE BUDGET YEAR. THANK YOU THE
L. A. O. PLEASE. THANK YOU MAN
IS AGAIN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE OUR OFFICE IS
STILL WAITING FOR SOME BACK UP
DATA FROM THE DEPARTMENT BUT
WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT AND THEN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS- NO CONCERNS HAVE
BEEN RAISED. OKAY THANK YOU.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. OKAY SO
THAT IS- ALSO. YES THE THANK
RICK RECOMMEND IS A HOLD OPEN
UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
K. YES THANK YOU ARE RISING- WE
MOVE ON TO. ISSUE SEVENTY. AND
COST RATE PROPOSED AND THAT
WILL BE ALSO BY CALTRANS NO I'M
SORRY THE L. A. L. I HAVE BEEN
IN FRONT OF MEANING. THAT STILL
BLEW IT. OKAY L. A- PLEASE. I'M
PREGNANT AGAIN LEGISLATURE
ANALYSTS- WE'VE BEEN A BY THE
COMMITTEE AND TO PRESENT THIS
IS SO JUST AS OVERVIEW I'M
CALTRANS DOESN'T ON THE OF
THEIR ENTITIES SHOULD ABOUT
FROM ON THE STATE HIGHWAYS. THE
DEPARTMENT RECOVERS FOR THE
WHICH ALL DIRECTLY OVER TO
ACTIVITY BEING ON. PLUS AFFAIRS
OF VENDOR COSTS EACH IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SB FORTY EIGHT CAP THE
RADIO CHARACTER KIND FOR UNDER
FORCE OKAY. WHICH ARE COUNTY
THAT HAVE CON WHITE SAID TAX
DEDICATED FOR CHANCE. FOR THE
CAP SET IN PLACE FOR THREE
YEARS AND EXPIRE JULY ONE
TWENTY TWO ONE. S. B. EIGHT
FOUR EIGHT ALL REQUIRE CULTURE
THROUGH ON WORK PERFORMED FIRST
OKAY BY JULY Y. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AS WELL. ON THIS PROPOSAL
IS NOT AND IN GOVERNOR'S ARE
DOESN'T HAVE- AND- FOR A- BUT
AS HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTION.
OKAY THANK YOU NOW CALTRANS.
THANK YOU CENTER THIS IS A-
WHAT WAS A PROPOSAL MAY SEVERAL
U. AGO BY THE SELF HELP COUNTY
COALITION AND IS NOT A-
ADMITTED PROPOSALS I HAVE NO ON
THAT THE START. OKAY FINANCE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR STEVE
WELLS DEPARTMENT FINANCE AND-
IT- IT'S WAY- STEVEN K. FROM
FROM- WORLD WORLD FORWARD TO-
REVIEW THE REPORT WHEN IT OUT
IN A THE- DATA BUT I OF THIS
TIME. FOR THE- OKAY. WHEN LA.
NOT OKAY THAT WOULD RESULT THAT
WITH- ANY QUESTION FROM THIS
FROM COMMITTEE US SENATE GROW
IN THIS CREEK THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR JUST HAVE A BRIEF
QUESTION WILL THE IN A ON
WHETHER FEATURE RESULT IN A
COST. OUR IS REALLY SHIFTING
FROM SELF HELP COUNTIES TO
CALTRANS SO WHEN WE PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT ON WORK PERFORMED ON
THE SYSTEM. WE ARE GENERALLY
REQUIRED BY LAW TO DO FULL COST
RECOVERY TO RECOVER THAT YOU
COMPLETE COST OF ABOUT
OVERSIGHT WHICH INCLUDES- BOTH
THE DIRECT OVERHEAD THE
SUPERVISORS OF THE FOLKS DOING
THE WORK AND ALSO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE OVERHEAD- SO.
THIS BILL CAPPING THAT
ADMINISTRATIVE OVERHEAD IT 10%
HAS REALLY SHIFTED THE COST
FROM SELF HELP COUNTIES TO
CALTRANS NOT BETWEEN SELF HELP
THE NONSTOP COPS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MA'AM CHECK
THANK YOU SEND A COURTESY.
THANK YOU MA'AM SURE HAVE A
QUESTION THAT'S A LITTLE
TANGENTIAL IN A MAYBE. A
CALTRANS CAN RESPOND BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S PROBABLY ALONG WITH
THE L. L. A. FOCUSED ON HERE
AND THAT IS DISEASE THE
OVERHEAD PROVISIONS THAT- WHO
WERE PART OF THESE CUTS I
ASSUME THIS IS PRIMARILY-
CAPITAL PROJECTS THAT ARE BEING
FOCUSED ON HERE. BUT IT TO THE
DIZZY OVERHEAD RECAPTURE BY
CALTRANS- COST RECOVERY IN
OTHER WORDS APPLY TO
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS THE THAT
MIGHT OCCUR IN THE SAME SELF
HELP COUNTIES OR OR THE
EXEMPTED THERE AS WELL. THAT'S
A GREAT QUESTION I THINK THIS
EXEMPTION. IS ONLY FOR THE
OVERSIGHT THAT WE PERFORM ON
CAPITAL PROJECTS- ON OUR SYSTEM.
YES THERE IS MAINTENANCE PAID
FOR BY OTHERS ON THE SYSTEM
WHICH IS FAIRLY RARE EXCEPT IN
VERY. IT'S A BIG CIRCUMSTANCES-
WE DO EL DO FULL COST RECOVERY
ON THOSE AS WELL AT THE FULL
RATE. GREAT OKAY THAT'S GOOD TO
KNOW THANK YOU FOR FUTURE
REFERENCE PRETIUM. OKAY. MMHM
THE FURTHER QUESTIONS OKAY THIS
IS- ON INFORMATIONAL ITEMS-
THERE WEREN'T MOVING ONTO SO
OUR FINAL ISSUE AND WE'VE BEEN
A FINAL ISSUES OF ISSUE
NINETEEN THE MULTI YEAR
INVESTMENT STRATEGY FOR CAL
STIRS WHAT. DID I MISS COME-
I'M SORRY I'M SORRY- WE WON
SEVENTEEN OKAY NEXT ISSUES
EIGHTEEN ON UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE UPDATE FROM EDT. NOT
SURE IF YOU WE DON'T TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT THROUGH THE
PUBLIC COMMENT IS AT THE END OF
ALL THE ISSUES I'M SORRY FOR
YOU IS THAT WHAT YOU WERE. OKAY
I'M SORRY SO AT THE END OF ALL
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE DO PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR EVERYTHING. THANK.
SO THE DEPARTMENT READY FOR
PRESENTATION YES WE ARE. GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING. TRIMMING
THE ROSTER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY
FOR THE RECORD FINALLY JUST
SCIENCE DIRECTOR OF THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT. THE DEPARTMENT HAS
MANY CHALLENGES AND I'M HERE TO
EXPLAIN HOW WE'RE HANDLING THEM.
BEFORE I DO THAT THOUGH I WANT
TO REMIND US OF THE CONTEXT OF
OUR SITUATION. WE TEND TO
COMPARE E. G. D. VAN ****
ISSUES TO THE GREAT RECESSION.
BUT IN MY PERFORMANCE AT THE
DEPARTMENT I SEE THAT THAT'S
NOT A GOOD COMPARISON. THE
GREAT RECESSION CAME UPON THIS
RELATIVELY GRADUALLY. THE
PANDEMIC STRUCK SUDDENLY. WE
WENT FROM THREE POINT 9%
UNEMPLOYMENT 217% UNEMPLOYMENT
ALMOST OVERNIGHT. AT THE HEIGHT
OF THE GREAT RECESSION IN THE
YEAR TWO THOUSAND TEN WE PAY
THREE. EIGHT THREE MILLION
CLAIMS A YEAR. IN THE FIRST
EIGHT WEEKS OF THE PANDEMIC. WE
PAID THREE MILLION CLAIMS IN
EIGHT WEEKS. AT. SINCE THE END
OF DECEMBER WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED
TO MASSIVE FEDERAL STIMULUS
PACKAGES WITH CHANGES IN
BENEFITS REQUIREMENTS AND
EXTENSIONS. EVEN NOW AS THE
PANDEMIC RECEDES EDT THIS PAIN
ONE AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS
IN CLAIMS EVERY WEEK THIS IS A
TREMENDOUS WORKLOAD. RIGHT NOW
OUR PRIMARY FOCUS IS GETTING
CLAIMS PAID. IN THE CALL CENTER
IMPROVING THE CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE. AND COMING FROM
AFTER THE PANEL WILL BE GLAD TO
ANSWER ANY OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS QUESTIONS. SINCE
PRESIDENT. SIGNED THE AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN ON MARCH ELEVENTH
WE HAVE ENSURED THAT MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS CONTINUE TO GET
PAID FEDERAL BENEFITS. EVERY
CALIFORNIA COLLECTING AN
EXISTING FEDERAL PANDEMIC
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE CLAIM
WAS ABLE TO CERTIFY AND RECEIVE
BENEFITS SINCE MARCH. FASTER
THAN OUR INITIAL APRIL TENTH
TARGET. THOSE ARE REGULAR STATE
UNEMPLOYMENT OR FED IT RECEIVED
THE EXTRA THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS
FEDERAL PAYMENT WITHOUT
INTERRUPTION. B. IN UC CLAIMS
HAVE ALSO BEEN MOVED TO THEIR
NEW EXTENSIONS. CALIFORNIA IS
PROCESSING NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CLAIMS A WEEK MORE THE
SIX MORE THAN THE SECOND AND
THIRD LARGEST STATES FLORIDA
AND TEXAS UNBIND. DESPITE THE
MASSIVE WORKLOAD INCREASE IN
TWENTY TWENTY WE MADE PROGRESS
IN SEVERAL AREAS. BY THE END OF
JANUARY WE LIQUIDATED THE ONE
POINT EIGHT ONE POINT SIX
MILLION CLAIMS BACKLOG
IDENTIFIED BY THE STRIKE TEAM
IN SEPTEMBER. WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED TEXT MESSAGING
NOTIFICATIONS AND DOCUMENT
UPLOAD TO ALLOW FOR BETTER
COMMUNICATION AND IMPROVE
SERVICE OFFERINGS TO CLAIMS. WE
ARE IMPLEMENTING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE STRIKE
TEAM AND THE STATE AUDITOR. WE
LAUNCHED A NEW DATA DASHBOARD
ON OUR WEBSITE SO THAT WHAT WE
ARE DOING CAN BE TRANSPARENT.
WE ARE NOW IN THE PROCESS OF
REDESIGNING OUR I. T. SYSTEM
USING THE BEST INFORMATION FROM
THE BENEFIT SYSTEMS
MODERNIZATION PROJECT. THE
LESSONS THAT WE AND THE OTHER
STATES LEARNED DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND NEW SOFTWARE THAT
MAY HAVE BECOME AVAILABLE SINCE
WE STARTED THE B. S. M. PROJECT.
THE BACKLOG OF CLAIMS PENDING
DEPARTMENT ACTION. LONGER THAN
THREE WEEKS IS CURRENTLY ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHT. WELL
THIS HAS FALLEN OVER 3435%
SINCE FEBRUARY IT'S CLEARLY NOT
ENOUGH AND I'M SURE THAT YOUR
STAFF HAS LET YOU KNOW THAT.
EACH OF THESE FEDERAL
EXTENSIONS NECESSITATES A NEW
EDUCATION CAMPAIGN TO HELP
CLAIMANTS AND CLEAN PROCESSORS
TO UNDERSTAND THE NEW
REQUIREMENTS. FOR EXAMPLE IF
YOU HAVE A REGULAR STATE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE YOU MUST
FILE A CLAIM WHEN YOU'RE
BENEFIT YEAR CANS THIS IS
RESULTED IN A SURGE. BUT IF YOU
HAVE. ENDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE YOU DON'T HAVE TO
FILE A NEW CLAIM. COMMUTING
COMMUNICATING THAT DIFFERENCE
TO MILLIONS OF PEOPLE IS A
CHALLENGE. IT REQUIRES
DEVELOPING NEW MATERIALS TO
HELP PEOPLE DETERMINE WHAT TYPE
OF CLAIM THERE ARE NONE AND
WHAT IF ANYTHING THEY MUST DO
NEXT. WE KNOW THAT THE PROGRAMS
ARE COMPLICATED AND WE KNOW HOW
FRUSTRATING THAT HISTORICALLY.
SO WE CONDUCT PUBLIC OUTREACH
AS A RESULT OF THAT OUTREACH
THERE WERE FIVE MILLION VISITS
TO OUR WEB PAGE TO CLARIFY THE
END OF THE BENEFIT YOUR
PROCESS. WE HAVE DEVELOPED MORE
VIDEOS TO HELP. OUR ASK ANY
YOUTUBE VIDEO ON THE BENEFIT
YEAR AND HAS HAD OVER A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTEEN THOUSAND REVIEWS
IN THE LAST FOUR WEEKS SINCE IT
WAS POSTED. WE ALSO CONDUCT
ADDITIONAL OUTREACH VIA
MESSAGES AND EMAILS TO
CLAIMANTS WHOSE BENEFIT YEAR
EXPIRED BUT THEY HAVEN'T RE
APPLY. WE'RE CONDUCTING
OUTREACH PROVIDE GUIDANCE THAT
HELPS CLAIMS ACCURATELY COULD
ANSWER THEIR CONTINUED CLAIM
FORMS IN BOTH ENGLISH AND
SPANISH. WE ARE AWARE THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE OFFICES HAVE
EXPERIENCED A SURGE OF CLAIMS.
AND WE HAVE ADDED AN ADDITIONAL
ADDED ADDITIONAL YOU ARE STAFF
TO WORK ON THE LEGISLATIVE
REFERRALS WE HAVE REDIRECTED A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE ALREADY
TRAINED STAFF FROM OTHER
BRANCHES OF THE DEPARTMENT. TO
BACK FILL BEHIND THEM AND
ASSIST WITH CLAIMS. THIS MEANS
THAT MORE STAFF IS WORKING ON
THE CLAIMS THAT YOUR STAFF. IS
HAS REFERRED YOUR LIAISON.
WE'RE MONITORING THIS WORKLOAD
AND WE'RE GOING TO ADJUST STAFF
TO ENSURE YOUR OFFICES WE SEEM
RESOLUTION ON THESE CASES.
THESE STATISTICS AND SERVICE
IMPROVEMENTS ARE SIGNIFICANT.
BUT THEY DON'T OFFER MUCH
COMFORT TO CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
WAITING FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
GET THE BENEFITS. DDD WE KNOW
THAT EVERY CLIMATE MATTERS. WE
CONTINUE TO PUT INTENSIVE FOCUS
DOING WHAT IT TAKES TO GET
ELIGIBLE CLAIMANTS PAID. AND
WE'RE DOING THIS AS WE FACE THE
COMPLICATIONS POSED BY
IMPLEMENTING THESE WELCOME NEW
FEDERAL PROGRAMS. A KEY AREA OF
MY FOCUS HAS BEEN THE EDG CALL
CENTER OPERATIONS. THE
CHALLENGE WITH THE CALL CENTER
IS RELATED TO THE SPEED OF
PAYMENT. IT'S OBVIOUS BUT WORTH
MAKING EXPLICIT. THE FASTER WE
PAY BENEFITS THE FEWER CALLS
CLAIMANTS NEED TO MAKE. MOST
CALLERS ARE ASKING ABOUT AN
EXISTING CLAIM. AS CLAIMS TO
GET RESOLVED THE CALL STUFF
THAT'S WHY IN JANUARY WE
STARTED TO BRING ON HUNDREDS OF
MORE PERMANENT STATE STAFF WHO
COULD PROCESS CLAIMS TO GET.
ELIGIBLE PEOPLE PAID. BECAUSE
OF THE COMPLEXITY OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE CODE
STATES AROUND THE COUNTRY
COUNTRY ARE UNANIMOUS IN
SAYING. THAT IT TAKES ABOUT SIX
TO EIGHT MONTHS TO TRAIN NEW
CLAIM AGENTS. WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO REDUCE THAT TO ABOUT FOUR
MONTHS. THAT'S AS EFFICIENT AS
WE CAN MAKE IT WHILE ENSURING
HIGH QUALITY SKILLS. STILL HELP
REPUBLICAN OPERATIONS IS
HELPING TO REDUCE SOME OF THE
CALL CENTER PRESSURE. WE
MONITOR A VARIETY OF SOURCES
ARE COMMON QUESTIONS IN AREAS
OF PUBLIC CONFUSION. AND WE
ADDRESS THEM WITH BETTER PUBLIC
INFORMATION. OVER THE LAST FIVE
WEEKS THE CALL CENTER. HAS
RECEIVED NEARLY TWENTY MILLION
CALL IT CAPS WHICH IS OVER A
53% DROP FROM THE SAME PERIOD
LAST YEAR. STILL THE AVERAGE OF
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY CALLS
CALL ATTEMPTS PER DAY IS MORE
THAN THE CALL CENTER CAN HANDLE
EVEN WHEN IT IS RUNNING TWELVE
HOURS A DAY. SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
DOES THAT MEAN I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND. THOSE TWENTY
MILLION CALLS WERE MADE BY ONE
POINT NINE MILLION PEOPLE. I
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT OUR CALL
CENTER. AND AT ANSWER ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION OF THOSE CALLS OR
70% I KNOW SOMETIMES YOU SEE IN
THE NEWSPAPER LASSEN EXAMPLE
TWENTY MINUTES TWENTY MILLION
CALLS AND DATA ONLY 7% WERE
ANSWERED BUT- THIS IS
DIFFERENT. THESE ARE THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE CALLING.
WE'VE ADDED MORE ONLINE SELF
SERVICE OPTIONS TO HELP PEOPLE
AVOID HAVING TO CALL AT ALL. WE
ALSO IDENTIFY TOP PLACEMENT
QUESTIONS AND PROVIDE
RESPONSIVE INFORMATION WEEKLY
ON OUR WEBSITE OUR GENERAL
MEDIA SOCIAL MEDIA AND EXPANDED
STAKEHOLDER OUTREACH. EARLIER
THIS YEAR I INVOICE THIS
COMMITTEE. THAT MANY OF THE
FEATURES OF THE CALL CENTER
WERE DISABLED WHEN WE ARE SENT
PEOPLE HOME IN AN EFFORT TO OF
COURSE COMBAT THAT. OKAY TWO
WEEKS AGO SO WE'RE WHAT WE'RE
DOING NOW IS WE'RE WE
IMPLEMENTING SOME OF THOSE
FEATURES TWO WEEKS AGO WE
LAUNCHED A VIRTUAL HOLD FEATURE
ON A LIMITED BASIS THAT ALLOWS
CALLERS TO HOLD THEIR PLACE IN
LINE AND HAVE THE DEPARTMENT
CALL THEM BACK. WE ARE PILOTING
OUR SPANISH LANGUAGE LINE NOW
AND- OUR INTENTION IS TO
RELIEVE CLAIMANTS OF HAVING TO
CALL MULTIPLE TIMES ARE TO BE
FRUSTRATED BY HAVING TO WAIT ON
THE PHONE. ONE OF OUR TOP GOALS
IS TO CREATE A MULTI LINGUAL
TRANSLATION AND INTERPRETER
SERVICES HELP LIMITED
PROFICIENT CLAIMANTS. BETTER
ACCESS OUR BENEFIT PROGRAMS
RIGHT NOW. WE ARE INVESTING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN LANGUAGE
INTERPRETER SERVICES FOR OUR
CALL CENTER TO PRESERVE
CLAIMANTS IN POTENTIALLY
HUNDREDS OF LANGUAGES WE NOW
HAVE DEDICATED PHONE LINES IN
ENGLISH SPANISH CANTONESE
MANDARIN AND VIETNAMESE. THIS
WILL BE OUR FOR OUR FUTURE
EFFORTS WILL INCLUDE A MULTI
LINGUAL ACCESS PORTAL AND OTHER
NEW ELLIE P. SERVICES. WE HAVE
TO REACH OUT TO DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
WITH INVESTMENT PUBLIC OUTREACH
AND PARTNERSHIPS WITH
SPECIALIZED LOCAL AND IN
LANGUAGE MEDIA. FINALLY WE
RECOGNIZE THAT MANY
CALIFORNIANS DO NOT HAVE ACCESS
OR THE ABILITY TO USE THE
INTERNET WHEN WE CAN TALK
CONTINUE TO TALK TO COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS TO FIND BETTER
WAYS TO SERVE THOSE PEOPLE.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT RIGHT NOW.
LAST YEAR WE TOOK STEPS TO
ENHANCE OUR FRAUD PREVENTION
AND DETECTION. AND TO ADDRESS
THE UNPRECEDENTED IMPOSTOR
FRAUD SEEN HERE GONNA TRY TO
IVORY NOW. THE CRIMINAL SCHEMES
MOVED TO OTHER STATES WITH
WEAKER FRIED FILTERS ALTHOUGH
WE ARE STILL INTERCEPTING
FRAUDULENT ATTEMPTS REGULARLY.
WE LUNCHED IDENTIFICATION
IDENTITY VERIFICATION AND
ROBUST FRONT FILTERS TO CHECK
CLAIMING INFORMATION AGAINST A
DATABASE OF THOMSON REUTERS TO
PROTECT FROM THIS CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY. NEW EFFORTS TO CURB
FRAUD SUCH A STRONGER IDENTITY
VERIFICATION WITH ID ME HAVE
ADDED ANOTHER LAYER OF REVIEW.
THIS NEW MEASURE HAS STOPPED
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
POTENTIAL FRAUD. HOWEVER WE
HAVE NOT YET STRUCK THE BALANCE
WE NEED BETWEEN SECURITY AND
SPEED. SO WE ARE NOW WE FIND IN
OUR FRAUD FILTERS SO THAT
LEGITIMATE CLAIMS ARE NOT
CAUGHT UP OR DELAYED BECAUSE OF
OUR FRAUD PREVENTION EFFORTS.
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT NATIONALLY
UP 235% OFCLAIMS LAST YEAR
WERE FRAUDULENT. WE INTEND TO
HOLD THOSE HI ANGELA CLEMENTS
ACCOUNTABLE OUR INVESTIGATIONS
UNIT CONTINUES TO PROVIDE
VALUABLE LEADS AND EVIDENCE TO
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
INVESTIGATORS AND PROSECUTORS
WE ARE SEEING A RISING TIDE OF
SEARCH WARRANTS ARRESTS
PROSECUTIONS AND CONVICTIONS.
THE WEEK BEFORE LAST THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES ANNOUNCED
THAT THE STATE TASK FORCE ON
PANDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE FUNDS HAS LED TO THE
ARREST OF SIXTY EIGHT SUSPECTS.
OPENED ONE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
AND FORTY ONE ADDITIONAL
INVESTIGATIONS AND THIS WILL
CONTINUE TO RAMP UP. WE HAVE
BUILT STRONG PARTNERSHIPS WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO SHARE DATA
WITH OTHER JURISDICTIONS TO
HELP CATCH MULTISTATE
FRAUDSTERS. WE ARE COST CROSS
REFERENCE THE DATA GETS LAW
ENFORCEMENT RECORDS SUSPENDED
MULTIPLE CLAIMS FROM SINGLE
ADDRESSES FOR FURTHER
INVESTIGATION AND WE HAVE
IMPLEMENTED THE STATE AUDITOR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO HAVE A FRONT
ORGANIZATION THAT COORDINATES
ALL FRAUD PREVENTION. AND
DETECTION EFFORTS ACROSS THE
DEPARTMENT. WE ARE COMMITTED TO
HELPING VICTIMS OF IDENTITY
FRAUD WE KNOW CRIMINALS USE
STOLEN REAL IDENTITIES BACK
FROM THE DARK WEB TO FILE
FRAUDULENT CLAIMS. IN RESPONSE
WE ARE CONTINUALLY REACHING OUT
TO THE PUBLIC ON HOW TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AGAINST IDENTITY
THEFT. WE ALSO HELP PEOPLE WHO
RECEIVE TEN NINETY NINE G.
SHOWING FORMS SHOWING
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS THEY DID
NOT SEEK. HOWEVER AS I SAID OUR
FRAUD FILLED FILTERS HAVE ONE
WOULD BE ONLY SWEPT UP
LEGITIMATE CLAIMANTS SO THAT'S
THE REASON THAT WERE RISKS OF
REASSESSING OUR FILTERS. IN
CLOSING THE FOCUS OF THE
PENDANT SINCE THE FOCUS SINCE
THE PANDEMIC BEGAN EDT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN TO DO WHAT IS BEST
FOR CLAIMS. DURING THE WORST
YEAR OF THE RECESSION AS I SAID
THERE WERE THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
CLAIMS FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS. THERE HAVE BEEN
TWENTY TWO MILLION CLAIMS IN
THIS PANDEMIC. THE WORK THE
VALUE OF WORK IS STAGGERING.
DURING THAT SAME TIME THE
ENTIRE EDG WORKFORCE WAS MOVING
TO REMOTE TO REDUCE THE SPREAD
OF THE CORONAVIRUS. MASS HIRING
WE DIRECTED WORKERS FROM OTHER
FROM FROM WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
AND FROM OTHER DEPARTMENTS.
CONTINUED STAFFING UP AND THE
USE OF BENDERS HAVE ALL PLAYED
A PART OF THE EFFORT TO RESPOND
TO THE HISTORIC DEMANDS FOR
BENEFITS DURING AN
UNPRECEDENTED YEAH SURE
LANGUAGES. DESPITE THOSE
DISRUPTIONS WE HAVE MANAGED TO
PAY OVER A HUNDRED AND FORTY
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
BENEFITS. WE HAVE HANDLED MAJOR
PROBLEMS. THE ELIMINATION OF
THE ONE POINT SIX BACKLOG OF
CLAIMS. OPENING THE CALL CENTER
TO RUN TWELVE DAYS TWELVE HOURS
A DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK HIRING
HUNDREDS OF NEW STATE WORKERS
AND LAUNCHING NO. IDENTITY
VERIFICATION TO PREVENT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FIVE.
NOW THERE ARE NEW CHALLENGES
PROCESS THE NEW CLAIMS AS
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE REACH THE
END OF THE YEAR RECEIVING
BENEFITS. INTEGRATION OF NEW
VERIFICATION PROCEDURES
REDUCING THE BACKLOG OF A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHT CLAIMS AND
WORKING WITH PROSECUTORS TO
HOLD SOPHISTICATED FRAUDSTERS
FROM LAST YEAR ACCOUNTABLE. WE
HAVE A SOLID ROAD MAP FROM THE
STRIKE TEAM AND THE AUDITOR AND
WE'RE PUTTING THOSE CHANGES IN
PLACE. I WANT TO THANK
LEGISLATORS WHO IN SO MANY WAYS
HAVE CONSISTENTLY OFFERED ME.
AND THE DEPARTMENT HELP AND
ADVICE AND TO THEIR STAFF. WHO
HAVE SERVED OUR CLIENTS WHO ARE
THEIR CONSTITUENTS. FINALLY
MANY THANKS TO OUR MAGNIFICENT
STAFF WHO HAVE STEPPED UP FROM
OTHER PARTS OF THE G. D. TO
RESPOND TO THIS EMERGENCY. I AM
HOPING THAT THIS HEARING
RESULTS IN A CONSTRUCTIVE
DIALOGUE IN A WELCOME ANY NEW
IDEAS OFFERED BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR SIGNS OF WE WANT TO
MOVE ON TO THE STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BOB
HARRIS AND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE
ANNOUNCED THE PROJECT MANAGER
ON OUR TWO MOST RECENT AUDITS
IF EDG- TODAY I'LL PROVIDE THE
COMMITTEE WITH AN OVERVIEW OF
EDIE'S PROGRESS IN ADDRESSING
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE
MADE COMING OUT OF THOSE TWO
REFUSE. TO STARTED LIKE TO
DIRECT THE COMMITTEE'S
ATTENTION TO A DOCUMENT WE
PROVIDED- THIS DOCUMENT IS A
PRETTY COMPREHENSIVE OVERVIEW
OF ETP'S PROGRESS THUS FAR
WE'VE ASSESSED ALL OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE NEED TO
DO AND WHERE HE'S AT AND THAT'S
PROGRESS- IN THAT DOCUMENT
GIVES YOU A STATUS FOR EACH
RECOMMENDATION EVEN SOME I
WON'T GO INTO DETAIL ABOUT MY
TESTIMONY TODAY. IT ALSO GIVES
YOU ON THE LAST PAGE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE LEGISLATIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE AND
THEN FINALLY PROVIDES IN GREEN
HIGHLIGHTING AN INDICATION
WHENEVER A STRIKE TEAM
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
GOVERNOR STRIKE TEAM- FROM
SEPTEMBER OVERLAPS OR IS
COMPLEMENTARY TO OUR
RECOMMENDATION WE MADE DVD SO
HOPEFULLY THAT'S A VALUABLE
RESOURCE FOR. THE COMMITTEE.
I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU AN
OVERVIEW OF THE DVDS PROGRESS
AND THROUGH A FEW DIFFERENT
LENSES THE FIRST IS WHERE EDS
MADE SIGNIFICANT POSITIVE
PROGRESS. YOU'LL PROBABLY KNOW
THAT OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
INCLUDE TIMELINES WHERE WE
EXPECTED EDT SHOULD HAVE
COMPLETED CERTAIN ACTIVITIES-
AND WITH RESPECT TO THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE WHERE
OUR EXPECTATION WAS THAT YOU
DID YOU WOULD HAVE ALREADY
ACHIEVED FULL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS BY THIS
POINT IN TIME IN THE CALENDAR.
THEY HAVE DONE SO THEY'VE AT
LEAST FULLY OR OR PARTIALLY
IMPLEMENTED THE MAJORITY OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WE EXPECTED
THEY WOULD ACHIEVE BY NOW SO
THAT'S GOOD PROGRESS THAT
THEY'VE MADE. AS THE DIRECTOR
MENTIONED A FREE RICK REFRESH
THEIR WEBPAGE TO PROVIDE A MORE
CLEAR PICTURE OF THE BACKLOG OF
CLAIMS. THAT REQUIRE YOU TO D.
ACTION. THEY ALSO AT FEATURES
TO THEIR CALL CENTER THIS NEED
TO SURE THAT BACKS IS A- AND
LET. OTHER THAN ENGLISH IS
STILL A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO PROVIDE A BETTER
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE. I WANT TO
TAKE PARTICULAR TIME TO KNOW
EDIE'S PROGRESS AND HELPING
VICTIMS OF IDENTITY THEFT WE
SAW DURING THE PANDEMIC PERIOD.
THE PEOPLE'S IDENTITIES WERE
STOLEN AND THE FRAUDSTERS USE
THOSE IDENTITIES TO FILE FALSE
UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIMS.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT LEAVES THE
VICTIM OF IDENTITY THEFT WITH
THE TAX LIABILITY. EDT CAN HELP
THOSE VICTIMS- CLEAR THAT TAX
LIABILITY BUT THEY NEED AN
AVAILABLE RESOURCE AT U. D. D.
TO CONTACT DVD ENTERTAINMENT
ASSISTANCE THAT'S WHY WE
RECOMMENDED ET DE SET UP A
DEDICATED LINE. TO COMMUNICATE
WITH THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND
INEFFICIENT PROCESS WITH THE
RIGHT KIND OF STAFFING TO
PROCESS THAT WORKLOAD. WE CAN
SAY THAT FOR RIGHT NOW EASIEST
ON ALL OF THOSE THINGS NOW
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO PAY ATTENTION TO
THAT WORKLOAD OVER TIME AS IT
MIGHT FLUCTUATE IN THE COMING
MONTHS BUT WE ARE. SAYING THAT
FOR NOW THEY FULLY IMPLEMENTED
THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN THAT
VERY IMPORTANT AREA. SO THAT'S
GOOD PROGRESS THAT HE'S MAKING.
ACCORDING TO THE TIMELINE THAT
WE EXPECTED IT TO.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE ALSO A
COUPLE KEY AREAS I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT WHERE EDT IS NOT ON
TRACK WITH WHERE WE EXPECTED
THEM TO BE BY NOW IN THOSE TWO
AREAS THAT I'LL HIGHLIGHT FOR
THE COMMITTEE OR IN THE AREA OF
WORKFORCE AND WORKLOAD PLANNING.
AND THEN- THE CREATION OF A
FRAUD- UNIT. FIRST ON WORKFORCE
AND WORKLOAD PLANNING SO DURING
OUR AUDIT WE FOUND SOME
CONCERNS RELATED TO HOW EASY
WAS ANTICIPATING. UPCOMING
WORKLOAD- WE SAW THAT IT WAS
TRYING TO ANTICIPATED UPCOMING
WORKLOAD. BASED ESSENTIALLY ON
HISTORICAL DATA. NOT ON. A
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF CLAIMS THAT
ARE COMING OVER THE PAST FEW
WEEKS BUT THAT UNFORTUNATELY.
ISN'T ALWAYS THE CASE SOMETIMES
THE WORKLOAD WILL INCREASE-
BASED ON SEASONAL FLUCTUATION
OR OTHER ECONOMIC INDICATORS SO
WE WERE REALLY LOOKING FOR EDT
TO DEVELOP A BETTER WORKLOAD
PROJECTION MODEL. AND THAT'S AN
AREA WHERE THEY STILL HAVEN'T
MADE. SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS.
SECONDARILY WE HAD CONCERNS
ABOUT AN AMPLE LARGE IMPENDING
WORKLOAD THAT YOU DO IS ALSO
GOING TO NEED TO MANAGE WHILE
IT SIMULTANEOUSLY ENSURE THAT
IT CONTINUED TO PAY TIMELY
BENEFITS. AND THAT IS THE
DEFERRED WORK THAT UNITY WAS
NOT PERFORMING DURING THE HEART
AT THAT PART OF THE PANDEMIC
PERIOD. BUT FOR WHICH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NOW EXPECTS
YOU NEEDED TO GO BACK AND
COMPLETE THAT'S A VERY LARGE
WORKLOAD WE WERE CONCERNED THAT
WITHOUT A VERY. STRUCTURED AND
RISK BASED PLAN FOR HOW YOU DO
THE WOULD. ADDRESS THAT
WORKLOAD IT WAS GOING TO
STRUGGLE TO ADEQUATELY OR
OPTIMALLY BALANCED IT'S
COMPETING OBLIGATIONS. WITH
RESPECT TO ALL THESE DIFFERENT
WORKLOADS. THEY NEED TO HAVE A
FIRM PLAN IN PLACE FOR HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO EFFECTIVELY
MANAGE THEIR STAFF. AND ALL OF
THESE IMPENDING WORKLOADS AND
THAT'S AN AREA WHERE WE STILL
WANT TO SEE MORE PROGRESS FROM
EDT. I MENTIONED ALSO THE
COMPLETION OF A FRAUD UNIT IS
AN AREA WHERE WE DON'T FEEL
LIKE EATING HE'S MADE ADEQUATE
PROGRESS AND RESPECTFULLY. WE
DO NOT AGREE THAT EDIE HAS
IMPLEMENTED THE RECOMMENDATION
TO CREATE A DEDICATED UNIT
FULLY RESPONSIBLE FOR MANAGING
ITS FRAUD PREVENTION APPROACH.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT BEST
PRACTICES WITH THE JUST EIGHTY
SHOULD DO WHAT WE FOUND WHEN WE
WERE DOING OUR AUDIT WAS A
FRAGMENTED APPROACH WHERE
VARIOUS UNITS. NEEDED TO
COORDINATE WITH ONE ANOTHER AND
SOMETIMES DIDN'T DO SO
EFFECTIVELY. WE CAN SEE THAT
EDT HAS TAKEN. SOME STEPS
TOWARDS CREATING THAT KIND OF
YOU KNOW. THEY. COMMITTEE MIGHT
HAVE THERE ARE KEY
RECOMMENDATIONS WE'VE MADE FOR
WHICH THE TIME LINES THE
EXPECTED DEADLINES HAVE NOT YET
COME TO PASS BUT ARE STILL VERY
IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO FOLLOW
THROUGH WITH THERE ARE
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED BETTER
CALL CENTER MANAGEMENT AND
ALSO- INCREASED AUTOMATION OF
CLAIM PROCESSING WHERE WE'D
HAVE MADE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
EDT- AND THEY HAVE NOT
INDICATED YET THAT THEY'RE DONE
WITH THEM OR DO WE AGREE THERE
IF THEY'RE DONE YET WITH
IMPLEMENTING THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS SO. STILL A LOT
OF IMPORTANT WORK YET TO COME
AND WITH THAT I'LL TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MASS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS. MORNING ON
THIS IS MARK AND THEN AS WITH
THE FROM THE FINANCE NO
COMMENTS BUT I AM AVAILABLE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU SENATOR
THANK YOU- AND NOW COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. IT CENTER GROW AND
THEN SENATOR NEWMAN. RIGHT OKAY
I WILL BE FAST SO I JUST DIRECT
SIGNS- I JUST WANTED TO COMMEND
YOU INTO THANK YOU- AND DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FERRIES FOR MAKING
YOURSELF SO AVAILABLE NOT JUST
TO THIS COMMITTEE BUT TO THE
VARIOUS OTHER COMMITTEES AND
GROUPS THAT HAVE BEEN MEETING
OF THE PANDEMIC INCLUDING MY
WORKING GROUP EVERY TWO WEEKS-
ANSWERED NO QUESTION THIS IS AN
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGE I DON'T
THINK YOU'VE RISEN TO THE
MOMENT FOR YOU COMING IN LATE-
IN A WAY THAT'S IMPRESSIVE- AND
I AM HOPEFUL- THAT THE WORK
WILL CONTINUE TO PREPARE FOR
THE NEXT. AT RISK RESUME BE
ECONOMIC AND THAT WE WILL NOT
ZERO SO THIS POSITION GOING TO
THE JOYSTICK COMMENT YOU THANK
YOU SENATE I'M THINKING MADAM
CHAIR DIRECTOR SCENTED STEP A
PLACE TO C. AGAIN- I REMEMBER
COME FROM. HEARING JUST AND-
I'LL SAY THE SAME THING TODAY
IS I DID BACK THEN- YOU HAVE
WALKED INTO A HORNET'S NEST I
AM VERY- PLEASE THAT YOUR
PROBLEM SOLVING SOLUTIONS ARE
BEING APPLIED TO THE PROBLEMS
THAT WE HAVE EDDIE EDT NOW- ALL
THAT SAID I KNOW THAT EDIE'S
TAKEN STEPS TO IMPROVE. AND I
AND- WITH THE AUDIT REPORT OF
THE CURRENT- THAT. CHANGES THAT
ARE BEING MADE I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT UPDATE AND- AND
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE GOOD
PEOPLE WORKING- REALLY HARD-
FROM ALL AREAS OF THE STATE
THAT- LANDED A POSITION AT EDT.
TO HELP US GET THROUGH THIS
PROCESS- BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THINGS- I
DON'T WANNA SAY ARE GETTING FAT
DONE FAST ENOUGH BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU'RE DOING YOUR BEST BET IT
SEEMS LIKE TO ME BASED ON WHAT
CALMATTERS IS REPORTING IN THE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE ACCESS
TO. IS THAT THE BACKLOG IS
ACTUALLY GROWING LARGER. AND
THAT THERE ARE MORE PENDING
CLAIMS- NOW THAT OUR AND
RESOLVED THEN THERE WERE A AS
OF MAY EIGHTH I GUESS AS A MATE
THEY WERE 1-009-500-0500 EIGHTY
FIVE BACKLOG OF CLAIMS. WHICH
IS THE TWENTY ONE DAYS EDT
ACTION- AND THE NUMBER BEFORE
THAT WAS NINE HUNDRED AND NINE.
THOUSAND CLAIMANTS
CERTIFICATIONS- IN CLAIMS S. I
KNOW YOU'VE GIVEN A SAID A LONG
LINK FLEA EXPLANATION OF. HOW
WE'RE CLEARING UP THE BACKLOG.
AND I AGAIN I RECOGNIZE THE MAN
THAT DIRECTOR THAT YOU WALKED
INTO WHAT I WOULD CALL A
HORNET'S NEST AND- I APPLAUD
YOU FOR TAKING ON THIS
HUMONGOUS CHALLENGE TO FIX. A
BIT IT SEEMS LIKE EVERYTHING
THAT'S HAPPENING IS ACTUALLY
INCREASING THE BACKLOG CAN YOU
ADDRESS THAT FOR ME. PLEASE.
WELL LET ME OUR FIRST SAY THAT-
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT WE'VE
PUT IN A NEW DASHBOARD IS THAT
PEOPLE DID NOT UNDERSTAND THE
PREVIOUS DASH DASH BOARD.
NUMBER NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND.
IS NOT HAVE TO DO. WITH THE
WORK THAT EDG. IS DOING. WHAT
IT HAS TO DO WITH AN IS THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THE CLAIMANTS
WHO HAVE TO COME INTO THE
DEPARTMENT AND RECERTIFY. YOUR
ELIGIBILITY. SO ARE I'M GLAD
YOU BROUGHT THAT UP BECAUSE HE
GIVES ME A CHANCE TO CLARIFY
THAT. WE'RE NOT SURPRISED THAT
WE HAVE MORE WORK RIGHT NOW- WE
HAVE INSTITUTED THESE TWO MAJOR
NEW FEDERAL PROGRAMS. YOU'RE
NOT ALWAYS EASY FOR OUR CLIENTS
TO UNDERSTAND. SO OFTEN THEY
MAKE MISTAKES IN THEIR
APPLICATIONS AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS. IS WORKING WITH THOSE
PEOPLE NOW NOW SO WHAT WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED BASICALLY IS A
SURGE IN APPLICATIONS AND- IT'S
TAKING US SOME TIME TO KEEP UP
WITH HIM. BUT I WILL LET ANY OF
MY COLLEAGUES- OFFER SOMETHING
MORE SPECIFIC THAN THAT AND I
WANT TO SAY- ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
THAT I REALLY DO OF. YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE
DIFFICULTIES THAT WERE IN. WE
ARE NOT SATISFIED WITH THE WAY
THINGS ARE GOING YET YEARS ARE
ALL IMPROVEMENTS THINGS ARE
GETTING BETTER. BUT AS I SAID
THAT THE WORKLOAD IS STAGGERING
AND- WE'RE LOOKING FOR EVERY
SINGLE OPPORTUNITY PEOPLE ARE
DOING THIS DALY BOTH THAT RANK
AND FILE STAFF THE MANAGERS OF
THE EXECUTIVES- SO FAR THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN THAT
REGARD AND- I'LL HAVE MY
COLLEAGUES ANSWER ANY. DETAILED
QUESTIONS ON THERE. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR CONSIST CAROL WILLIAMS
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS AND I'LL BE BRIEF
BUT WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE CLEAR WITH
YOU AND TO BE CLEAR WITH THE
MEDIA OUTLETS YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT. THE BACKLOG IS
INCREASING AND I'LL TOUCH ON
THAT THE CURRENT BACKLOG FOR
EDIE DAY'S WORK OVER IT THAT IS
PENDING OVER TWENTY ONE DAYS
AND THIS IS ON THE NEW
DASHBOARD DELIVERED BY WAY OF
THE CSA RECOMMENDATION AS WELL
AS DISTRACTING. IS A HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND CLAIMS
YOU'RE CORRECT THE PRIOR WEEK.
THE BACKLOG WAS A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SIX THOUSAND PRIOR TO
THAT THE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND CLAIMS. FULL
TRANSPARENCY. THE READ. THE
REASON- THE INCREASE IS
OCCURRING IS AS THE DIRECTOR
HAS JUST- ADDRESSED ONE THERE
IS- A LOT OF WORK GOING ON WITH
THE BENEFIT YEAR ENDING BUT
WHAT THIS BACKLOG IS. OVER 95%
OF THE BACKLOG FOR EDIE'S WORK
HAS TO DO WITH DETERMINATIONS.
AS MOST OF YOUR WERE ALL OF
YOUR WHERE BEGINNING IN JANUARY
EDT RESOUND DETERMINATIONS AND
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE CLAIMS TO ENSURE THAT THE
CLAIMANT IS ACTUALLY ELIGIBLE.
BEGAN THAT WORK AND BECAUSE OF
HOW THE QUESTIONS ARE BEING OUT
BECAUSE OF HOW THE ANSWERS OR
THE CLAIMANTS ARE RESPONDING
THIS WORK IS COMPOUNDING THAT
THE ET DE STAFF MUST HANDLE.
INDIVIDUALLY WE'RE LOOKING AT
FULL AUTOMATION FOR ANYTHING
THAT WE CAN AUTOMATE REGARDING
THE CLAIMANT'S- THAT THE WAY
THAT THEY'VE RESPONDED IN THEIR
ANSWERS. AB BUT THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT VOLUME THAT WE MUST
ACTUALLY OBTAINED INFORMATION
FROM THE CLIENT AND SO THAT IS
WHERE THE BACKLOG IS INCREASING
BUT IS. COUPLED WITH US BEING
MORE CLEAR ON HOW THE QUESTIONS
ARE ASKED AND WHAT THE
RESPONSES WILL- WHAT WILL OCCUR
DEPENDING ON HOW THEY RESPOND
TO THE ANSWERS. ON OUR WEBSITE
IN ACTUALLY ON THEIR
CERTIFICATION FORMS SO IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT. CENTER
GROVE THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT- RESPONSE
AND AGAIN DIRECTOR SIGNS I
APPLAUD YOU FOR TAKING ON THIS
ROLE I WANT TO MOVE TO SOME
QUESTIONS ON THE FRAUD
PREVENTION AND I APPRECIATE
YOU- DOING WHAT YOU'RE DOING
NOW TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CORRECT INFORMATION IS-
AVAILABLE WHEN APPLICANTS TO
APPLY FOR THESE BENEFITS- I
WANT TO MOVE TO THE FRAUD PART
OF IT I DO REALIZE THAT THERE
IS A DELICATE BALANCE TO. A
STOP AND INTENDED INDIVIDUALS
FROM GETTING BENEFITS- LIKE FOR
INSTANCE THE COUPLE ANDERSON
CARTY WHO WERE- VESTED BY
POLICE OFFICERS THEY FOUND OUT
THAT THEY READ AND- WELL LET'S
SEE HOW THAT THE THEY WERE
DOING DRUG TRAFFICKING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CREDIT CARD FRAUD
EDT FRAUD AND THEY ESTIMATED
THAT. THEY ACTUALLY APPLIED FOR
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN EDP D. BENEFITS AND WERE
SUCCESSFUL IN WITHDRAWING TWO
POINT THREE EIGHT TWO. MILLION
DOLLARS IN EDT BENEFITS. AND I
DO BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT MAKE A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT
OF MONEY. BUT IS ONE OF THE
FRAUD MECHANISMS THAT YOU HAVE
IS- LOOKING AT CLAIMS MORE
SOPHISTICATED LEE IF FOR- A CAP
I MEAN IF YOU HAVE A REGULAR
CAP. WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
AVERAGE INCOME AND INDIVIDUALS
IN COMMUNITIES THAT. LIKE
RESTAURANTS- A BARTENDER
SERVERS FOR THE HOTEL INDUSTRY
THE HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY. IT
WOULD SET OFF AN ALARM IF
ANYBODY WAS WITHDRAWING-
APPLYING FOR FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN BENEFITS. IS
THERE A CALF A REASONABLE CAP
TO INVESTIGATE ON FRAUD- I MEAN
AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
REASONABLE CAP IS I'M ASSUMING
SOMEBODY MAKES FIFTEEN DOLLARS
AN HOUR YOU KNOW FIFTY TWO
WEEKS FOR THE BENEFIT TO TOTAL
THAT OUT. BUT IF THERE IS
SUBSTANTIAL INDIVIDUALS DURING
YOU KNOW ONE ONE MILLION DOLLAR
CLAIMS PER SE IS THERE A CAP-
ON ANY TYPE OF THE BENEFITS IS
THAT MAKES SENSE NOT A CAP TO
STOP THE BENEFITS BECAUSE
THEY'RE THEY'RE ENTITLED TO IT.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE ENTITLED TO IT
BUT- I MEAN IF SOMEBODY APPLIES
REPORT POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN BENEFITS YOU WOULD
THINK THAT WOULD SET OFF JUST A
LITTLE BIT OF AN ALARM. BEFORE
THEY WERE ABLE TO WITHDRAW TWO
POINT EIGHT THREE TWO MILLION
GOOD GOOD QUESTION AND I THINK.
IT NEEDS TO BE CLARIFIED. WHAT
HAS HAPPENED IS RATHER THAN
ONE. PERSON APPLYING FOR FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN.
BENEFITS WHICH WOULD OBVIOUSLY
SET OFF ALARMS IMMEDIATELY. ALL
HAVE STOLEN IDENTITIES FROM THE
WEB. HAVE CREATED BACKSTORIES
TO THEM AND HAVE APPLIED
MULTIPLE TIMES. THAT'S WHAT HAS
BEEN HAPPENING THAT WAS WHAT
WAS HAPPENING NOW NO ONE GETS
THROUGH WITHOUT GOING TO OUR
FRAGILE TRUCE SO THAT IS NOT
LIKELY TO HAPPEN AGAIN. AND WE
ARE CONTROL WE ARE MONITORING.
ANY ADDRESS IN WHICH MORE THAN
SEVEN PEOPLE ARE APPLYING AND I
BRING THAT UP BECAUSE WE ALSO
HAVE ISSUES WITH SOMETIMES
HOMELESS PEOPLE USING THE
SHELTERS ADDRESS SO WE
INVESTIGATE ALL OF THOSE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
ANOTHER CHANCE TO CLARIFY NO
THANK YOU MA'AM FOR CLARIFYING
THAT SITS I WAS READING THAT
AND I JUST THOUGHT THAT'S
THERE'S GOTTA BE SOME FRAUD
PREVENTION MECHANISMS THAT
WOULD BE AVAILABLE. TO HELP-
REDUCE THAT AND- AND I APPLAUD
YOU FOR THE SEVEN PEOPLE PER
HOUSEHOLD- IN THE BEGINNING OF
THE PANDEMIC I HAD ONE
CONSTITUENT BRING ME OVER A
HUNDRED AND FORTY AM EDT
REPLIES TO THEIR ADDRESS WHICH
WAS NOT THEM APPLYING FOR IT
THAT AND THEY HAD APPLIED THE
INDIVIDUAL EASIER ADDRESS IT
APPLIED FOR BENEFITS. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR PUTTING THOSE
MECHANISM PLACE THE NEXT THING
I'D LIKE TO MOVE TO IS AND THAT
DEBT IN THE U. I FIND YOU HAVE
A CURRENT BALANCE IN THE DEBT-
AND THE WIFE AND. ALL ESTIMATED
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE DEBT IN
THE U. I. FUND IS CURRENTLY AT
TWENTY. BILLION DOLLARS ALL HAS
HIT MY COLLEAGUES WOULD WANT TO
CORRECT ME ON THAT. YOU SEE
BILLION MA'AM. YES OKAY THANK
YOU. YEAH THIS IS KEVIN MILEAGE
FOR YOU TO DATE- THE CURRENT-
LOAN BALANCES AT TWENTY POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLARS. OKAY THANK
YOU IS THERE A IS THERE A PLAN
AN WITHIN THE E. D. DE PART
MENT TO ADDRESS THAT OR IS THAT
JUST GOING TO FALL ON THE FOOD
A TAX REDUCTION CREDIT AND
EMPLOYERS THAT HAVE BEEN
STRUGGLING. TO KEEP THEIR DOORS
OPEN THE PANDEMIC WILL JUST
HAVE TO FOOT THE BILL LIKE THEY
DID- A FEW YEARS AGO OR IS
THERE A PLAN. BY EDG I MEAN I
KNOW YOU WERE I REALIZE THAT
YOU NEED THE LEGISLATURE TO
FUND A PLAN BUT IS THERE A
PLAN. TO ADDRESS THAT DEBT-
OTHER VAN THE FOOD FEDERAL YOU
KNOW THE FUTURE TAX REDUCTION
CREDIT THAT COMES FROM THE
FED'S. AT THIS POINT. OF WHAT
WE HAVE IS THE LAW TO FOLLOW.
AND DRIVEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PROVIDE A LITTLE MORE
INFORMATION ON THAT BUT- WE
HAVE TO FOLLOW CURRENT LAW
RIGHT NOW. YEAH JUST AS YOU SET
ASIDE OR GROW THE- CURRENT
MECHANISM FOR REPAYING A LOAN
AS THOSE FOR THE REDUCTION
CREDITS- THERE IS. YOU KNOW
CURRENTLY NO PROPOSAL ON TO
ADDRESS THE DEFICIT- AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU AND JUST
REFRESH MY MEMORY M. IS IT IS
IT GOING TO BE SIMILAR TO WHAT
HAPPENED LAST TIME WHERE THESE
PAYMENTS WERE JUST DO YOU GOT A
NOTICE JANUARY FIRST AND IF YOU
GET PAID BY THE TENTH WHICH YOU
KNOW SMALL RESTAURANT THEIR
BILL MIGHT BE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. IF THEY
DIDN'T PAY IT BY THE TENTH
THERE WOULD BE A 10% PENALTY
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT EVERY DAY
THAT THEY DIDN'T PAY IT IS THAT
SIMILAR WHAT. TO WHAT HAPPENED
LAST TIME. THE ORDERS WILL
RECEIVE THE NEW TAX BILL AND IN
JANUARY FOR- WHAT THAT WHAT IS
OWED FOR THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE- THAT THOSE SAME
MECHANISMS THAT WERE IN PLACE
FOR THE GREAT RECESSION ARE
STILL IN PLACE- AND I WILL BE
HOW THE- THE LOAN IS PAID BACK.
UNLESS THERE ARE ANY CHANGES TO
THE LAW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SIR FOR ANSWERING THOSE
QUESTIONS THANK YOU- DIRECTOR
SIGNS AGAIN THANK YOU- IT WAS
MY PLAY BRIDGE RIGHT PRIVILEGE
TO. AN INTERVIEW AND TALK TO
AND CONFIRM YOU TO THIS
POSITION AND- I ALMOST FEEL
GUILTY AFTER DOING THAT
CONFIRMATION BECAUSE OF THE
SITUATION THAT YOU ACTUALLY
FIND YOURSELF IN BUT I APPLAUD
YOU FOR TAKING ON THE ROLE. AND
BEING A PROBLEM SOLVER IN THIS
IN THIS ARENA THANK YOU MA'AM.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY. THANK YOU
SENATOR GROVE I THINK THOSE ARE
ALL REALLY SENATOR GREAT THE-
QUESTIONS AND ALSO APPRECIATE
THE- DIRECTOR SIGNS ARE
RESPONSES. FROM. FIFTY YES
SENATOR COURTESY OF THE PERFUME
QUICKLY WITHIN EVERY CRITIC.
I'M NOT SURE THESE ARE QUICK
QUIZ I CAN'T COME TO THE
ANSWERING WILL BE QUICK ON IN
SO YOU GO IT. THEY WERE BOTH
THE NUMBER HERE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MANAGE OF. THIS MAYBE I
CAN JUST LAY OUT MY QUESTIONS A
DOZEN FEEL LIKE A THE DIRECT
EXAM. GOING ON HERE- IN AND-
PERSON DIRECTOR IN IN I THINK
ONE OF THEM IS FOR THE AUDITOR-
YOU KNOW WE- NEARER TO THE
BEGINNING OF THE CALENDAR YEAR
WE HAD THE INFORMATIONAL
HEARING- WE HEARD. THE AUDIT. A
LOT OF US ASK QUESTIONS AND
PART OF WHAT I WANTED TO DO
HERE WAS JUST ON A ON A COUPLE
OF THOSE QUESTIONS YOU KNOW
FOLLOW UP ON. PROGRESS BUT-
MORE THINGS ARE HEARD TODAY WAS
THAT THERE ARE THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION. CLAIMS TOTAL IN JUST
BUT I AM ASSUMING THOSE ARE
UNIQUE. INDIVIDUAL CLAIMS GIVEN
THAT WE ONLY HAVE FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE IN THE STATE- BACK OF
THE ENVELOPE MATH ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT. OUR CHILDREN-
THAT WOULD LEAVE THIRTY MILLION
OF EACH AND EVERY ADULT PERSON
IN THE STATE PUT IN A CLAIM- IN
THE SITE I THANK I'M GUESSING
THAT THAT. HAS SOMETHING TO DO
WITH THE REDUNDANCY OR THE
FRAUD OR- SOMETHING LIKE THAT
IN A NOTE CENTER GROVE WAS
ASKING SOME QUESTIONS AROUND
THAT- BUT THAT WOULD BE ONE OF
MY QUESTIONS JUST WHAT IS IT
THIRTY MILLION REALLY REPRESENT-
IN. IN IN IN THE OTHER QUESTION
IS- JUST ASK NOW YOU CAN
ANSWERING BOTH FROM HIT TO HIT
YOU WITH COMPOUND QUESTIONS
HERE BUT- THEY'RE NOT HARD
QUESTIONS OF. BACK AT THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. YOU TALK
ABOUT HAVING. NINE HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL STAFF BY NOW-
BROUGHT ON TO EITHER TO HELP
WITH THE WHOLE SITUATION
BACKLOG PHONES EVERYTHING IS AS
I UNDERSTOOD IT. HOW DO YOU
KNOW WHAT IS WHAT IS REALLY
THAT THE SITUATION WITH THAT I
HEARD YOU TALKING ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND SOME ODD. HIRES
WHICH IS. GOOD BUT I DIDN'T
HEAR NINE HUNDRED. AND ALSO. A
SOME INFORMATION- A THAT WAS
SHARED WITH WITH MY OFFICE-
THAT'S WHEN THE POLICY
COMMITTEE CHAIRS BY THE BY THE-
OFFICE OF PROTEIN- I THOUGHT
INDICATED THAT SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE CALENDAR YEAR
SINCE AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING
THERE'S ACTUALLY A NET
REDUCTION IN- IN STAFF AND I
MAY BE READING THAT WRONG BUT-
DUE TO ATTRITION WHEN REFERRING
TO IS A TRADITION SO HOUSE
ATTRITION PLAYED INTO. WHERE
YOU STAND NOW IN TERMS OF.
CAPACITY PERSONNEL- HUMAN
RESOURCES. THOSE ARE THE TWO
QUESTIONS FOR THE DIRECTORY YOU-KNOW I TO APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU SENATOR- LET ME ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS IN TWO WAYS. OUR
FIRST WELL WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT TWENTY TWO MILLION CLAIMS
THAT HAVE BEEN PAID OVER THE-
AGE OF THE PANDEMIC TURNER.
THOSE REPRESENT MULTIPLE CLAIMS
BY INDIVIDUALS SO INDEED WE DO
NOT HAVE THIRTY MILLION PEOPLE
APPLYING FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE FELL. AT THE PERIOD
OF TIME THAT PEOPLE CAN APPLY
CAN COVER APPEARED TO TWENTY
SIX WEEKS. WITHIN A YEAR'S OUR
QUALIFICATION PERIOD SO THAT'S
WHAT THE TWENTY TWO MILLION
REPRESENTS. DOES THAT ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION RIGHT SO WE'RE
COUNTING CLAIMS AS THIS EACH
HALF HOUR THE REVIVAL OF THE
CLAIM OF THREE DIFF THE RESERVE
RENEWAL. RIGHT SINCE IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US IN WHAT WE DO
IS WE ARE. DETERMINED THAT
EVERY TWO WEEKS A PERSON WE
CERTIFIERS FOR THEIR CLAIM AND
WE ARE REVIEW THAT TO INSURE
THAT THEY ARE INDEED ARE
AVAILABLE FOR WORK ARE NOT
WORKING ALREADY. AND ASKING FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDS SO YEAH SO
IT'S NOT THREE MILLION IT'S NOT
THE JOB. BACK TWENTY TWO
MILLION PEOPLE- UNDERSTAND WILL
THANK YOU. I'M SORRY SIR I
UNDER THAT WELL ENOUGH AT THE
POINT FOR YOU OKAY ARE A GREAT
HEY YOU ASKED ABOUT HIGHER. SO
ARE MY WHEN I SAID THERE WERE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE PEOPLE I
WAS TALKING ABOUT STAFF THAT WE
HAVE TAKEN FROM OTHER BRANCHES
AND BROUGHT INTO OUR- TO HANDLE
SOME OF THESE ARE LEGISLATIVE
REFERRALS THAT YOUR STAFF. IS
MANAGING. HI THIS IS WE DID
THIS ARE STARTING LAST WEEK.
AND THESE ARE FULLY TRAINED
PEOPLE THEIR PEOPLE WHO CAME
INTO THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
BRANCH. OFF FROM TAX BRANCH OR
FROM A WORK SERVICES BRANCH WHO
ARE ALREADY TRAINED BECAUSE
THEY PARTICIPATED DURING THE
HEIGHT OF THE PANDEMIC. IN OUR
IN REVIEWING CLAIMS. SO THAT'S
NOT A NEW HIRE IT'S A
REDIRECTION. WE CONTINUE TO
HIRE PEOPLE- IN JANUARY WE
BROUGHT CON I THINK SOMEWHERE
IN THE YEAR TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY PEOPLE WHO ARE FULLY
TRAINED. TO BE ON THE PHONES
AND WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
HIRING THOSE NINE HUNDRED
PEOPLE AND IF YOUR OFFICE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THE NUMBERS ON THAT
WOULD BE GLAD TO PROVIDE THEM.
BUT WE HAVEN'T HIRED UP ALL
THOSE PEOPLE YET- THANK YOU I
WOULD I WOULD JUST TELL US IF
YOU COULD DISTRIBUTE THOSE
NUMBERS TO ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OFFICES- AND GENERALLY.
OF THERE'S MORE THAN ONE WHO'S
INTERESTED IN THE SAME
INFORMATION BUT I APPRECIATE
THAT VERY MUCH AND WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THOSE AND WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW HOW WE CAN BE OF
ASSISTANCE I THINK IS- PROBABLY
THE MAIN. TONE HERE THEME HERE-
DIRECTOR IF I COULD OFFER THOSE
THOSE NUMBERS RIGHT NOW THAT
MIGHT BE HELPFUL SURE. PLEASE
WILLIAMS. SO IN THE-
INFORMATIONAL HEARING WE SHARED
THE AROUND THE NINE HUNDRED.
GOAL TO HIRE. THE PLAN HIRES.
WE HAD PLANNED TO HIRE NINE
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN JANUARY
THROUGH MAY. OF THIS YEAR. THE
ACTUAL HIRES JANUARY THROUGH
MAY OF THIS YEAR. R. SIX
HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT SO WE
FELL SHORT ABOUT. THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY NINE- FROM THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR THIS YEAR
TO DATE AND WE ARE EXPERIENCING
THAT IT IS. IT IS- DIFFICULT TO
RECRUIT TOO DIFFICULT TO RETAIN
OR ATTRITION RATE IS- OVER 30%
PARTICULAR FOR THE CALL CENTER
AND THAT'S NOT. UNLIKE OTHER
CALL CENTERS BUT THAT IS
CERTAINLY WHAT WE ARE
EXPERIENCING WE ARE ENCOURAGED
THAT THE REST OF OUR HIRES
PLANNED FOR JUNE THROUGH AUGUST
WERE PLANNING FOR SIX HUNDRED
AND THIRTY. AND THAT'S THE-
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM REP THAT'S
THE HIGHEST CLASSIFICATION THAT
THE CLASSIFICATION THAT CAN
NEARLY DO A 100% OF THE WORK
LOAD WHERE COURAGE ABOUT. THOSE
NUMBERS AND THAT IS OUR PLAN
FOR- JUNE TO AUGUST THANK YOU
HAS THERE BEEN ANY THOUGHT TO-
ANYTHING. THE LEGISLATURE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE COULD PROVIDE
IN TERMS OF RETENTION-
INCENTIVES- IN AND OUT OF MEAN
OBVIOUSLY THAT WOULD HAVE BE
ACROSS THE BOARD NOT TARGETED
TO ANYBODY WHO. TENDERS
RESIGNATION BUT- HE YOU KNOW
YOU IN THESE TERMS WITH IN
THESE TIMES WE'VE SEEN
EVERYTHING FROM HAZARD PAY TO-
YOU NAME IT AND- I WOULD
VENTURE TO SAY IT PROBABLY IS
JUST A FOLLOW DAY HAZARD PAY
FOR THE PEOPLE OF THE ANSWERS
PHONE CALLS I KNOW MYSELF FEELS
THAT WAY SOMETIMES SO. ALL
JOKING ASIDE AND JUST WONDERFUL
I'M LOOKING FOR WAYS THAT WE
CAN BE OF ASSISTANCE TO. TO
HELP YOU. IN THERE'S ONLY A FEW
THINGS WE CONTROL ONE OF THOSE-
WOULD BE. RESOURCES DOLLARS AN-
ILL- THOSE KINDS OF THINGS. I
KNOW AT ANY TIME CAROLINE'S
WE'RE- HAPPY TO. PARTNER WITH
YOU FOR RECRUITMENT AND SOME
HAVE ASKED US FOR SCHEDULES OF
RECRUITMENT FOR THOSE SEEKING
EMPLOYMENT WE CERTAINLY CAN
EASILY PROVIDE THAT TO ANYONE
ACROSS THE STATE ANY OF YOU
THAT ARE INTERESTED. THE AGAIN
I JUST I DON'T WANT TO BE
RETURNED IT BUT IT IT TAKES A
LONG TIME TO HIRE AND TRAIN
PEOPLE BUT- IT SEEMS LIKE THE
MORE EFFICIENT ROUTE IS TO TRY
TO RETAIN. THE 30% THAT ARE
GOING AWAY- RATHER THAN LOSE
THEM AND HAVE TO SPEND FOR FIVE
MONTHS. IT RECRUITED IN
TRAINING AGAIN SO I WOULD JUST
ASK THAT SOME. SOME THOUGHT BE
GIVEN TO THAT AND YOU KNOW INTO
WHAT WE CAN DO TO BE OF
ASSISTANCE IN THAT REGARD-
CLOTH THE LAST QUESTION EIGHT I
THINK I HAVE- ON THIS SIDE- I'M
THE DIRECTOR SIDE OF THINGS IS-
OFF ON THE FRAUD ISSUE. IS
THERE A TO BLINDER HOTLINE AT
EIGHT I HEARD YOU TALK ABOUT-
FRAUD INFORMATION COMING IN
SOMEHOW INCOMING- GIVE ME AN
EXAMPLE OF WHY I'M ASKING THE
QUESTION THIS IS ONE OF SEVERAL
THAT ARE ON MY MIND I RECEIVED
A TEXT YESTERDAY UNSOLICITED
SENIOR EDT PREPAID DEBIT CARD
HAS BEEN SUSPENDED I DON'T HAVE
ONE OF THOSE- I'D LIKE TO TURN.
TURN THIS INTO SOMEBODY OF THE
FOLLOW UP OBVIOUSLY YOU
PRESENTLY THAT'S- SOME SORT OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
EVENTUALLY HAS TO GET A HOLD OF
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BUT- DO YOU
HAVE A TIP LINE I MEAN AT
LEAST. YOU SEE THAT ACROSS
OTHER STATE AGENCIES EVEN FISH
AND WILDLIFE SOMEBODY SEE
SOMETHING. WRONG GOING ON THEY
CAN JUST CALL AN EIGHT HUNDRED
NUMBER AND REPORTED. OUT THAT.
YES WE DO GREAT WHAT IS A
NUMBER. GOOD QUESTION I CAN
SHARE THE US SENATOR CORTESE
IT'S ONE EIGHT HUNDRED. TWO TWO
NINE SIX TWO NINE SEVEN OKAYGREAT- I DON'T KNOW IF MY
DISTRICT OFFICE IS AWARE THAT
THE WE WILL DO OUR BEST YOU
KNOW WITH- YOU KNOW I THINK A
LIST SERVE OF ABOUT A HUNDRED
FIFTY TO TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
TO GET THAT INFORMATION OUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO ENROLL
THE BROADER COMMUNITY NOT. TO
TURN EVERYONE INDIVIDUAL
ARTISTS BUT TO THE EXTENT
PEOPLE GET WEIRD TEXT MESSAGES
EMAILS. THEY'RE HEARING OVER
HEARING. SOMETHING THAT THEIR
NEIGHBOR SAYS- THEY KNOW
SOMEBODY IS- INVOLVED IN
NEFARIOUS ACTIVITIES YOU KNOW I
THINK WE SHOULD BE IN. TRYING
TO ENROLL IN THE LISTED TO THE
GENERAL PUBLIC- IT MOST PEOPLE
I TALK TO WANT US TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS IN THE
FUEL HELP US THEY WANT TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS SPECIAL ON
THE- ON THE FRAUD SIDE SO.
THAT'S THE REASON I'M ASKING
FOR THE- LAST LEADER KEVIN.
SORRY NEED TO VARIOUS WITH EDT-
KEEP. THAT I'D- WANTED TO ON
THAT WE DID SEND OUT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM PEOPLE ON THAT
PARTICULAR SCAM. AND WE DID
SEND OUT SOME INFORMATION TO
THE PRESS TO VOTE LEGISLATIVE
STAFF TO CLAIMANTS WE POSTED IT
ONLINE BECAUSE WE HAVE HEARD
THAT THAT THAT IS AN ISSUE- AND
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT.
TO OUR ATTENTION- AGAIN BECAUSE
IT SEEMS TO CONTINUE TO HAPPEN
WE JUST SENT IT OUT I BELIEVE
LAST WEEK WHEN WE FOUND OUT-
AND THE SECOND POINT IS- TO
YOUR PREVIOUS QUESTION ABOUT-
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION- ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE DO AND
EDT AS WE DO DO. EXIT
INTERVIEWS- AND WE HAVE THEY
ARE VOLUNTARY BUT WE HAVE BEEN
COLLECTING THAT DATA AND WE DO
PLAN ON USING THAT MOVING
FORWARD- TO FIGURE OUT WHERE WE
CAN IMPROVE- YOU KNOW.
BASICALLY YOU KNOW PEOPLE WHO
WORK HERE AND- THERE AND-
WORKING CONDITIONS AND- YOU
DON'T SEE WHY THEY'RE LEAVING
AND IF THERE IS SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN DO ABOUT THAT. LET'S GO
SCREW INTO YOUR- YOU HAVE WAS
SOME EXPERTISE IN THAT AREA
MISS FERGUSON APPRECIATE THAT
VERY MUCH AND THANKS FOR THE
CONFUSION WE JUST WANT TO HELP
AGAIN I DON'T THE CAMPUS SAYS
THAT ENOUGH TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE HAVE. YOU KNOW MASS ABOUT
REACH OF THE CAPABILITY WITHIN.
YOU KNOW THE MILLION PEOPLE
THAT ARE IN OUR SENATE-DISTRICT
WE CAN PUSH OUT INFORMATION
REPEATEDLY LIKE THIS TIP LINE
AND- TRY TO GET PEOPLE
INVOLVED- MANAGER MY LAST
QUESTION IS JUST- FOR THE
AUDITOR. I- BUT BY. MADE A
SUGGESTION- I'M NOT SURE THAT
IT WAS VERY WELL RECEIVED AT
THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING THAT
EITHER INTERNAL OR EXTERNAL-
AUDIT SERVICES SHOULD BE-
FOCUSED YOU KNOW WITHIN EDT.
PRETTY MUCH ON A DAILY BASIS
YOU KNOW UNTIL FURTHER NOTICE
UNTIL WE'RE WE'RE AT THE POINT
WHERE- YOU KNOW WE FEEL WE'RE
OUT OF THE WOODS I DON'T. NO
WHAT THE INTENSITY OF YOUR-
ARMS. EFFORTS ARE AT THIS POINT
A MISTER HARRIS ALTHOUGH I'M
VERY IMPRESSED WITH HOW MUCH
YOU ARE AWARE OF THE PROGRESS
HOPE HOW DETAILED YOUR REPORT
WAS. YOU KNOW HOW DETAILED THE
SEWERAGE REPORT IS SO OBVIOUSLY
YOUR YOUR OFFICE IS SPENDING A
LOT OF TIME. IN OVERSIGHT BUT
COULD IF YOU COULD JUST
DESCRIBE. A VERY QUICKLY IF YOU
WILL YOU KNOW WHAT THAT.
INTENSIVE EFFORT- REMAIN THIS
WAY FOR LOOKS LIKE ON YOUR ON
YOUR OFFICES PART AT THIS POINT.
FINALLY HAVE A TO DO SO SENATOR
SO. WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW
IS MONITORING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF
RECOMMENDATIONS AND WE'RE DOING
THAT AT SCHEDULED INTERVALS- AT
A MINIMUM AND THOSE ARE EVERY
NINETY DAYS SO EVERY NINETY
DAYS WE'RE ASKING YOU TO DO TO
PROVIDE US AN UPDATE. AT ITS
PROGRESS IN ALL OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE MADE TO
IT. WHEN WE DO ONCE WE RECEIVE
THAT UPDATE FROM EDG AS WE
REVIEW IT AND ASK FOR
ADDITIONAL EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT
THAT PROGRESS SO FOR EXAMPLE-
REVIEWING THAT IT HAS IS A WORK
FORCE PLAN FOR INSTANCE AND
LOOKING AT THAT PLAN AND SEEING
DOES THAT COMPORT WITH ALL OF.
THE CONSIDERATIONS THAT WE
RECOMMENDED EATING MAC. ONCE WE
COMPLETE THAT ASSESSMENT FAMILY
REACH THOSE CONCLUSIONS LIKE
THE ONES IN THE DOCUMENT WE
PROVIDED TO THE COMMITTEE TODAY
ABOUT WHAT IS THE STATUS OF.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS SO WE ARE
ENGAGED IN REGULAR
COMMUNICATION WITH EDG AS IT
PROVIDES US THOSE UPDATES AND
DOING A REVIEW OF DOCUMENTATION
IT'S NOT JUST LOOKING AT THE
TAX THEY PROVIDE TO US IT'S
ALSO ASKING FOR SUPPORTING
DOCUMENTATION AS WELL. AND WILL
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE IN THOSE
FOLLOW UPS- AND SO IT'S NOT
RELEVANT ANYMORE AND WE AGREED
THAT ALL OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE FULLY ADDRESSED AND FULLY
IMPLEMENTED AND CERTAINLY WE
HAVE. AS WELL STATUTORY
AUTHORITY AND THE OPTION TO-
CONDUCT ADDITIONAL FOLLOW UP
WORK IF WE FIND THAT THAT THAT
IS ACTUALLY NECESSARY. THANK
YOU THROUGH THE TRUTH THANK YOU
MISTER HARRISON AND AGAIN AND
IT AYE I WANT TO FRAME- IN
RETROSPECT THE HER MY QUESTION
IS NOT AN INTEREST IN HAVING
THE AUDITOR HOWEVER- OR-
GETTING. IN X. SCRUTINY. BUT
THE PICKUP ISSUES WERE ON
ISSUES THAT MAY GET OFF TRACK
OR- OR MAKE SUGGESTIONS OF ME
PUT THINGS BACK ON TRACK I
THINK THE RETENTION ISSUES A
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF THAT
MEANWHILE WAIT NINETY DAYS. TO
COME IN AND SAY JEEZ WE GOT A
RETENTION PROBLEM AND I'M NOT
I'M NOT LAYING THERE YOUR
DOORSTEP. I'M ACTUALLY SAYING
THAT. YOU'RE IN A VERY GOOD
POSITION. IF YOU'RE REGULARLY
OVERSEEING THINGS TO GIVE. BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE WITHIN A
REPORT TO SAY. WE HAVE SOME
MORE SUGGESTIONS HERE. A TO
KEEP US OFF THE- THE HUMAN
RESOURCES TREADMILL AND HERE'S
WHAT THEY ARE IN- THOSE. THAT
THIRTY PERCENT. IT HAS GOT TO
BE. A DEVASTATING ISSUE IN
TERMS OF KEEPING UP WITH
CASELOAD AND IT'S ALSO GOING TO
BE A DEVASTATING RAW ISSUE FOR
THE EMPLOYEES THAT ARE STILL
THERE TO SEE PEOPLE TO SEE THAT
KIND OF ATTRITION SO- I'M KIND
OF FOCUSED ON THAT. BUT I THINK
IT'S ALSO A GOOD EXAMPLE OF WHY.
MORE IN A MINUTE- OVERSIGHT
WRITTEN RECOMMENDATIONS- YOU
KNOW MIGHT BE PREFERABLE THAT
SAID AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
VERY DETAILED REPORT TODAY
APPRECIATED VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU MANAGER. YES SENATOR NEWMAN
I WOULD I WOULD I HAVE ONE
QUESTION HOPEFULLY IS REALLY
QUICK I THINK IT'S FOR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WILLIAMS. AND IT'S
ABOUT THE LEGISLATIVE LIAISONS
BACK TO WHAT ONE OF THE
ENCOURAGING DEVELOPMENTS IS THE
ASSIGNMENT. OF SPECIFIC
LIAISONS TO OFFICES- AND SO I
KNOW THAT'S BEEN A NET POSITIVE
FOR US BUT I JUST WANNA GIVE
SOME FEEDBACK I I'M TOLD THAT
THE WAY IT WORKS IS- IT'S
COMING MY OFFICE THAT THAT.
THAT WE HAVE A DEDICATED PERSON
THAT'S HANDLING THIS MASSIVE
LOAD OF CONSTITUENT COMPLAINTS.
AND NEEDS- AND SHE GETS FOUR
HOURS A WEEK WITH OUR DEDICATED
LIAISON IT'S BROKEN UP ACROSS
THREE DAYS- AND WANT TO GIVE
THE FEEDBACK THAT THEY
APPARENTLY THAT IS NOT ENOUGH
AND I WOULD FOR THE SAME THING
FROM. OTHER OFFICES OR DO I
JUST WANT TO RAISE THAT HERE-
AND I GUESS ASK THE QUESTIONS.
YOU KNOW IS IT POSSIBLE AND-
DIED NOW THAT WE'VE GIVEN YOU
THAT FEEDBACK- THAT WE COULD
ALLOCATE SOME MORE MANPOWER TO
THAT I UNDERSTAND IT'S NOT
INSIGNIFICANT WHEN YOU MULTIPLY
IT BY. HUNDRED TWENTY
LEGISLATORS BUT BUT I THINK IS
PROBABLY NECESSARY- AND SO IT
YOU KNOW IF YOU COULD NOT BE
TAKE THAT AS INPUT BUT WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR RESPONSE. THANK
YOU FOR. YOUR QUESTION- I THINK
THE QUESTION IS BEST ANSWERED
BY THE LEGISLATIVE DEPUTY.
KEVIN YES THANK YOU SUTTER
NEWMAN. WE'VE HEARD THE
FEEDBACK AS WELL- WE- TRIED TO
TAKE MANY STEPS TO. EASE THE
BURDEN ON YOUR DISTRICT OFFICES
BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE HAS
BEEN AN INCREASE IN THAT
CASELOAD- LIKE THE DIRECTOR
MENTIONED TO ME. RECENTLY
AUGMENTED A HUNDRED TWENTY ONE
STAFF TO WORK ON. LEGISLATIVE
REFERRALS- AND- REALIZE THAT
THAT MAY NOT BE ENOUGH TO
ADDRESS- WHAT THE OFFICERS ARE
CURRENTLY DEALING ONE SO. THE
YOU KNOW THE DEPARTMENT
ADMINISTRATION ARE WORKING WITH
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP- TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT- WHAT SORT OF
SOLUTION CAN BE IMPLEMENTED
TIME TO HELP EASE THAT BURDEN
AND- AS SOON AS THERE HAS BEEN-
SOLUTION AGREED TO WE WILL BE
SURE TO MAKE OFFICERS AWARE OF
THAT VERY GOOD I APPRECIATE
THAT SO I'M TOLD AND EASY AT
LEAST PARTIAL SOLUTIONS JUST TO
ALLOCATE MORE TIME. AND I SAID
YOU COULD TAKE THAT UNDER
CONSIDERATION PRITCHETT
UNDERSTOOD. YEAH CAROL WILLIAMS.
AND WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
FEEDBACK- WE DO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOUR STAFF TO COME
TO A RESOLUTION AND- SOME TERMS
THAT WE CAN RELIEVE THE BURDEN
AS WELL AS PRIMARILY. CLOSE THE
CASES SERVE THE CLAIMANTS OF
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
FEEDBACK WE APPRECIATE IT. YEAH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEMBERS- I
ALSO WANT TO. REINFORCE WHAT
SENATOR NEWMAN WAS TALKING
ABOUT I'VE HAD. THE EQUIVALENT
OF THREE FULL TIME PEOPLE
DURING THIS LAST YEAR WORKING
ON- CASES ADD CASES L. AND IT
STARTED TO MAKE A VERY BIG
DIFFERENCE WHEN A PARTICULAR
PERSON WAS ASSIGNED EVEN IF IT
WAS FEET EIGHT LOOK FORWARD. TO
THE FEW HOURS THAT THEY HAVE
WITH THIS LADY IS ON BECAUSE
THEY ACTUALLY SOLVE THE CASES
WHICH THEY ARE MOSTLY UNABLE TO
DO THEMSELVES IF THEY YOU KNOW
JUST TRY DIRECTLY WITH THE D.
D. SO. IT'S PROVEN TO BE
SUCCESSFUL THE ISSUE THAT
THAT'S NOT THE CORE ISSUE
THOUGH THAT'S NOT THE REAL
PROBLEM WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS
A PROBLEM. THAT IS ALREADY
EXISTS AS FAR AS NOT ET DE NOT
BE IN A POSITION TO SOLVE ALL
THESE CASES DIRECTLY ON YOUR
OWNBECAUSE- WE DON'T WANT TO
HAVE MORE PEOPLE IN OUR OFFICE
ADDRESSING THIS. DISC I WANNA
THANK YOU AS CENTER GROVE HAS-
AND OTHERS ARE ON THE COMMITTEE
OF FOR JUMPING INTO THIS AND-
BEING COURAGEOUS ENOUGH TO TAKE
ALL THE OF THE CRITICISM THE
PUBLICITY AROUND THIS YEAR
REALLY UNDER A MAGNIFYING
GLASS- AND YET WE STILL FIND
OURSELVES YOU FIND YOURSELVES
WITH SOME OF THE SERIOUS ISSUES
SO I JUST HAVE A AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALSO FOR THE A
LANGUAGE ACCESS ISSUES I KNOW
MORE WORK HAS TO BE DONE ON
THAT BUT THAT'S A BIG ISSUE FOR
ME. IF IT'S SOME OF THE
BENEFITS SYSTEM MODERNIZATION
PROJECT- WHAT WHAT IS THE
TIMELINE. YOU SEE ON ON THAT.
THE QUESTION WE ARE NOW IN THE
PROCESS OF PUTTING TOGETHER. A
PLAN TO. WORK WITH A VENDOR. TO
BRING TOGETHER ALL OF THE
INFORMATION THAT THE- I. T.
BRANCH HAS. ANY OF THE ARE
REALLY. YOU KNOW WE SPENT TIME
OUT WITH THE INITIAL. STAR
SYSTEMS MODERNIZATION AND WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THE BEST OF THAT
INFORMATION. WE HAVE BEEN
FOLLOWING MASS WHAT NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF WORKFORCE.
AGENCIES AND WE'VE LEARNED FROM
THE OTHER OF STATE AND SOME OF
THE STATE'S ACTUALLY HAD A NEW
SYSTEM WHEN THE PANDEMIC
STARTED AND WE'VE ALL LEARNED
THAT THOSE SYSTEMS WERE
INSUFFICIENT. AND WE'RE GOING
TO RESEARCH ANY NEW SOLUTIONS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE. THE ACT
TIMELINE IS STILL BEING WORKED
ON BUT I EXPECT TO SEE SOME
PROGRESS BAR BEFORE THE FALL.
AT SOME PROGRESS WITH REGARDS
TO PUTTING THE LINE TOGETHER OR
WITH REGARDS TO THE PROJECT
ITSELF ON WHAT IT WILL PROJECT
ITSELF OUR OUR DEBTTHINK IT'S
AN IMPORTANT CLARIFICATION
DISHES FOR A ARE PLANNING FOR
HOW WE'RE GOING TO. HOW WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE SO I WANT TO
GIVE YOU I WANT TO GIVE THE
COMMITTEE AN EXAMPLE. ONE OF
THE OUR TRADITIONAL WAYS OF
APPROACHING. INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY IS WHAT IS CALLED A
WATERFALL APPROACH. AND IN THAT
APPROACH YOU BUILD AND BUILD
AND BUILD AND BUILD THE SYSTEM.
THE SYSTEM GOES LIVE AND YOU
DISCOVER ALL THE PROBLEMS. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT HERE IS USING THE
NEWER APPROACH WHICH IS THE
AGILE APPROACH IN WHICH PART OF
THE SYSTEM ARE RELEASED
GRADUALLY. IN ADDITION TO THAT
RATHER THAN BUILDING NUMBER THE
HE MUST OF- OF THE SYSTEM WE'RE
LOOKING AT CREATING A SMALL AN
AGILE SYSTEM AND ADDING OFF THE
SHELVES. OF PRODUCTS THAT CAN
HELP US. WHAT THEY CALL MODULES
TO HELP US TO KEEP THE SYSTEM
FLEXIBLE SO WE'RE LOOKING AT
KEEPING DOWN THE COST BUT ALSO
MAKING THE SYSTEM SMALLER
FLEXIBLE AND- THAT'S WHAT THIS
IS ABOUT PLANNING. PROCESS IS
GOING TO LOOK AT WHAT IS THE
BEST WAY FOR US TO APPROACH THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE NEW SYSTEM.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU MAY AND
WILL BE AVAILABLE YOU THINK BY
THE FALL. WELL I THINK WE'LL
HAVE SOME SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
BY THE FALL. OKAY AND- ONE UP
AND I TRIED TO GO THROUGH THIS
THE LIST OF ALL THE AUDITORS-
ISSUES AND- AND YOUR- YOU ARE
MAKING PROGRESS YEAR SEEM TO BE
MOSTLY ON THE TIME LINE BUT IF
YOU COULD JUST ANSWER THE ISSUE
RAISED BY THE AUDITOR TODAY ON
WORKLOAD SCENARIOS AND HOW
YOU'RE- ADDRESSING THOSE. BOB
WILL HAVE ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
ADDRESS THAT. HI CAROL WILLIAMS
THE CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
THIS IS ONE THE RECOMMENDATION
THAT WE CONTINUE TO WORK ON AND
WOOD WE'RE NOT GONNA STOP UNTIL
WE ACTUALLY GET IT RIGHT WE-
THIS IS THE ONE THAT WILL HELP
US PRESENTLY AND IN THE FUTURE
WE LOOK TO HAVE IT WERE-
RESOLVED HOPEFULLY WITH THE
NEXT FORTY FIVE DAYS. AT BUT-
AT THE LATEST. BUT WE ARE IN
PROGRESS AND THAT'S THE STATUS
THAT WE REFLECT ELECTED TO
STATE HONORS THANK YOU. OKAY
COLLEAGUES ANYMORE COMMENTED
QUESTIONS OKAY- AGAIN JUST WANT
TO THANK ALL OF YOU- IT WE'RE
TRYING TO BE SUPPORTIVE AS MUCH
AS WE CAN- WITH YOU AND- AND
YET WE UNDERSTOOD WE KNOW AND
YOU KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON IN
OUR RESPECTIVE DISTRICTS ALL
OVER CALIFORNIA IS- YOU KNOW
ENORMOUS FRUSTRATION AND ANGER
AND JUST THE- YOU KNOW. NOT
HAVING THE RESOURCES THAT
FAMILIES NEED AND INDIVIDUALS
NEED TO BE ABLE TO SURVIVE- SO.
UP I'M SURE YOU UNDERSTAND IT'S
OUR JOB TO NOT ONLY ASK
QUESTIONS BUT TO EXPECT MORE
AND MORE OF YOU AND- THAT'S
WHAT THAT'S WHAT THE
CALIFORNIANS EXPECT OF US AS
LEGISLATORS SO. BUT I DO WANNA
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD
WORK AND EVERYONE WHO IS NOT
WORKING SO HARD IN THE EDT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- GERMANS ARE
OURSELVES. WE ARE ACUTELY AWARE
OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WE'RE
HAVING. AND JACK I APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT I APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND THEIR SUGGESTIONS
AND DINNER WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO. WHAT WE NEED TO
DO TO GET THIS FIXED OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THAT THAT WAS AN
INFORMATIONAL ITEMS ARE OUR
FINAL ISSUE IS ISSUE OF THIS
AGENDA IS ISSUE NINETEEN THE
MULTI YEAR INVESTMENT STRATEGY.
FOR CAL STIRS OF WILL THE
DEPARTMENT PLEASE. PRESENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR DRAWS SO AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JULIE UNDERWOOD AND I AM THE
CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT SYSTEM THAT THIS
ITEM SUMMARIZES CAL STIRS MULTI
YEAR INTERNAL INVESTMENT
MANAGEMENT BCP THAT HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY THE TEACHERS
RETIREMENT BOARD NOW THIS B. C.
P. ALLIANCE WITH OUR INVESTMENT
BELIEF NUMBER THREE WHICH IS
MANAGING INVESTMENT COSTS YIELD
LONG TERM BENEFITS IN OUR
STRATEGIC PLAN GOAL TO CONTINUE
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
COLLABORATIVE MODEL BY
LEVERAGING CANCERS RESOURCES.
NOW THE PLAN DOES PROVIDE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FOUR POSITIONS TO
BE UTILIZED OVER A FIVE YEAR
PERIOD AT A BUDGETARY COST OF
THIRTY EIGHT POINT TWO MILLION
THAT THESE POSITIONS WILL BE
DEPLOYED OVER SIXTEEN DIFFERENT
ASSET CLASSES AND BUSINESS
AREAS THROUGHOUT THE
ORGANIZATION THAT WILL BE USED
TO SUPPORT THE GROWTH IN ASSETS
UNDER MANAGEMENT AND THE GROWS
IN THE COLLABORATIVE MODEL
WHICH IS AN INVESTMENT STRATEGY
TO MOVE MORE. INVESTMENTS TO
INTERNAL MANAGEMENT. HELPER ARE
LATEST BECAUSE REPORT. 4% OF
OUR NET ASSET VALUE IS MANAGED
BY EXTERNAL MANAGERS WHICH
COSTS APPROXIMATELY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS COMPARED TO THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR INTERNAL AND
HYBRID MANAGEMENT. NOW FROM A
NET RETURNS PERSPECTIVE
INTERNAL MANAGEMENT AND PUBLIC
MARKET ASSETS IS APPROXIMATELY
ONE EIGHT. TO ONE TENTH OF THE
COST COMPARED TO HIRING
EXTERNAL MANAGERS AND WE'VE
ALREADY ACHIEVED QUITE
AGGRESSIVE COST SAVINGS THAT WE
STARTED GROWING THIS MODEL. SO
FOR A COUPLE EXAMPLES OVER THE
LAST THREE AND A HALF YEARS
WHICH FUNDED SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN INTERNALLY MANAGED
PORTFOLIOS. SAVING
APPROXIMATELY NINETEEN MILLION
DOLLARS. WE ALSO ENTERED INTO A
HYBRID CALL INVESTMENT THAT
WILL REDUCE INCENTIVES AND FEES
OF APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS. IN A RECENT DIRECT
LENDING INVESTMENT REDUCE THE
STANDARD FEES BY 50% SO NOW WE
ANTICIPATE APPROXIMATELY TEN
YEAR. TEN YEARS TO SEE TWO
HUNDRED TO THREE HUNDRED
MILLION IN ANNUAL COST SAVINGS
AND INCREASED RETURNS AS WE
GROW THIS MODEL. THE OVERALL
THIS IS THE COST SAVINGS
INITIATIVES IT WILL ULTIMATELY
PROVIDE LONG TERM COST SAVINGS
TO THE TEACHERS RETIREMENT FUND
WHICH SUPPORTS THE STATE'S
DIRECTIVES TO MITIGATE COSTS.
THESE EFFORTS ARE PROJECTED TO
FAR OUTWEIGH THE COST OF THIS
REQUEST LONG TERM. AND COULD
CREATE ENOUGH SAVINGS TO KEEP
ANNUAL PORTFOLIO COSTS AT OUR
CURRENT LEVELS TEN YEARS FROM
NOW DESPITE THE PORTFOLIO
GROWING BY PROJECTED A
PROJECTED FIFTY PERCENT. YEAH
WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A
LARGE ADDITION TO RESOURCES
DURING AN UNPRECEDENTED TIME SO
OUR GOAL IS TO BE TRANSPARENT
AND ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE COST
SAVINGS ACHIEVED THROUGH THIS
MODEL. SO WE'RE COMMITTED TO
EXPANDING OUR ANNUAL COST
REPORTS THAT ARE PRESENTED TO
OUR BOARD TO SHOW OUR SUCCESS
OVER TIME AND GROWING THIS
MODEL WE ALSO PLAN TO HIRE A
THIRD PARTY TO INDEPENDENTLY
VERIFY OUR CAP OUR OUR
CALCULATIONS. FOR ADDITIONAL
ASSURANCE. SO IS THAT ARE
DEPUTY CHIEF AND OFFICER SCOTT
JANICE ALSO TODAY AND WILL BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. GREAT THANK YOU
THAT'S MISS UNDERWOOD RIGHT.
YES OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LIVED HERE ABOUT SAVING MONEY
THAT'S A THAT'S A THAT'S A
GREELEY GOOD. NEWS THAT YOU
BRING HERE- FINANCE DO YOU HAVE
ANY COMMENTS. BY ONE BUDGET FOR
THE FINANCE WILL SUPPORTIVE OF
THE CHARACTERS COLLABORATIVE
MODEL AND WE HAVE NO CONCERNS
WITH THIS PROPOSAL HAVING TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
ALEJO. YES THANK YOU ANGELES
SHORT WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE'VE
REVIEWED THE PROPOSAL AND DON'T
HAVE ANY CONCERNS AS YOU HEARD.
OF FROM THIS UNDER WOULD IT THE
POSITIONS THAT ARE REQUESTED
ARE IN LINE WITH CASTORS ON
TERM PLAN AND WOULD CONTRIBUTE
TO PROJECTED SIGNIFICANT LONG
TERM SAVINGS SO PROPOSAL SEEMS
VERY REASONABLE TO US.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SANDERS ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS THIS IS ARTISTIC
COMMENTARY. I FOR ONE THINK
THIS IS GREAT- GREAT DIRECTION
AND YOU KNOW I'M GLAD TO HEAR
IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE LONG
TERM PLAN AND I'M GLAD TO SEE.
ON A COUPLE ITEMS TODAY THIS
SEEMS TO BE KIND OF A TREND TO
BRING THIS KIND OF WORK OR-
WHAT WAS OUTSIDE WORKING INSIDE
SO. I JUST WANT TO GET THE
COMING OF THE RECORD THANK
MINIATURE OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE- ARE AT THE END OF OUR
PART A AGENDA. WE WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN
CORPORATIONS WE'VE CONCLUDED
THE DISCUSSIONS FOR PART A WE
WILL NOW RECESS FOR MAX FIVE
MINUTES AND RECONVENE TO HEAR
PART B. OF THE AGENDA. AFTER
WHICH. PHOTO NO PUBLIC COMMENTS
IS AFTER PART BE. IT'S AT THE
END OKAY SIR THANK I'M SORRY
RIGHT. OF SO ARE WE WILL HILL
PART B. OF THE AGENDA TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND THEN VOTE-
THE VOTES WERE PART EIGHT I AM
SO AGAIN. WE HAVE. SHAKLEE
MAXIMUM FIVE MINUTES. THE
GERMAN FIVE MINUTES I THINK
CAMINO DEL.
THE SENATE BUDGET
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE
WE WILL NOW PROCEED TO PART B.
OF THE AGENDA WHICH COVERS
PUBLIC SAFETY AND JUDICIARY
ISSUES OUR FIRST FIRST ISSUE ON
PART B. WILL DISCUSS THE POLICY
IN BUDGET IMPACTS ASSOCIATED
WITH CALIFORNIA'S FINES AND
FEES STRUCTURE ANITA LEE FROM
THE L. A. O. WILL KICK THINGS
OFF WITH AN OVERVIEW OF THE
SYSTEM FOLLOWED BY BRANDON
GREEN DIRECTOR RACIAL AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE PROGRAM AT
ACLU FOUNDATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND SHELLEY CURRAN.
ACTOR JUDICIAL COUNCIL CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SERVICES- MISLI WOULD
YOU PLEASE BEGIN. ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
IMMEDIATELY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I
AM GOING TO SHARE MY SCREEN AND
HOPEFULLY YOU ARE ABLE TO SEE
THE HAND OUT- ARE YOU ABLE TO
SEE THAT MADAM CHAIR YES OKAY
GREAT- SO WE HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
STATE'S CRIMINAL FINANCED THE
SYSTEM AS WELL AS TO HIGHLIGHT
SOME ACTIONS AND CHANGES TO THE
SYSTEM THAT HAVE BEEN INCLUDED
AS- PART OF THE PRIOR YEAR AND
ALSO THE PROPOSED BUDGET IS
ONLY USING THIS CANNOT AS A
GUIDE- THIS CANNOT IS ALSO
AVAILABLE ON THE L. A. A
WEBSITE FOR FOLKS WHO WANT TO
FOLLOW ALONG. SO IF YOU TURN TO
PAGE ONE OF THE HAND OUT- WE
TALK ABOUT CRIMINAL FINES AND
FEES WERE COLLECTIVELY
REFERRING TO ALL OF THE
ASSESSMENTS THAT ARE CHARGED
FROM INDIVIDUALS ARE CONVICTED
OF CRIMINAL OFFENSES. WHICH
INCLUDE TRAFFIC VIOLATIONS.
TWENTY TO PAGE TWO OF THE
HANDOUT IF YOU LOOK AT THAT
TABLE THE FIGURE BEFORE YOU.
THE TOTAL AMOUNT FOLLOWED BY AN
INDIVIDUAL STARTS WITH THE
BASELINE THE VERY FIRST LINE
ITEM ON THE FIGURE. OUT A
NUMBER OF OTHER CHARGES ARE
ADDED SOME OF WHICH ARE
STATUTORILY REQUIRED AND SOME
ARE PERMITTED BASED ON THE
VIOLATION OR OTHER FACTORS.
INDIVIDUALS ARE ABLE TO ASK
THAT THECOURTS AND JUST THE
AMOUNT OWED BASED ON THEIR
ABILITY TO PAY AND JUDGES DO
HAVE THE ABILITY TO WAIVE OR
REDUCE CERTAIN CHARGES. TURNING
TO PAGE THREE OF YOUR HAND OUT.
THE FIGURE BEFORE YOU
ILLUSTRATES THAT THE TOTAL FINE
IF YOU LEVELS HAVE INCREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER TIME. THESE
FINDINGS THE LEVELS ARE SET TO
SERVE MULTIPLE PURPOSES- SOME
OF THEM ARE TIED TO THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THE CRIME WHILE
OTHERS ARE USED TO GENERATE
REVENUE TO FUND PARTICULAR
ACTIVITIES FOR TO HELP OFFSET
STATE AND LOCAL COSTS FOR
PROVIDING CERTAIN SERVICES.
TURNING TO PAGE FOUR OF YOUR
HAND OUT. BOTH COUNTIES AND
COURTS ARE INVOLVED IN THE
COLLECTION PROCESS THE COUNTIES
ARE STATUTORILY RESPONSIBLE-
BOTH THE COUNTY'S AIRPORT CAN
ALSO CONTRACT WITH PRIVATE
COLLECTION VENDORS OR THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO HELP
WITH THIS AS WELL. THE
COLLECTION PROGRAMS USE A
VARIETY OF TOOLS. TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS EITHER PROVIDE
PAYMENT IN FULL IMMEDIATELY OR
TO SET UP AND REMAIN CURRENT ON
THEIR INSTALLMENT PLANS. IF AN
INDIVIDUAL DOES NOT PAY ON TIME
THE AMOUNT OWED IT DOES BECOME
DELINQUENT AND AFTER THE
APPROPRIATE NOTIFICATION
SANCTIONS CAN THEN BE APPLIED.
THE COLLECTION PROGRAMS
GENERALLY VERY AND HOW AND WHEN
THOSE SANCTIONS ARE USED BUT
THEY TYPICALLY HAVE BEEN
PROGRESSIVELY TO INCREASE THE
PRESSURE ON THE INDIVIDUAL. AND
TO COMMENT SECTIONS INCLUDE A
CIVIL ASSESSMENT OF UP TO THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR FAILING TO
PAY OR APPEAR WITHOUT THE
CLASS. AS WELL AS. WE AGE
GARNISHMENT AND BANK LEVIES. AT
THE END TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
THE G. BRANCH OF ABOUT POINTS
BILLION REMAINED OUTSTANDING
THE MINUTES OF THE- TURNING TO
PAGE FIVE OF YOUR HAND HOW.
STATE LAW ONCE TIS MONEY IS
COLLECTED DICTATES A VERY
COMPLEX PROCESS FOR
DISTRIBUTING THE FINANCIER OF
THE NEW TWENTY NUMBER OF
ELIGIBLE STATE AND LOCAL FINDS.
THE STATE GENERALLY RECEIVES A
MAJORITY OF THE REVENUE WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENT RECEIVING A
LITTLE BIT MORE THAN 40% AND
THEN THE REMAINDER- SUPPORTS
THE COLLECTION PROGRAMS THAT
ARE COLLECTING DELINQUENT
PAYMENTS. THE TOTAL AMOUNT
COLLECTED HAS VERY LITTLE MILE
DISTRIBUTED TO STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAS DECLINED SINCE
TWO THOUSAND TEN ELEVEN. AS A
RESULT A NUMBER OF STATE FUNDS
THAT RECEIVE THIS TYPE OF
ROMANIANS HAVE FACED FUNDING
SHORTFALLS. AND BECOME
INSOLVENT. THE TRYING TO PAY
SIX OF YOUR HAND OUT- AGREES
BUDGETS AS WELL AS THE CURRENT
PROPOSED ONE WHICH I'M INCLUDE
VARIOUS ACTIONS TO ADDRESS THE
DECLINE IN THIS FINANCIALLY
REVENUE. AND WE'RE GOING TO
HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF THOSE SO
FIRST- THE STATE HAS SHIFTED
COSTS FROM VARIOUS FUND
SUPPORTED THIS BY THIS REVENUE
TO THE GENERAL FUND OR TO OTHER
FINES- IN DIFFERENT YEARS. IN
SOME CASES IT'S THE WHOLE SHALL
SIXTEEN OF PRODUCT OF PROGRAMS
AND OTHER CASES OF TOBACCO. SO
AS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET FOR EXAMPLE
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF CAUTIOUS
INCLUDING PROPOSALS FOR AN
ONGOING GENERAL PLANS BACK FILL
OF BOTH THE DNA IDENTIFICATION
FIND AS. WELL AS THE
RESTITUTION FINES- S. ACTION
THAT HAS BEEN INCLUDED IN
BUDGET IS THE STATE HAS.
CERTAIN STATE ENTITIES
SUPPORTED BY THIS REVENUE TO
REDUCE OUR EXPENDITURES. IN
CERTAIN YEARS. A THIRD ACTION
IS THAT THE STATE HAS ALSO
ATTEMPTED TO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF FINANCING REVENUE
COLLECTED IN DIFFERENT WAYS.
THE FOR EXAMPLE FTV DID RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IS PART OF
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN BUDGET. FOR COLLECTION
FOR INCREASED COLLECTION
ACTIVITIES. TURNING TO PAGE
SEVEN IN YOUR HAND OUT I'M KIND
OF A COUPLE OF OTHERS AS YOU
KNOW AS PART OF THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BUDGET. THE
STATE ACTUALLY ELIMINATED SOME
OF THE STATUTORY FORMULAS
DICTATING SPECIFICALLY HOW
CERTAIN FUNDS WERE TO BE
DISTRIBUTED AND INSTEAD SHIFTED
TO A PROCESS WHERE FUNDS WERE
APPROPRIATED- BASED ON IN STATE
PRIORITIES INSTEAD. AND THE
FINAL ONE WE HIGHLIGHT FOR HERE
AS PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET THERE IS A
PROPOSAL TO CONSOLIDATE THE
JUDICIAL BRANCHES TO
CONSTRUCTION ACCOUNTS TO DELAY
THE NEED TO ADDRESS THE
INSOLVENCY OF THE ACCOUNTS.
TURNING TO PAGE EIGHT YOUR HAND
OUT. THE STATE BUDGET HAS ALSO
INCLUDED ACTIONS TO REDUCE
IMPACTS OF FINES AND FEES ON
INDIVIDUALS AND I'M GOING TO
HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF THOSE. THE
FIRST TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET PACKAGE
AUTHORIZED A PILOT PROGRAM TO
FACILITATE THE ONLINE EDUCATION
AND ABILITY TO PAY
DETERMINATIONS. FOR CERTAIN
TRAFFIC INFRACTIONS AT A
MINIMUM OF EIGHT CORE. THE
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSES TO
ELIMINATE THIS KIND OF PROGRAM
AND EXPAND THE STATE THE ONLINE
EDUCATION AND THE ABILITY TO
PAY STATEWIDE. AS WELL AS TO
APPLY TO ALL INFRACTIONS AND TO
BACK FILL THE EXPECTED
REDUCTION IN THE CRIMINAL.
FINANCIALLY REVENUE THAT WOULD
BE COLLECTED. A SECOND AT LEAST-
IS THAT AS PART OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET THE
ASSESSMENT AND COLLECTION OF
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY CRIMINAL
JUSTICE ADMINISTRATIVE FEES
WILL BE ELIMINATED AS OF JULY
FIRST OF THIS YEAR. AND SIXTY
FIVE MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS WAS SET ASIDE- TO
PROVIDE COUNTIES WITH THE BACK
FELL OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS-
AND SO PURSUANT TO THE LANGUAGE
IN THAT IN THAT BUDGET PACKAGE
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON FINALIZING THE
METHODOLOGY TO ALLOCATE THAT
SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR BACK
SO. INTERNING TO THE FINAL PAGE
OF YOUR HANDOUT- THERE ARE TWO
OTHER ACTIONS TAKEN IN RECENT
BUDGET THAT WE WOULD HAVE LIKED
YOUR ATTENTION. THE FIRST IS A
PART OF THE TWENTY FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN BUDGET PACKAGE THAT IT
DID INCLUDE A TRAFFIC AMNESTY-
PROPOSAL. IN WHICH ELIGIBLE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE THEIR CIVIL
ASSESSMENTS WAVES THE TOTAL
AMOUNT BE REDUCED. THE TOTAL
NUMBER EIGHT OLD REDUCED AS
WELL AS THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSES
RESTORED UNDER CERTAIN
CONDITIONS. AND THEN AS PART OF
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN BUDGET- ELIMINATED THE
COLLECTION PROGRAMS ABILITY TO
USE DRIVER'S LICENSES HOLDS AND
SUSPENSIONS AS A COLLECTION
SANCTION. FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
FAIL TO PAY THEIR CRIMINAL
FINES AND FEES. SO HOPEFULLY
THIS IS A HELPFUL. OVERVIEW FOR
THAT SHE SET UP THE REST THE
DISCUSSION FROM PANEL WE'RE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE A
PROVIDE DETAIL- IF NECESSARY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU-
THANK YOU MISLI APPRECIATE THAT
PRESENTATION AND MAKE. FROM MR
GREEN FROM THE ACLU PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON. GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON BRINGING DURING
DIRECT RUSSIAN ECONOMIC JUSTICE
PROGRAM AT THE ACLU OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY- I FIRST
WANT TO JUST. NO FED WHAT IS
PROPOSED IS NOT MERELY AN
ECONOMIC JUSTICE SERVE BUDGET
FUNDING ISSUE WHAT IS THE ISSUE
THAT SORT OF INEXTRICABLY
LINKED TO THE RACIALIZATION OF
POLICING AND THE
CRIMINALIZATION OF BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITY- THAT FIND A
FEES IN TRAFFIC- FOR TRAFFIC
INFRACTIONS FOR EXAMPLE- IS
INEXTRICABLY CONNECTED TO THE
WAY IN WHICH BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES ARE. OVER POLICED-
PULLED OVER A MORE FREQUENT
BREAKS. HAVE THEIR DRIVER'S
LICENSE MAY BE A MORE
FREQUENTLY BREAKS THE EXTENT-
AND SO WE'RE ACTUALLY TALKING
ABOUT IS REALLY CONNECTED TO
SORT OF THE REPARATIONS
DISCUSSIONS- THAT HAVE BEGUN-
SOME OF THE OTHER RACIAL
JUSTICE. LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS
AND BILLS THAT WERE PASSED IN
SUBSEQUENT YEARS. BECAUSE WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT WEALTHY
STRETCHING FROM BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES SO THIS IS NOT ONLY
AN OPPORTUNITY TO SHRINK THE
REACH OF THE RACIALIZED SYSTEM
BUT ALSO LEVY EIGHT ECONOMIC
ARMSTRONG BY THE SYSTEM. MAKES
ONE NECESSARY STEP TOWARDS
BRINGING VISIONING THE CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM. AS IT RELATES TO
BRILEY- ABILITY TO PAY- I JUST
WANT TO NOTE DAY- FOR EXAMPLE I
WORKED AT THE STATION LAWCENTER
DURING THE TRAFFIC AMNESTY-
HIGHLY. AND WE HAVE SEEN OF
BOTH- IN SORT OF LOCAL
IMPLEMENTATION AND JUST OVER
TIME DATE ABILITY TO PAY- IS
INEFFECTIVE- IS AN EFFECTIVE
BOTH AT ADDRESSING THIS SORT OF
RACIALIZED NATURE OF ALL THAT
IS INEFFECTIVE AND- FULL THE
ADDRESSING SORT OF ECONOMIC.
SANCTIONS IN THE WEALTH
EXTRACTION BROUGHT ON BY THIS-
SYSTEM AND CREATES-
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS THAT
LOOK VASTLY DIFFERENT FROM.
COURT TO COURT I TYPICALLY
UTILIZING- SORT OF ECONOMIC
REQUIREMENTS THEY DON'T- WITHIN
GET TO SORT OF. THE NATURE OF
THE RACIALIZED WEALTH GAP IN
THE ACTUAL EXPENSE OF LIVING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THAT IS WHY THE COALITION THAT
I'M PART OF THE DEBT FREE
JUSTICE COALITION- HAS BEEN
PUSHING FOR AND ADVOCATING FOR-
ABOLITION NOT ONLY IS IT SORT
OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT. MEANS OF GETTING RID
OF THIS RACIALIZED WHAT THE
EXTRACTION SYSTEM BUT IT ALSO-
IS THE MOST FAIR AND JESS AND
SO. WE WAITED- URGE- A
MINISTRATION LEGISLATION TO
AGAIN TAKE ACTION TOWARDS- A
RADIC HATING THE SEASON AND
JUST. SORT OF PROPPING UP IN
ABILITY PAY SYSTEM THAT HAS
BEEN PROVEN TO BE. INEFFECTIVE
BUT ALSO DOESN'T FULLY ADDRESS
THE RACIALIZED POLICING BAD
BRINGS ABOUT THE
DISPROPORTIONATE RATES OF.
FINES FEES AND WHAT THE
TRACTION. OKAY THANK YOU MISTER-
WE ASKED THE JUDICIAL BRANCH OF
SHELLEY CURRENT TO PLEASE
PRESENT. YES A GOOD AFTERNOON-
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
MADAM CHAIR I'M SHELLEY KERN
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL'S CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SERVICES OFFICE- I AM
SPOKE TO YOU A COUPLE OF MONTHS
AGO ABOUT- SOME OF THE RESULTS
OF THE ABILITY TO PAY PROGRAM
THAT WE'VE SEEN TO DATE- AND SO
I'M NOT GOING TO TAKE TOO LONG
AND REALLY. HAVE TIME TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS BUT I JUST JUST TO
UPDATE YOU OF THAT AND READ AND
REMIND FOLKS OF THE PROGRAM.
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL WAS ONE OF
FIVE STATE COURT SYSTEMS- TO
RECEIVE A PRICE OF JUSTICE
GRANT UNDER THE US DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION TO DEVELOP A
TOOL- TO DO ABILITY TO PAY
DETERMINATIONS THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPLEMENTED THAT FUNDING IS
MOSTLY MENTIONED- AND EXPANDED
THE PROGRAM TO ADDITIONAL
PILOTS. GOVERNOR NUISANCE
BUDGET PROPOSAL EXPANDS ATP TO
ALL FIFTY EIGHT TRIAL COURTS
OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS AND
AS MISLI MENTIONED IT PROVIDES
BACK FEEL TO THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH FOR THAT LOST REVENUE
TWELVE MILLION IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND FIFTY EIGHT
POINT FOUR MILLION- IN TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND ONWARDS.
EIGHTY P. IS NOW AVAILABLE TO
LOW INCOME CONSUMERS INSEVEN
COUNTIES AND WE ARE PLEASED
WITH WITH THE RESULTS TO DATE
WHEN THE PILOT LANGUAGE WAS
ADOPTED- THE LEGISLATURE
REQUIRED THAT THE TOOL
RECOMMEND AT LEAST A 50%
REDUCTION THE AVERAGE REDUCTION
THE COURTS ARE MAKING IS 54% OF
COURTS FOLLOW THIS TOOL
RECOMMENDATION MOST OF THE TIME
WITH OVER 70% OF REDUCTIONS
WITHIN TEN DOLLARS OF THE
RECOMMENDED AMOUNT. AND THIS
SAVES THE AVERAGE LOW AND
CONSUMER SEVERAL HUNDRED
DOLLARS EIGHTY P. ALSO
ADDRESSES THE ISSUE A LICENSE
SUSPENSION AN ISSUE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS RAISED CONCERNS
ABOUT FOR MANY YEARS NOW USING
EIGHTY P. COUNTS AS AN
APPEARANCE SO USERS AVOID
FAILURE TO APPEAR CITATIONS
WITH NO SUBSEQUENT LICENSE
HOLDS AND NO SIMPLE
ASSESSMENTS. AS OF MAY FIFTH
NEARLY EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
REQUESTS WERE APPROVED FROM
OVER FOURTEEN THOUSAND
LITIGANTS- AND. AND A TOTAL OF
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS- THE
APPROVED AND WE- ACROSS NINE
TWO PER. OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
LIVE BELOW 210050% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LIMIT LIMIT.
AND USERS LIKE THE TOOL WE
CONDUCT AN ONLINE SURVEY TO GET
USER FEEDBACK- WITHOUT THE
TOOL. USERS HAVE TO- TRAVEL TO
COURT TO ASK FOR A REDUCTION IN
THERE AND THE AMOUNT OF. AND
THIS ACTUALLY ADDS TO THE COST
OF BY TRANSPORTATION OR
CHILDCARE OR TAKING A DAY OFF
OF WORK. WHEN WE DEVELOP THE
TOOL WE RECEIVED INPUT FROM
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY EAST BAY COMMUNITY LAW
CENTER- IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
WE CAN MAKE THE TOOLS
ACCESSIBLE AS POSSIBLE. AND SO
IN RESPONSE TO SOME DAY THE
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED IN THE
FEEDBACK THAT WE RECEIVED- WE
MADE THE TOOL AVAILABLE ON
DESKTOPS. AND TABLETS AND ON
SMARTPHONES. WHICH WAS
AVAILABLE IN BOTH ENGLISH AND
SPANISH AND HAS A CHATBOT
FUNCTION IN BOTH OF THOSE AS
WELL. AT LEAST WE SURVEY USERS
AND OVER 92% OF RESPONDENTS
FELT THAT THE ABILITY TO PAY
TOOL WAS HELPFUL- IN RESPONSE
TO QUESTIONS ABOUT- WHY IT IS
THAT THEY THEY FOUND IT HELPFUL
AND WHAT MADE IT DIFFICULT TO
COME TO COURT THEY SAID- TAKING
TIME OFF WORK AND FINING
TRANSPORTATION WITH THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES THAT THEY
IDENTIFIED. THAT WE REQUESTED
THE- THAT THE LEGISLATURE ADOPT
THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY PROPOSAL
AND I'M. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
OKAY MEMBERS COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. SALINAS OKAY- I JUST
WANT TO ASK HERE. HELLO THERE
WERE SEVERAL OFTHE ISSUES THAT
WERE RAISED WITH THE PILOTS
CREATION WAS THE- THAT THE
REDUCTION IN FEES AND FINES
WERE OPTIONAL- IT RECOMMENDED A
FIFTY PERCENT- A REDUCTION OF
50% OF THE TOTAL AMOUNT IT WAS
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO UP MET A
CERTAIN NOT THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL 125% POP SO CONSIDER
WE'VE GONE THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC- AND- OF. OUR CONCERN
ABOUT THE NEED TO RELIEVE ANY
FINANCIAL BARRIERS. OF HAS THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL RECONSIDERED
CHANGES TO THE ELIGIBILITY
PERCENT REDUCTION OR MANDATES-
USE OF THE TOOL. WE'RE WE'RE
HAPPY TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND-
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ABOUT-
DIFFERENT PERCENT PROVISIONS IN
THE LEGISLATION I WILL POINT
OUT THAT THAT MINIMUM 50%
REQUIREMENT IS ACTUALLY
INCLUDED AND STATUTE THAT WAS
SOMETHING- THAT WAS DISCUSSED
WHEN THE ORIGINAL PILOTS WERE
INCLUDED- AT THE REQUEST OF THE
LEGISLATURE- THAT LEGISLATION
WAS AMENDED TO ACTUALLY PUT
THAT 50% AND SO AS I SAID WHERE
WE ARE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS ON. THE SAY
THAT ALL THE COURTS ARE MADE
50% REDUCTION. I MEAN THAT WAS
A REQUIREMENT THAT A MINIMUM OF
50% ARE A MAXIMUM THE
REQUIREMENT IS THAT THE TOOL
ITSELF RECOMMENDED A 50%
REDUCTION THE AVERAGE REDUCTION
AMONG ALL OF THE REDUCTIONS
THAT HAVE HAPPENED IS ABOUT 54%
THERE'S A RANGE AMONG THE
COURTS SOME COURTS ARE JUST
BELOW 50% OTHER COURTS ARE UP
278% IN TERMS OF THE AVERAGE
REDUCTION THAT THEY PROVIDED TO
CONSUMERS. SO THAT AMOUNT IS
STILL- OPTIONAL AS FAR AS-
WHETHER OR NOT MEET THE FIFTY
PERCENT. YES I'M A WITCH IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE- JUDICIAL
DISCRETION YES IT'S- IT'S
OPTIONAL- C. AND THEN JUST GIVE
ME GIVE ME AN EXAMPLE KIND OF
WALK ME THROUGH WHY WOULD IT A
JUDICIAL OFFICER NOT RECOMMEND
A REDUCTION OF TO SOMEONE WHO
IS QUALIFIED. SO ABOUT 75% OF
THE- OF OTHER REQUESTS THAT ARE
MADE ARE APPROVED BY THE
JUDICIAL OFFICER WE'VE GONE
THROUGH ON COLLECTED DATA ON
THE REASONS THAT THEY HAVE NOT
BEEN ACCEPTED 75% OF THOSE THAT
HAVE BEEN REJECTED. WERE
REJECTED FOR REASONS LIKE- THE
PERSON HAS A MISDEMEANOR IN THE
CITATION MISDEMEANORS ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS PROGRAM. THE
REQUESTED TO DUPLICATE OF ONE
ALREADY UNDER REVIEW- THEY'VE
ALREADY SCHEDULED A COURT DATE-
THEY HAVE A FIX IT TICKET AND
THEY MIGHT BE ENCOURAGED TO
COME IN AND FIX THE TICKET AND
HAVE THE FEE WAIVED. THERE ARE
OTHER INSTANCES WHERE THE
PERSON'S INCOME ELIGIBILITY IS
HIGHER THAN THE AMOUNT WOULD BE
ANOTHER REASON BUT WE ARE
SEEING ABOUT A SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT- FIVE APPROVAL RATES OF
THE OF THE REQUESTS THAT ARE
MADE. I THINK THAT JUST THE
ISSUE OF WORK WHAT ARE WE
FACING HERE. EIGHT POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS IN FINES AND
FEES REMAIN OUTSTANDING THAT'S
AN EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNT OF
MONEY OWED BY INDIVIDUALS- SO
THAT'S MY CONCERN IS ARE WE
REALLY IT REMINDS ME OF THE
OTHER- LAST YEAR IN THE DAM-
SENATOR MITCHELL RAISED AND
THAT WE RAISED ABOUT FEES JUST
ACCUMULATING. ARE OVER AND OVER
YEAR AFTER YEAR WE'RE NOT
COLLECTING THEM SO WHERE DO WE
WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO ABOUT IT
OTHER THAN IT JUST HANGS OVER
AND CAUSES ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
PROBLEMS FOR THOSE WHO- SO-
THAT'S MY CONCERN IS. ARE WE
REALLY GETTING ANYWHERE WITH
THIS OTHER THAN- OF PLACING
THAT PRESSURE ON PEOPLE TO PAY
WHEN THEY OBVIOUSLY DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO PAY- I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS.
ABOUT THAT. I WOULD I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT- THE FILM
CATALYST FOR DOING THIS PROGRAM
IS TO ADDRESS THE ECONOMIC
NEEDS OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WHO OTHERWISE
DON'T HAVE AN ABILITY TO PAY
AND SO IT REALLY IS A PROACTIVE
STEP. IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
RELIEF TO PEOPLE AND TO BREAK
DOWN SOME OF THOSE BARRIERS AS
I ALREADY MENTIONED RIGHT WHEN
SOMEONE HAS TO GO INTO COURT
AND TAKE A DAY OFF OF WORK OR
GET CHILD CARE- THOSE ARE THE
SORTS OF BURDENS AND THE
OBSTACLES THAT WE'RE TRYING TO-
TRYING TO ALLEVIATE WITH THE
ADOPTION OF THIS PROGRAM. YEAH
PLUS THE FACT PEOPLE JUST DON'T
HAVE THE MONEY. YES- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MISTER- MISTER
BRANDON GREEN. YES I'M SORRY
COULD YOU COULD YOU SHARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ABOUT THAT AS WELL.
SURE SO- AS I MENTIONED-
PREVIOUSLY I CO LED THE
DECOMPOSITION PROBABLY CONNECT
THE STAKING LAWCENTER AND
PRIMARILY- WHAT WE DID IN THAT
CLINIC WAS ADVOCATE FOR FOLKS
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY SUPERIOR
COURT- AND SO- YOU KNOW THIS
THE IDEA THAT YOU CAN KIND OF-
MAKE MORE- FACING SORT OF LIKE
THE INJUSTICE THAT ALREADY
HAPPENS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
SEE ON THE GROUND SO FOR
EXAMPLE- IF THE AVERAGE- IF
THERE'S- THAT MUCH LEEWAY
BETWEEN THE- REDUCTIONS THAT
PEOPLE ARE GETTING BETWEEN
FIFTY AND SEVENTY EIGHT
PERCENT. AND THAT MEANS
DEPENDING UPON WHERE YOU'RE
GETTING YOUR TICKET FOR EXAMPLE
HEY- THE PRODUCTION THAT YOU
GET MIGHT BE HIGHER WHEN
PLACING IN ANOTHER PLACE IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT
IT TOOK US YEARS TO SORT OF
PUSH THE COURT AWAY FROM USING
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LINE- TO
USE IN THE HOOD STANDARD IN
FROM USING THE LOWEST PORTION
OF THE HAD STATED TO. THE
MEDIUM AND HIGH FORCING BAD
READY SORT OF GOT AA- THE COST
OF LIVING IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
BECAUSE IF YOU GO TO- WHILE THE
MAIL IN OAKLAND THE VAST
MAJORITY PEOPLE THEY SHE GOING
TO SEE- TO BE BLACK AND BROWN
FOLKS RIGHT WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AT THE LOWER
INCOME BRACKET IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND SO PRIMARILY YOU
KNOW AS I SAID IN MY PUBLIC.
COMMENT A SECOND GO TO THIS IS
THE ISSUE OF OVER
CRIMINALIZATION OF BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES- SPECIFICALLY
AND SO WHILE IT MAY BE TRUE
TODAY- IT'S MORE A FISHING FOR
FOLKS NOT TO GO LEAN WE HAD A
LOT OF CLIENTS THAT ISSUES
BEING ABLE TO GO INTO INTO
COURT IF YOU CAN GOING TO COURT
AND GET 80% REDUCTION BUT YOU
CAN ONLY GET A 50% REDUCTION BY
USING THE ONLINE TOOL THEY CAN
BE MORE BENEFICIAL FOR YOU TO
GO. IN FRONT OF THE COURT OR TO
PUT IN THE PAPERWORK AS YOU
AFTER DOING ABSOLUTELY COUNTY
BUT OVERALL. YOU KNOW I THINK
THIS SORT OF- BRIDE. THE BRIDE
OF THE REDUCTIONS OF GET TO THE
POINT THAT. ABILITY TO PAY JUST
AS A MAKING DESIGNED. WORK IT
DOESN'T WORK TO SORT OF A LEVY
A WITH UNDERLYING ISSUE WITH WE
SHOULD. A OVERCOME THIS OR OF
THE BLACK AND COMMUNITY WHICH
IS WHY- THIS IS PRIMARILY ISSUE
OF RACIAL AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE
BECAUSE OF PRIMARILY TALK ABOUT
FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR WHO'VE BEEN
IMPACTED BY THE SYSTEM. GREAT
THANK YOU MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR GREEN- THIS WORD THIS
IS A- INFORMATIONAL ITEM ONLY
SO NO ACTION IS NEEDED. SURE
ALL I'M SORRY A TO LOOK OVER NO
I APOLOGIZE SO I AM ACTUALLY
THIS IS AN INTERESTING
DISCUSSION SO- DID NOT HAVE A
QUESTION TO- COULD GET
INTERESTING- AND I APPRECIATE
MR GREEN'S COMMENTS SO YOU
KNOW. WE CLEARLY SHOULDN'T FIND
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM ON
FINE SPRAY THEM INTO THAT THAT-
THAT WAS NEVER THE INTENT. AND
THE INTENT OF FINANCES TO
CREATE A DETERRENT FOR
MISBEHAVIOR. WE SHOULD PROBABLY
WHAT'S THE LOWEST FINE WE COULD
HAVE TO CREATE THE DETERRENT.
AND MY QUESTION FOR. ANYBODY
HERE IS HAVE WE GIVEN ANY
THOUGHT. TO LOOKING AT THIS IN
THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION MAYBE
INSTEAD OF REDUCING FINES
DOWNWARD. WITH RESPECT TO
ABILITY TO PAY MAYBE WE SHOULD
JUST FIND UPWARD YOU KNOW START
AT THE AT THE LOWEST NUMBER IS
A DO IN PLACES LIKE
SCANDINAVIA- AND DO IT
PROGRESSIVELY BASED ON YOUR
ABILITY TO PAY BUT IN THE OTHER
DIRECTION. I SAW THAT POOR
PEOPLE ARE BEING PENALIZED SO
HAVE HAS THAT EVER BEEN PART OF
THE DISCUSSION. SO IT SURE WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT- IS- IS A
DAY FIND MODEL- TO MY KNOWLEDGE
THAT HASN'T. BEEN CAN I SEE A
SEAMLESSLY WITH THEIR HAND UP
THE ONLY THING THAT I WOULD SAY
IS THAT- WHILE THAT. COULD WORK
IN BE MORE PROGRESSIVE THAN THE
CURRENT SORT OF REGRESSIVE
TAXATION- THAT EXIST. FHWA WE
STILL HAVE SORT OF THE
UNDERLYING ISSUES THAT I'M
SPEAKING TO SO- AT THE BACK OF
THE ROLL CALL THE SCENE YOU
KNOW DID A SERIES OF REPORTS
THERE'S INTERACTIVE MAPS THAT
SHOW ESSENTIALLY YOU CAN MAP-
BLACK BROWN AND- LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND YOU CAN SORT OF
DETERMINE. WHERE THE HIGHEST
DRIVER'S LICENSE SUSPENSIONS
ARE NO DON'T GET ME WRONG I
APPRECIATE THAT POINT I'M
SAYING YOU KNOW LET'S LEAVE IT
LEAVE LEAVING THAT ASIDE FOR A
MOMENT. YOU KNOW THERE'S
AMAZING PHILOSOPHICAL
DISCUSSION WE HAD HERE ABOUT
YOU KNOW IS FOR THE PURPOSE-
AND ROLL AND USE OF PENALTIES-
AND IT IT IT WOULD SEEM TO ME
THEY WERE LOOKING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION MAYBE MAYBE HIGH
INCOME PEOPLE SHOULD VERY. MUCH
MORE RIGHTS TO THEIR THEY'VE
THE PROPORTIONALLY THE SAME.
DISINCENTIVE TO DO CERTAIN
THINGS ARE DETERMINES. WHERE
WORKING PEOPLE SHOULD PAY LESS.
MAYBE THAT SHOULD BE THAT THERE
SHOULD BE THE BASELINE.
YESTERDAY FOR. MODEL WITH THE-
BE INTEREST TO HAVE A- OF.
GREAT THANK YOU- MISLI. I'M SO
CENTER NEWMAN YOU MIGHT FIND A
REPORT THAT WE PUT OUT A COUPLE
YEARS INTERESTING IT WAS FINE-
IT WAS AN ASSESSMENT OF THE
STATE'S. BROADER SYSTEM AND SO
ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WE HAD IN THERE WAS THAT WE DID
RECOMMEND AN EVALUATION OF THE
STRUCTURE OF THE ENTIRE
CRIMINAL POINTED THE SYSTEM
BECAUSE IT'S PART OF OUR WORK.
WE NOTED THAT WHERE WE ARE NOW
INVOLVED FROM BASICALLY LOTS
AND LOTS OF STATUTES BEING
PASSED OVER NUMEROUS YEARS SORT
OF BEING LAYERED ON TOP OF ONE
ANOTHER AND SORT OF OVER TIME
KIND OF THE PURPOSE AND KIND OF
WHAT WERE THE GOALS SORT OF GOT
LOST AND SO I'VE HEARD OF THAT
REEVALUATION. WE SAID THAT
THERE WERE FOUR KEY QUESTIONS
AND I THINK THE FIRST QUESTION
IS THE FIRST AFTER THE FIRST
AND SECOND QUESTION ARE IN LINE
WITH WHAT WE BROUGHT UP. SO
FIRST QUESTION IS WHAT SHOULD
BE THE GOALS OF THE SYSTEM AND
SO WE LAID OUT THIS CONCEPT OF
DETERRENCE VERSUS PROPORTIONAL
PUNISHMENT VERSES THE
MITIGATION OF CRIME THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARILY MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE
FROM ONE ANOTHER BUT DEPENDING
ON WHAT YOUR GOALS ARE YOU KIND
OF APPROACH HOW YOU SET THE
LEVELS. ETCETERA AND IN A
DIFFERENT WAY WHAT SECOND
QUESTION ALSO TIES. TO YOUR
COMMENTS IN TERMS OF. WE CALLED
IT THE BILL TO PAY IMPORT. AND
WE BASICALLY IN KNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE ARE DIFFERENT WAYS TO
THINK ABOUT. AN INDIVIDUAL'S
ABILITY TO PAY ONE OF THE
OPTIONS THAT WE RAISED WHAT IS
THE DEFINED SYSTEM IN TERMS OF
CALCULATING IT BASED ON. ON
THAT BUT ALSO THINKING ABOUT
DIFFERENT WAYS FOR YOU TO
ADDRESS PAYMENTS SO THAT. THIS
IS RAISING THE ISSUE ABOUT
COMMUNITY SERVICE ETCETERA AND
JUST TO ROUND IT OFF OF THE
THIRD QUESTION IT WHAT IS AND
WHAT SHOULD BE THE
CONSEQUENCES. IF AN INDIVIDUAL
DOESN'T PAY AND THE FOURTH WAS
IT SHOULD FINES AND FEES BE
ADJUSTED. AND SO THAT WAS YOU
KNOW SHOULD THEY AUTOMATICALLY
BE ADJUSTED IT YOU KNOW SHOULD
THERE BE A TIME HERE AND WHERE
BY WHICH LEGISLATURE ROUTINELY
COMES BACK AND EVALUATES THEM
ETCETERA. MY MORE DETAIL OR
MORE COME. WITH YOU IF YOU'RE-
AND I. IT WOULD BE WEIRD AT
THIS POINT I SAID I WASN'T
INTERESTED BUT I ACTUALLY AM SO
IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND IF YOU
COULD FOR THAT TO ME I I'D BE
GRATEFUL AND I DIE DEPRECIATE.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU. MISTER
GREEN WHAT WHAT ARE YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS. SORRY JONATHAN
ME MYSELF- SPECIFICALLY TO THE
ABILITY TO PAY BY THEIR OR MORE
BROADLY I'M BECAUSE MORE
BROADLY MY RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
ALIGNED WITH- THE COALITION
THAT WERE PART OF THE DAY FOR
JUST A COALITION WHICH IS
ELIMINATION OF FINES AND FEES-
YEAH I MEAN THAT'S THAT'S KIND
OF OUR- FANTASIES. BAY YOU KNOW
AS I TRIED TO A LITTLE TOO EVEN
WITH THAT A DAY FUNDS MODEL
SORT OF THIS IS ALL CONNECTED
TO. FROM A BROADER SYSTEM DAY
YOU KNOW THE AMOUNT OF
REDUCTION SORT OF THE SAME. J.
TWO IS HELPFUL. NO DOUBT- BUT-
ALL THE SIGNS OF FEES BECOME
ALBATROSSES ON BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES WHO AGAIN ARE THE
ONES OVER REPRESENTING ALL OF
THE SYSTEM. OKAY THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES ANY MORE QUESTIONS
OKAY WELL I WANNA THANK YOU-
FOR MAKING THE PRESENTATION WE
ARE REALLY APPRECIATED AND YOU
CERTAINLY GOT OUR ATTENTION
HERE- THAT WE WOULDN'T HAVE
OTHERWISE HAD WITHOUT DONE
WITHOUT YOUR POINTS OF VIEW SO
THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED- THIS WAS A AGAIN
AN INFORMATIONAL ITEM ON NO
ACTION IS NEEDED- SO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUED.
TO AND THIS IS ABOUT THE SPRING
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROPOSALS FOR
THE CDC ARE AND- WHO IS HERE
FROM CDC OURS THAT MR LEAVE. I
GUESS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHRIS
LEAVES ON THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR CDCR AS DISABILITY PLANNING
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT
DIVISION- THIS ITEM CONCERNS-
THREE TOP OUT LIKE PROPOSALS-
THAT WERE SUBMITTED AS PART OF
THIS SPRING FINANCED LETTER
PROCESS. AT THE FIRST PROPOSAL
IS AN INCREASE OF POLICE
REVENUE AUTHORITY FOR FORTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND- FORWARD THE
HEALTHCARE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM- PROJECTS. AS NOTED IN
THE AGENDA THERE ARE- PROJECTS
REMAINING AT SIXTEEN OF THE
TWENTY FIVE INSTITUTIONS THAT
ARE FUNDED FROM THIS SOURCE.
AND OF THE- OF THE- SIXTEEN
INSTITUTIONS- THAT HAVE WORK
REMAINING- THIS FUNDING WILL-
PROVIDE- IT'S JUST A FUNDING
FOR TO COMPLETE PROJECTS AT
ELEVEN OF THE INSTITUTIONS- THE
OTHER FIVE ARE EXPECTED TO-
COMPLETE WITHIN THEIR EXISTING
AUTHORITY- THE SECOND PROPOSAL
IS EIGHT HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
FOR THE PRELIMINARY PLANS PAYS.
FOR PROJECTS TO- PRETTY. TO
CONSTRUCT TWO NEW GROUNDWATER
SUPPLY WELLS- TO PROVIDE A
SUSTAINABLE WATER SOURCE FOR
AFFORDABLE WATER AT CHUCKWALLA
PAPERS AND IRONWOOD STATE
PRISON- THE INSTITUTION'S
ORIGINALLY HAD SIX WELLS THE-
SERVER THE TWO INSTITUTIONS-
BECAUSE OF MAINTENANCE ISSUES
TO OF THE WELLS HAVE BEEN AT
THE COMMISSION- THERE ARE TWO
THAT ARE CURRENTLY OFFLINE THAT
WE'RE AT IT'S TEMPTING TO GET
REPAIRED. AND THERE ARE TWO
THAT ARE OPERATING- THAT DON'T
QUITE MEET. ATHLETES IS FOR X.
MEN THAT THE INSTITUTIONS- SO
THIS PROJECT IS NECESSARY TO-
PROVIDE- AND IN ADDITIONAL TO
WELLS- THAT WE CAN HAVE A
RELIABLE WATER SUPPLY FOR. THE
AT THE BILL DAYS IS A
SUPPLEMENTAL CORPORATION FOR
ELEVEN MILLION FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY ONE THOUSAND A POLICE
REVENUE AUTHORITY. FOR THE-
IT'S TRACK PROJECTS THAT ARE IN
ONE STATE PRISON- THIS
SUPPLEMENTAL PREPARATION IS
NECESSARY- FOR THE- TWO FUNDS
EIGHT. INCREASED COSTS THAT ARE
RELATED TO EXTEND I'M ONE OF
THE PROJECT- WHICH WERE CAUSED
BY- SOME DESIGNERS EMISSIONS-
AND THEN- DURING COPAYS WE HAD-
I THINK YOU WERE HOUSING UNITS
AVAILABLE AT ANY GIVEN TIME- SO
THAT SLOW PROJECTS OF PROGRESS
AND- BAND THERE IS SOME
UNFORESEEN FIELD CONDITIONS
THAT ALSO EXTENDED THE PROJECT
TIMELINE- BUT WITHOUT OVER
BEYOND HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
BELIAU ARE MISTER PUSH MORAL.
THANK YOU LOOK KISHA MORROW
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. WE DON'T HAVE A CONCERN
WITH THE NUMBER OF THESE
PROPOSALS ARE WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ON THAT HEALTH CARE
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS
BONTA FIRST ARRIVAL MORE
BACKGROUND THE FUNDING FOR
THESE PROJECTS THE FIRST
APPROVED IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE- AND THE PRODUCTS ARE
INTENDED TO RENOVATE EXPAND
TREATMENT SPACES TO IMPROVE
MEDICAL CARE IN. PRISON
FACILITIES. THE WAY THE PROJECT
WAS STRUCTURED IN THIS FUNDING
WAS FIRST APPROVED LIST ALL THE
PROJECT AT ALL THE PRISONS FOR
THE HEALTH CARE FACILITY
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS LIKE THAT-
ARE CONSIDERED ONE PROJECT FOR
THE PURPOSE OF BUDGIE
BUDGETING. THERE'S A LOT OF
ADMINISTRATION TO MOVE MONEY
BETWEEN THE PROJECTS AND ALSO
ALLOWS LIMITATION TO AUGMENT
THE TOTAL AMOUNT BY TWENTY
PERCENT. WITH FIRE INVOCATION
TO THAT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE- SENSING. FOR THE
FUNDING FOR THIS THE FIRST
PROVE THAT THE NUMBER OF
CHANGES NECESSARY TO BRING THE
PROJECTS IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
FIRE LIFE AND SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS. AND TO ADDRESS
THESE COST INCREASES THE
LEGISLATURE HAS IMPROVED ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE POINT FOUR
MILLION IN ADDITIONAL. LEASE
REVENUE FOR THESE PROJECTS. ALL
GIVE ABILITY TO AUGMENT AMOUNT
BY TWENTY PERCENT- BADLY USED
EIGHTEEN POINT 5% OF THE TWENTY
PERCENT. OFF AUTHORITY OR TOTAL
OF ONE HUNDRED NINETY POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS. THIS PROPOSAL-
WHAT ALLOW THE MINISTRATION TO.
RECEIVE ADDITIONAL ALL THESE
REVENUE AUTHORITY AND IS
BECAUSE THE PROP DEPARTMENT
CONGRESS JACKS. THAT ARE FOR
THE RATE INCREASES FOR COST OF
THE LEVEL OF THE TICKET
PROJECTS THAT WOULD CAUSE IT TO
EXCEED THE FIFTEEN POINT ONE
MILLION THAT COULD BE REMAINS
BELOW ITS 20% POLITICIAN WOMEN.
ENTER THE REQUESTING FORTY
POINT TWO MILLION ADDITIONAL
LEASE REVENUE AUTHORITY.
BECAUSE THE TECHNOLOGY THAT I
KNOW THE 20% THIS COULD RESULT
IN A TOTAL OF FIFTY ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION. DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY FOR THESE
PROJECTS. WE FIND THAT WHILE IT
IS GENERALLY APPROPRIATE TO
INCREASE OF THE TRAVELER OF THE
WORLD FOR THESE PROJECTS. IT
WOULD NOT BE COST EFFECTIVE
RIDE ADDITIONAL CONSTRUCTION.
ORTEGA PROJECT PRISON THAT'LL
BE CLOSE IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
FOUNDED THE DECLINING PRISON
POPULATIONS STUDENTS ARE
ALREADY ANNOUNCED PLANS TO
CLOSE TO PRISONS BY TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. AND WE
ESTIMATE THAT THE STATE WILL BE
IN A POSITION BECAUSE ANOTHER
THREE PRISONS BY. TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR POINT FIVE. IT BASED ON
CARNEY REVIEW WE BUT IN A
NUMBER OF PRISONS ARE STRONG.
FOR CLOSURE LARGELY DUE TO
HIGHEST OF COSTS OPERATE COSTS
FOR. RELATIVE TO THE CAPACITY
WITHIN THOSE PRISONS. IT
DIFFICULT TO ONCE AGAIN IF I
THE- READABILITY CENTER NORCO.
INCLUDING STATE. CORRECTIONAL
TWENTY TO IN SEOUL. AND
CALIFORNIA MAY COLONY SEEMS
CDNS OBISPO. AND DESPITE CMC
STRONGER FORECLOSURE. IT EASIER
HAS THAT GOING TO MILLION AND
PROPOSAL WOULD BE UTILIZED FOR
A PROJECT AT YOU SEE. THIS IS A
THAT SIMPLY POTENTIALLY CLOSE
WE OR SHORTLY THE PROJECT IS
COMPLETE. WE RECOMMEND NOT THE-
PROPOSED TO ENSURE THAT FUNNY
IS NOT ON. ON CHRIS ARE SHORTLY
THEREAFTER. THIS IS A GREAT
RESOURCE FOR DIRECT THE NEWS OF
TO LIVE OF REASONS ARE STRONG
FOR. SECOND ALLEGED COMMAND
USERS IN TO IF IT AGREES WITH
ASSESSMENT OFF FIND THAT OTHER
PERSON TO BE STRONG CANDIDATES.
TOWARD THE LESSER COULD APPROVE
BY THE TRAILER STATE TO FOR ME
FROM USING A THE REVENUE FOR
THE PROJECT AT PRISONS THE
VIEWS A STRONG CANDIDATES FOR.
FOURTH THE MINISTRATION COULD
ADJUST THE INCREASINGLY
REGULATORY ACCORDINGLY SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF THE LEGISLATURE
AGREES THAT SEEMS EVEN STRONGER
CANADA CLOSER THEY COULD REDUCE
THE PROPOSAL IS REVENUE THIRTY
EIGHT POINT TWO MILLION WHICH
IS THAT NOT A LETTER INDICATES
THAT TIME ADMINISTRATION. WE
RECOMMEND CORRECTING THE
MINISTRATION TO NOT USE ITS
ABILITY TO AUGMENT THE
LEGISLATIVELY QUIGLEY'S
REGULATORY PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
PROJECTS PRISONS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS FROM CAN ITS
CLOSURE. YEAH THE LEGISLATURE
ASSESSMENT THE COULD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- FINANCE- YOU'D LIKE
TO COMMENT. BRING ON RUNNING
HER SUPPORT IN A FINANCE WE
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING FURTHER TO
ADD. OKAY COLLEAGUES MAY I
RESPOND TO THE L. L. CUMMINS.
WOOD COUNTY- CHRIS OKAY YES GO
AHEAD MR LEAF. THANK YOU- SO-
IT WILL BE UNDERSTAND THE
LEGISLATURE IS CONCERNED IN LA
IS CONCERNED ABOUT- THE
SPENDING MONEY ON IT ABSOLUTELY
IS THAT ARE LIKELY TO BE
CLOSED- I WOULD I WOULD POINT
OUT TWO THINGS- ONE EIGHT IN
GENERAL THIS ADDITIONAL FUNDING
IS FOR ACTIVE PROJECTS NOT TO
START NEW PROJECTS. AND TO- FOR
AS CMC IN PARTICULAR- ALTHOUGH
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT
PROPOSED ANY ADDITIONAL PRISONS
FOR CLOSURE BEYOND- TPI AND
CCC- C. R. A C. M. C. HAS A
MENTAL HEALTH- COMMISSION. THAT
IS A VERY IMPORTANT TO THE
DEPARTMENT AND WHICH CONTINUES
TO BE OF CONCERN TO THE COMMON
COURT FOR HAVING A CAPACITY FOR
MENTAL HEALTH. PROGRAMS WHICH
WOULD- ARGUE IN FAVOR OF ITS
CONTINUED OPERATION THANK.
THANK YOU- EITHER TO THE CDC OR
OR- BELIAU CAN YOU GIVE US SOME
BACKGROUND ON THE INITIAL LEASE
REVENUE BOND APPROPRIATION AND
THE OF INCREASES IN
AUGMENTATION UP AUGMENTATION
AUTHORITY. AND DO YOU
ANTICIPATE INCREASES IN THE
FORTY FOR THE FUTURE YEARS. D.
THE REQUEST TO THE FORTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS I REQUEST
BEFORE YOU NOW REPRESENTS OUR
BEST ESTIMATE OF WHAT IT WOULD
TAKE TO COMPLETE THE PROGRAM-
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT WE WOULDN'T
HAVE TO COME BACK OR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING- BUT THAT WILL BE
EVALUATED AGAIN AS OF THE
PROJECT- CONTINUE. OKAY THE L.
A. O. HAVE ANY COMMENT ON THAT.
NO FURTHER COMMENTS ELIZABETH
OKAY. OKAY- IF THERE NO
FURTHER- QUESTIONS FOR MARK MY
COLLEAGUES THEN WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD OPEN
THESE PROPOSALS THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH. ARE WE MOVE ON NOW
TO ISSUE THREE. OF AND THAT IS
THE STATE A REMOTE
COMMUNICATIONS AT CDC OUR ADULT
PRISONS. I BELIEVE. KRISTIN
MONTGOMERY. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS KRISTA MONTGOMERY
AND I AM THE ACTING DIRECTOR
FOR ENTERPRISE INFORMATION
SERVICES AT CDC ARE. IN MARCH
OF TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY CDC
ARE TEMPORARILY STOPPED IN
PERSON VISITING TO CURTAIL THE
SPREAD OF CODE NINETEEN VIRUS
IN PRISONS. CDCR DISCUSSED
AVENUES TO BEGIN REUNIFICATION
PROCESS DURING THE PANDEMIC.
CDCR INITIATE INITIATED BDO
VISITATION IN DECEMBER TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY IS A VEHICLE
CONNECT CONNECT FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. AS PART OF CCAR'S
CONTINUED EFFORTS TO MAINTAIN
THE FAMILY CONNECTIONS GTL
PROVIDED FREE PHONE CALLING
DAYS FOR ONE YEAR. STARTED IN
MARCH OF TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
AND ENDED IN MARCH OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE FOR A TOTAL
OF FORTY SIX RECALLING DAYS. IN
THE WINTER OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WE BEGAN THE PILOT AT
THE FIVE SITES LISTED IN THE
AGENDA TO ALLOW US TO
OPERATIONALIZE THE USE OF
TABLETS IN THE HE ASKED TO
PROVIDE EXPANDED COMMUNICATIONS
CAPABILITY. INCLUDING SECURE
ELECTRONIC MESSAGING IN BONN
VIDEO CLIPS AND PHOTOS. IN THE
SUMMER OF TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
CITIES HERE OUR WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY THERESA COMPETITIVE
OPEN SOLICITATION FOR NEW
SERVICES TO CONSOLIDATE ALL
COMMUNICATIONS. LEVERAGE A
REDUCTION IN COMMUNICATION
RATES. THE NEW CONTRACT WAS
AWARDED TO GTL PROVIDES GREATLY
REDUCED RATES WHICH WENT INTO
EFFECT ON MARCH NINETEENTH.
THIS IS A SIX YEAR CONTRACT
WITH FOUR ONE YEAR OPTIONS. IN
ADDITION TO THE REDUCED RATE OF
TELEPHONE CALLS THE CONTRACTS
THAT'S THE DEPARTMENT ON THE
PATH TO ENHANCE COMMUNICATIONS
TECHNOLOGY ACROSS THE STATE.
INCLUDING EXPANDING ACCESS TO
TABLETS AND KIOSKS. EVERY
INCARCERATED PERSON RECEIVES
FIFTEEN MINUTES OF FREE
TELEPHONE CALLS EVERY TWO WEEKS
FOR THE ENTIRETY OF THE
CONTRACT AND ALL USE CALLS
REMAIN FREE OF CHARGE. THE
CONTRACT WITH THE PREVIOUS
MULTI TIERED CALLING RATE WHICH
WAS PREVIOUSLY SEVEN POINT SIX
CENTS. PER IN STATE AND TWENTY
ONE CENTS FOR OUT OF STATE. TO
NATIONWIDE RATE OF TWO POINT
FIVE CENTS PER MINUTE. THIS
CONTRACT ALSO PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL COMMUNICATION
CAPABILITIES LIKE SENDING AND
RECEIVING SECURE MESSAGES.
RECEIVING VIDEO CLIPS AND
PHOTOS FROM LOVE ONCE. THE
RATES FOR MESSAGING WILL BE
REDUCED FROM THE CURRENT RATE
AT PILOT SITES FROM THIRTY FIVE
CENTS PER MESSAGE NINETY FIVE
CENTS. THE CAR'S RATED
INDIVIDUALS WERE IN GINGIN
GINGIN WILL RECEIVE FIVE FREE
MESSAGE CREDITS PER WEEK. THE
SERVICES WILL BE AVAILABLE ON
TABLETS THAT ARE PROVIDED FREE
OF CHARGE TO THE INCARCERATED I
DON'T KIOSKS INSTALLED IN THE
HOUSING UNITS. WE ARE TURNING
HOW TO KIOSKS AND TABLETS
IMPLEMENT AT THE ADULT
INSTITUTIONS BY THE END OF THIS
CALENDAR YEAR. WITH VALLEY
STATE PRISON BEING OUR FIRST
SITE. WHICH IS CURRENTLY
SCHEDULED FOR MID JUNE.
STATEWIDE WE HAVE PRIORITIZED
YOUTHFUL OFFENDER
REHABILITATION COMMUNITIES. AND
PROGRESSIVE PROGRAMMING
FACILITIES IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION SCHEDULE. VIDEO
CALLS WILL ALSO BE AVAILABLE ON
THE NEW SOLUTION INCARCERATED
INCARCERATED PEOPLE WILL
RECEIVE FIFTEEN MINUTES OF FREE
VIDEO CALLS IN ADDITION TO FREE
PHONE CALLING EVERY TWO WEEKS
FOR THE ENTIRETY OF THE
CONTRACT. ADDITIONAL VIDEO
CALLS WILL BE TOOK CHARGE AT A
RATE OF TWENTY CENTS PER MINUTE.
ON APRIL TENTH TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE IN PERSON VISITING
BEGAN AGAIN WITH A LIMIT OF ONE
VISIT PER MONTH. FOR ONE HOUR.
BASED ON THE DEPARTMENTS RE
OPENING ROAD MAP CDCR IS NOT
IMPLEMENTING AN EXTENSION TO
OUR VISITS. FOR TWO ADDITIONAL
VISITORS BEGINNING ON MAY
FIFTEENTH TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE. IF CONDITIONS WARRANT CDCR
IS PROPOSING TO REINSTITUTE
FAMILY VISITING ON JUNE SEVENTH
OF THIS YEAR. NOW LET ME
DESCRIBE SOME ADDITIONAL
DETAILS OR SPECIFIC AREAS OF
THE PANEL MAY BE INTERESTED IN.
BARELY A PRINCE MISSTEPS A
PREPAID ACCOUNT WITH GTL TO
ALLOW THEIR INCARCERATED FAMILY
MEMBER TO CALL THEM. WE
ELIMINATED THE CALL SET UP FEE
FOR OUR NEW CONTRACT TO MAKE
THE PROCESS EASIER. IN ADDITION
WE REMOVED THE PREVIOUS MULTI
TIER CALLING RIGHT TO A NATION
WIDE RATE OF TWO POINT FIVE
CENTS PER MINUTE. THE CONTRACT
WITH GTL WENT THROUGH A
COMPETITIVE SOLICITATION
CONDUCTED BY CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY TO OBTAIN
THE SERVICES. THE RESPONSES
REVALUATION SCORED BASED ON THE
SERVICES AND RATES OFFERED BY
THE BIDDERS. GTO WAS AWARDED
THE CONTRACT. THE AGENDA
IDENTIFIED PASSED LEGISLATION
IN COMMUNICATIONS RELATED TO
PHONE COSTS FOR ADULTS AND
JUVENILES OVER THE YEARS. OVER
THE PAST DECADE CDCR HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED COST OF
CALLING FROM STATE PRISONS AS
IDENTIFIED IN THE CHART BUDGET
IN THE AGENDA. IN MAY OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT THE CONTRACT WAS
AMENDED TO ELIMINATE CONCESSION
FEES IN ACCORDANCE WITH SENATE
BILL EIGHTY ONE. THE UNDER PER
YEARLY REVENUE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT WAS REDUCED. AS
PART OF THE CONTRACT GTL
PROVIDES MONTHLY AND ANNUAL
PERSONAL C. T. AND C. D. C. R.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THERE
WAS ABOUT THREE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION MINUTES OF
CALLING. THE FAMILIES AND
FRIENDS SPENT ABOUT TWENTY FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLIONS ON PHONE
CALLS. WITH THE NEW RATES THAT
SAME CALL LINE BECAUSE FAMILY
AND FRIENDS ABOUT EIGHT MILLION.
WE BELIEVE THE REDUCTION RATE
AS WELL AS PROVIDING FIFTEEN
MINUTES OF FREE CALLING EVERY
TWO WEEKS WILL FURTHER INCREASE
THE CALL VOLUME ALLOWING EVEN
MORE COMMUNICATION WITH
FAMILIES AND FRIENDS. ARE YOU
HAPPY TO ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. EMORY WE
GOT NOW I'D LIKE TO HAVE-
EXCUSE MY LACK OF PRONUNCIATION
DANYCH A ROTOR MURDER MILE.
STATE POLICY DIRECTOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER TO
DISCUSS THE IMPACTS ON
INCARCERATED FAMILIES AND
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE BUT I REALLY MESS
UP YOUR NAME. DANNECKER
O'DONNELL NAY DID PRETTY WELL
ROAD I'M SORRY SAY IT AGAIN RO
DARNELL ROAD GOVERNMENTAL OKAY.
IT GOOD NEWS THANK YOU. I GET
AFTERNOON AND DANNECKER-
DARNELL STATE POLICY DIRECTOR
FOR THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER AND I WANT TO START BY
THANKING STAFF FOR THEIR GREAT
WORK ON THE SIDE- AND IT'S AN
HONOR TO BE SPEAKING WITH YOU
ABOUT THIS TODAY BECAUSE I KNOW
WHAT AN IMPORTANT ISSUE THIS IS
FOR HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DIRECTLY IMPACTED CALIFORNIANS.
I ALSO HAVE PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
SOMETIMES PAYING HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS A MONTH TO KEEP IN
TOUCH WITH AN INCARCERATED
LOVED ONE. ACCESS BETWEEN
INCARCERATED PEOPLE IN THEIR
SUPPORT SYSTEMS IS TRULY A
LIFELINE. THIS IS WHY PEOPLE
WILL FORGO PAYING BILLS
SOMETIMES HAVING UTILITIES
TURNED OFF. AND OFTEN GOING
INTO DEBT IN ORDER TO DO SO.
MANY PEOPLE ARE SHOCKED AND
HORRIFIED TO LEARN THAT THE
MAJORITY OF INCARCERATED PEOPLE
HAVE EFFECTIVELY NO ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH CARE. WHAT ACCESS
THEY MAY HAVE IS OFTEN LOW
QUALITY AND REQUESTING MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT WHILE
INCARCERATED ISN'T JUST
STIGMATIZED FOR MANY IT CAN BE
USED AGAINST THEM IN THEIR
EFFORTS TO GAIN THEIR FREEDOM.
THEREFORE OFTEN INCARCERATED
PEOPLE'S ONLY OPPORTUNITY FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT IS
THROUGH THEIR CONNECTION TO
FAMILY AND FRIENDS. IT IS ALSO
CRUCIAL TO THE WELL EING OF
FAMILIES WITH INCARCERATED
MEMBERS TO BE ABLE TO KEEP IN
TOUCH WITH THEM. AS FAMILY
SEPARATION LEADS TO WORSE
OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN WITH
INCARCERATED PARENTS ANXIETY
ABOUT THE SAFETY OF A LOVED ONE
IN JAIL PRISON OR IMMIGRATION
DETENTION CAN OFTEN ONLY BE
ALLEVIATED IN THE MOMENTS OF
HEARING THEIR VOICE ON THE
OTHER END OF THE PHONE. AND
FINALLY A FAMILY CONNECTION
LONG CARS READ HAS BEEN PROVEN
TO INCREASE SUCCESSFUL REENTRY
OUTCOMES. WHICH IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE NEARLY EVERYONE
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED IN THE
STATE WILL BE RELEASED AT SOME
POINT. THE NEED FOR ACCESSIBLE
REMOTE COMMUNICATION HAS ONLY
BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE
PANDEMIC WHEN SUDDENLY ALL
ACCESS TO IN PERSON VISITS WERE
CUT OFF AND EXPENSIVE AND HIGH
DEMAND PHONE CALLS BECAME THE
ONLY WAY TO HEAR A LOVED ONE'S
VOICE. SO LET'S BE CLEAR THIS
IS A PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE. ACCESS
BETWEEN INCARCERATED PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY ON THE OUTSIDE
SHOULD BE VIEWED AS A PUBLIC
UTILITY AND IT IS WORTHY OF THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT. LOVED ONES
ON THE OUTSIDE PAY THE COST OF
KEEPING IN TOUCH WITH
INCARCERATED PEOPLE ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY NOT INCARCERATED
PEOPLE THEMSELVES. THIS IS TRUE
ACROSS THE BOARD WHEN WE
EXAMINE WHO FOOTS THE BILL FOR
MOST OF THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM
CONTACT. AND WITHOUT EXCEPTION
THESE COSTS FALL MOST HEAVILY
UPON WOMEN OF COLOR. WELL I
APPLAUD GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S
OFFICE IN CDC ARE FOR THEIR
EFFORTS IN THIS AREA THERE'S
STILL MUCH MORE TO DO. THE
ISSUE REMAINS ENTIRELY
UNADDRESSED IN OUR JAILS WHERE
THE SITUATION IS MUCH WORSE
WITH RATES AS HIGH AS SEVENTEEN
DOLLARS FOR A FIFTEEN MINUTE
CALL IN ONE COUNTY. CURRENTLY
PRIVATE TELECOM COMPANIES
CONTROL THE MARKET AND THE
SYSTEM IS SET UP TO EXTRACT
EXTRACT AS MUCH MONEY FROM
CONSUMERS AS POSSIBLE. BUT THE
GOVERNMENT HAS LEVERAGE TO
NEGOTIATE DIFFERENT CONTRACTS
AND PRICING STRUCTURES TO GET A
MUCH BETTER DEAL. THAN
INDIVIDUAL CONSUMERS CAN. FOR
EXAMPLE SAN FRANCISCO RECENTLY
BROKE THE INDUSTRY MOLD BY
CONTRACTING A FIXED RATE RATHER
THAN PERMANENT CONTRACT MAKING
IT INCREDIBLY AFFORDABLE FOR
THE COVERS CITY TO COVER THE
COST OF PHONE CALLS IN OUR
JAILS. AND MAKING UP SO LITTLE
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BUDGET
THAT IT HAS BEEN DEEMED TO
BUDGET DUST. DURING THE
PANDEMIC CDCR DID BEGIN
PROVIDING FREE VIDEO
COMMUNICATIONS WHICH IS OPENED
UP THE ABILITY FOR SOME
FAMILIES TO SEE EACH OTHER FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN YEARS. THESE
SERVICES SHOULD CONTINUE BEYOND
THE PANDEMIC WITH THE COPIER
THAT THEY SHOULD BE OFFERED IN
ADDITION TO AND NEVER IN
REPLACEMENT OF IN PERSON
VISITS. NOTHING AS A
REPLACEMENT FOR IN PERSON
CONTACT. THEREFORE I RECOMMEND
THE COMMITTEE CONSIDER THE
FOLLOWING. FIRST PROVIDE FREE
PHONE CALLS TO PEOPLE
INCARCERATED IN OUR STATE
PRISONS FOR THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR AND USE THIS PERIOD TO
EXPLORE MAKING PHONE CALLS FREE
PERMANENTLY. IT SHOULD INCLUDE
REIMAGINING STATE CONTRACTS AND
SHIFTING TOWARDS FIXED RATE
AGREEMENTS. SECOND ENSURE FREE
VIDEO COMMUNICATIONS REMAIN
AVAILABLE AT ALL OF THE STATE
RUN INSTITUTIONS. THIRD ENSURE
THAT ASKED TABLETS AND OTHER
TECHNOLOGY ARE INTRODUCED TO
PRESENTS THAT ALL OF THE
ASSOCIATED SERVICES REMAIN
AFFORDABLE OVERALL. THESE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE
CONSUMERS SHOULD BE PROTECTED
FROM PREDATORY INDUSTRY
PRACTICES AND ESSENTIAL
SERVICES LIKE EMAIL AND ACCESS
TO EDUCATIONAL MATERIAL SHOULD
BE EXTREMELY LOW COST AND FREE
WHEREVER POSSIBLE. FINALLY WE
MIGHT NEXT TURN OUR ATTENTION
TO ENSURING THAT COMMUNICATIONS
FOR PEOPLE IN JAILS IN THE
STATE ARE MADE AFFORDABLE. WHEN
AND BY SAYING THAT TRUE
ACCESSIBILITY BETWEEN
INCARCERATED PEOPLE AND THEIR
SUPPORT SYSTEMS REQUIRES
ENSURING THAT EVERYONE HAS
REASONABLE ACCESS. OUR PRISON
SYSTEM IS NOT A HOMOGENOUS
POPULATION AND MANY PEOPLE
CURRENTLY LACK ACCESS DUE TO
UNAFFORDABILITY AND
INACCESSIBILITY THEREFORE WE
MUST PROVIDE A RANGE OF OPTIONS
IN FREE PHONE CALLS AND VIDEO
COMMUNICATIONS REPRESENTS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THERE WAS A VERY VERY HELPFUL-
I THINK. COLLEAGUES YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS YES GO AHEAD
SENATE- MERGER ONE ONE VERY
SPECIFIC QUESTION- AND IT WAS-
I FORGET WHO BROUGHT IT UP BUT
THERE IS I THINK IN THE OPENING
PRESENTATION THERE WAS A
REFERENCE TO. OF THE FIVE
CREDITS FOR. INDIGENT INMATES
IN IT'S SORT OF A QUESTION JUST.
OF FOR MY FUTURE UNDERSTANDING
OF HOW THINGS ARE TO FIND IN
THE SYSTEM HOW DO YOU SEPARATE
OUT WHO'S AN INDIGENT INMATE
FROM WHO ISN'T- IT STRIKES ME.
THAT THIS IS FAIRLY EASY TO DO
THE GENERAL POPULATION BUT- AND
I MEAN THE GENERAL NON
INCARCERATED POPULATION BUT- IT
SEEMS LIKE MOST PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED. IN THE PRISON
SYSTEM WOULD BY. BY DEFINITION
BE- YOU KNOW AT LEAST ON THEIR
OWN AS ADULT HUMAN BEINGS I'M
NOT I'M NOT COUNTING. ANY
GRATUITOUS FAMILY ASSISTANCE WE
GET OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT BUT
ON THEIR OWN IT WOULD SEEM LIKE
THEY'RE- THEY'RE IN A PRETTY
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD THERE IN
TERMS OF POVERTY SO- COULD YOU
EXPLAIN THAT IT AGAIN IT'S A
QUESTION OF CURIOSITY AS MUCH
AS ANYTHING. IS CHRIS MUNGER
MEGAN- I HAVE TO GET BACK ON
THE DEFINITION OF WHAT THERE IS
DEFINITIONS WITH REGARDS TO
THAT I'LL HAVE TO GET THAT.
INFORMATION BACK TO YOU. YEAH I
GUESS I GUESS I DID HAVE A
VALUE JUDGMENT ON IT WOULD BE
IF THAT'S A VERY MARGINAL.
DIFFERENCE THEN MAYBE IT SHOULD
JUST BE ERASED AT SOME POINT-
AS AND EVERYBODY GETS THE
CREDIT- IN A BAR IN SOME OTHER
CRITERIA OTHER THAN. POVERTY I
GUESS IS A HOTEL IF YOU THE
WORD INDIGENT BUT- IF THERE'S
IF THERE'S OTHER REASONS FOR
BEHAVIOR OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
THE COME INTO PLAY THAT WOULD
BE INTERESTING TO KNOW AS WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MANAGER THEY GIVE. UP JUST A
LITTLE BIT OF A FOLLOW UP ON
THAT IS WHAT DO YOU GET THE
CREDITS FOR. D. THE CREDITS FOR
THE MESSAGING. SO IT'S THE
EMAIL MESSAGING. BUT HOW DOES
SOMEONE GET CREDITS FOR THAT IF
YOU COULD JUST EXPLAIN THAT
CONNECTION YES THANK YOU SO IT
WAS AMAZING HEY WE ARE ABLE TO
WORK WITH OUR VENDOR AND BEAT
AND WE PUT TO THEIR ACCOUNT SO
IT'S A TIED DIRECTLY TO THEIR
ACCOUNT WHEN- PAYMENTS COME IN.
THEY GET A CREDIT ON THEIR
ACCOUNT. OKAY SO THIS IS. THIS
IS PAID FOR BY. EMILY SOMEONE
WHO SENDS IN RIGHT RIGHT SO-
WHEN FRIENDS AND FAMILIES PAID
FOR- PHONE CALLS AND THAT THAT
TYPE OF THING GOES INTO THE
COUNT FOR THE INMATE AND IF
THERE'S CREDITS IT ACTUALLY
WILL BE CREDITED ON THE
INMATE'S ACCOUNT SO THE FRIENDS
AND FAMILY WILL SEE THAT
THERE'S A CREDIT. OKAY. THAT
MAKES SENSE. FOR ME THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THE FOR YOUR
FOLLOW UP QUESTION FOR ME IT'S
ENOUGH INFORMATION UNTIL WE
GET- SOUNDS LIKE WE'RE GOING TO
GET SOME SOME WRITTEN
INFORMATION LATER. THANK YOU
FOR. ADD ONE THING YES I WAS
INTO SEE IN THE STATE PRISON
SYSTEM AND THAT IS DETERMINED
BY THE AMOUNT OF MONEY ON
SOMEBODY'S BOOKS THEY CALL IT
THEIR ACCOUNT WHICH IS PUT
THERE BY FAMILY MEMBERS
GENERALLY- PEOPLE DO GET PAID
SMALL AMOUNTS OF MONEY IF
THEY'RE WORKING IN THE PRISONS
BUT GENERALLY THE AMOUNTS OF
MONEY ON THEIR ACCOUNTS ARE PUT
THERE BY FAMILY MEMBERS. OKAY
YEAH RIGHT NOW I'M SURE PHONY
FOUR FIVE EIGHT I JUST THINK.
IT MIGHT BE OUTSIDE OF FROM AN
OUTSIDE PERSPECTIVE A
DISTINCTION WITHOUT A
DIFFERENCE- IS THE IDEA THAT.
ONE INMATE HAS FAMILY THAT'S
GENEROUS AND PUTTING MONEY UP
FOR THEM AND ANOTHER INMATE
DOESN'T- MAYBE JUST NEEDS TO BE
DISREGARDED IN THIS CONTEXT IN
TERMS OF COMMUNICATIONS CAUSES
I MEAN THE IDEA WOULD BE.
ALLOWING COMMUNICATIONS TO
OCCUR. I WOULD THINK FAIRLY-
EQUITABLY ACROSS THE SYSTEM
IRRESPECTIVE OF. WHO HAS A RICH
UNCLE OR NOT FROM THIS THAT'S
OR FOR HOW LONG THAT MAY BE THE
CASE- BUT ANYWAY THAT'S JUST
MY- PERSONAL OPINION NO I AGREE
ESPECIALLY- AS WE HEAR ABOUT
HOW THIS HAS A BIG IMPACT ON
MENTAL HEALTH THIS HAS AN
IMPACT WITH REENTRY SUCCESS
MEAN ALL THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
SORT OF LOOKING FOR- YOU KNOW
TO CHANGE IN THE IN THE SYSTEM.
THIS IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT PART
I THINK MOST PEOPLE WOULDN'T
THINK OF PHONE CALLS AND VIDEOS
IN CONNECTION WITH FAMILY OF
WOULD BE SO IMPORTANT TO THE TO
THE FUTURE OF THOSE-
INDIVIDUALS AND NEWMAN THEY
JUST ADD IMAGE OF MY UNDERSTAND
IS MOST OF THE SYSTEMS ARE.
VESTIGES FROM THE OPEN YOU KNOW
WHAT TIME BEFORE BROADBAND WAS
UBIQUITOUS. AND SO IN THE
CURRENT YEAR RIGHT YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT UNREASONABLE. TO IT
INTERSERVE. IT UP BASS PROPOSED
WHERE GET RID GETS. AND THERE'S
NO EFFECTIVE COST OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS ALREADY THERE
MAYBE YOU'D PAY EXTRA FOR
ADDITIONAL ACCESS BUT- IT
SEEMS. YOU KNOW SORT OF
UNREASONABLE AND BORDERLINE
CRUEL TO DENY. PRISONERS ACCESS
TO THEIR FAMILIES DECEMBER
BECAUSE IS A VENDOR SYSTEM IN
PLACE YEAH THAT. OKAY ALL RIGHT
WELL- THEY'RE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE OUT YOU JUST ONE
MORE QUESTION FOR- LET'S SEE
WHAT WHAT WE X. EXPECT THE
TIMELINE FOR THE RESUMPTION OF
IN PERSON VISITATION TO BE. THE
TIMELINE FOR IN PERSON WE ARE
AS ARE- AS I MENTIONED WE HAVE
A DEPARTMENT- ROADMAP TO RE
OPENING. AND WE'VE ALREADY
STARTED SOME OF THE IN PERSON
VISITING- AT ALL ALL OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS. AND IN IN THAT
STARTED ON APRIL TENTH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE. AND THEN-
BY MAY FIFTEENTH TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE- WE'RE GONNA BE
IMPLEMENTING EXTENSION OF TO
OUR VISITS. FOR JUDICIAL
VISITORS. AND THEN THE WE HOPE
BY- JUNE- BY JUNE SEVENTH WILL
BE ABLE TO REINSTATE FAMILY
BUSINESS. SO YEAH THAT'S NICE
OKAY WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT I AGREE WITH YEAH I
AGREE WITH THE ISSUE THAT- THE
VIDEO- CONNECTION SHOULD NOT
REPLACE THE IN PERSON- CONTACT
THAT- THESE INDIVIDUALS COULD
HAVE WITH THEIR FAMILIES THANK
YOU JUST A QUICK DAY MAY
FIFTEENTH IS THE DAY AFTER
TOMORROW SORT OF A ON TRACK TO.
HIT THE DILLON. YES WE ARE IN
GOOD GOOD TO HEAR YEAH GREAT
OKAY WELL WE THANK BOTH OF YOU
VERY VERY MUCH FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO BE WITH US AND- PROVIDE
ALL THIS INFORMATION PRECIADO
THANK YOU. BOTH OF THIS- IS
INFORMATIONAL SIR MOVING ON TO
ISSUE FOR- WE'RE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT IMPROVING THE PAROLE
PREPARATION PROCESS WE'RE GONNA
HAVE- JAMES KING CAMPAIGN
MANAGER AT THE ELLA BAKER
CENTER. TO TESTIFY AND PROVIDE
HIS RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE THANK YOU FOR BEING
GOOD AFTERNOON AFTERNOON HERE
AND EACH MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY. MY NAME
IS JAMES KING AND CAMPAIGN
MANAGER AT THE ELLA BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS.
THEY'RE LIKE TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT A MODEST REFORM THAT CAN
POTENTIALLY HAVE AN OUTSIZED
IMPACT UPON PAROLE SUITABILITY
RATES. FOR INCARCERATED PEOPLE
WERE GOING TO THEIR INITIAL
PAROLE BOARD HEARINGS. ADDING
ONE ADDITIONAL HOUR OF A TURN
TIME FOR A TOTAL OF TWO HOURS
WITHIN THE FIRST THIRTY DAYS OF
THEIR- FIRST GADGIL PAROLE
BOARD HEARING WILL HELP PEOPLE
SERVING LIFE SENTENCES WHO HAVE
NEVER BEEN TO THE PRO PROCESS.
WITH PREPARATION AND IMPROVING
GRANT RATES. I WAS PREVIOUSLY
INCARCERATED WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
AND IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
NINETEEN I WAS INFORMED THAT I
WILL GO BEFORE THE PAROLE BOARD
HEARING. TO DETERMINE MY
SUITABILITY FOR RELEASE THAT
APPROACHING AUGUST. A FEW WEEKS
LATER I RECEIVED A VISIT FROM A
STATE APPOINTED ATTORNEY
INFORMED ME THAT THEY WOULD
REPRESENT ME DURING MY HEARING.
AT THE TIME THE ATTORNEY WASN'T
FAMILIAR WITH MY CONVICTION
HISTORY. THE REASON I WAS IN
PRISON OR ANYTHING I'D DONE
WHILE IN PRISON. I WANTED
ADVICE ABOUT MY ODDS OF SUCCESS
ATTENTION HURDLES TO BEING
FOUND SUITABLE AND THINGS I
COULD BETTER WORK ON TO PREPARE
MYSELF. INSTEAD WE USED OUR
FIRST MEETING FOR ME TO TELL
HER ABOUT MYSELF IN FOR HER TO
GIVE ME A GENERAL OVERVIEW OF
THE PAROLE PROCESS. ABOUT A
MONTH LATER I RECEIVED AN
APPOINTMENT FOR A COMPREHENSIVE
RISK ASSESSMENT OR CRA. CRA IS
A PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSESSMENT
CONDUCTED BY FORENSIC
PSYCHOLOGIST TO DETERMINE AN
INDIVIDUAL'S RISK FOR FUTURE
VIOLENCE OF RECIDIVISM. DURING
THE ASSESSMENT I WAS ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT MY CHILDHOOD
CRIMINAL HISTORY INSIGHT INTO
WHY I COMMITTED MY COMMITMENT
OFFENSE WE ABILITY OF WORK I'VE
DONE SINCE COMING TO PRISON AS
WELL AS DISCIPLINARY HISTORY
AND POST RELEASE PLANS. I'D
LATER FIND OUT THAT THESE WERE
ALL TOPICS THAT WILL BE COVERED
IN EVEN MORE DEPTH THAT MY
PAROLE HEARING. AND THE ANSWERS
ARE GIVEN TO THE FORENSIC
PSYCHOLOGISTS WERE INTEGRAL
PART OF THE PREPARATION OF
PAROLE COMMISSIONERS WERE GOING
TO ASSESS MY SUITABILITY FOR
RELEASE. I'VE BEEN DILIGENTLY
DOING MY OWN REHABILITATIVE
WORK FOR FIFTEEN YEARS LEADING
UP TO THIS FINAL SIX MONTHS.
BUT WHILE GOING THROUGH THIS
PROCESS I LEARNED THAT THERE'S
A HUGE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
INTERNALIZING THE SKILLS I NEED
TO SAFELY REENTER SOCIETY. AND
EXPRESSING THAT INSIGHT REMORSE
IN PREPARATION TO OTHERS. MY
LACK OF KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE
PROCESS AND WHAT WAS EXPECTED
OF ME LARGELY LEFT ME AT RISK
OF FAILING TO BE FOUND
SUITABLE. EVEN THOUGH I'VE BEEN
WORKING TO REHABILITATE MYSELF
FOR OVER A DECADE AND A HALF.
SO WHEN I SAW EARLIER THIS YEAR
THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY. ONLY
ELEVEN POINT 5% OF PEOPLE WERE
FOUND SUITABLE FOR RELEASE AT
THEIR INITIAL HEARING. I WASN'T
SURPRISED. IN FAR TOO MANY
CASES THE BARRIER TO BEING
FOUND SUITABLE ISN'T THE WORK A
PERSON IS DONE. INSTEAD IT'S A
LACK OF FAMILIARITY WITH THE
PROCESS AND WHAT IS EXPECTED OF
THEM. PRIOR TO EACH PERSON'S
RELEASE THROUGH THE PAROLE
BOARD PROCESS. PEOPLE GO TO AN
EXHAUSTIVE AND RIGOROUS
EXAMINATION THAT CULMINATES IN
A PAROLE BOARD HEARING. THEY
WOULD BENEFIT FROM HAVING AN
ATTORNEY'S GUIDANCE THROUGH
EVERY STAGE OF THE PROCESS.
GRANTING INCARCERATED PEOPLE
WHO ARE PREPARING FOR THEIR
FIRST PAROLE BOARD HEARING AN
ADDITIONAL HOUR PREP TIME WITH
AN ATTORNEY. IN ORDER TO
EXPLAIN THE ROLE OF THE C. R.
A. TOPICS THE SEAT THE FORENSIC
PSYCHOLOGIST WILL INTERROGATE.
DISCUSS ANY POTENTIAL LEGAL
LIABILITIES AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY PROVIDE TIME FOR
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS WILL
IMPROVE THE ODDS OF SUCCESS FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE DONE THE WORK
LACK KNOWLEDGE OF THE PROCESS.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST
YEAR ALONE I'VE SPOKEN TO
MULTIPLE PEOPLE OF GOING TO THE
PAROLE BOARD PROCESS. IN EACH
HAS SUPPORTED THIS ADDITIONAL
OUR AS SOMETHING THAT WOULD
GREATLY BENEFIT PEOPLE. A FEW
LIKE ME WERE SUCCESSFUL WITHOUT
IT BUT THE VAST MAJORITY
EXPERIENCE A LARGELY
UNNECESSARY SET BACK THAT THIS
RECALL REFORM WOULD HELP FIX.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER KING- REALLY APPRECIATE
YOU BEING HERE TODAY AND
SHARING THAT WITH US- YOUR
EXPERIENCES UP MATTER IN A VERY
VERY BIG WAY AND- OBVIOUSLY
HAVE A BIG IMPACT. SO THANK YOU
AGAIN- COLLEAGUES IN THE-
MISTER NEWMAN YOUR AVAILABLE
ACCOUNT OR NEW. EITHER ONE'S
FINE MISTER KING THANK YOU FOR
DOING THIS AND I'M ALWAYS
IMPRESSED WHEN A SINGLE
INDIVIDUAL CAN- OF- ON THEIR
OWN THE OBSERVE AFFECT PROGRESS
OR CERTAINLY INSTIGATE A GOOD
CONVERSATION LIKE THIS RIGHT SO
I COMMEND YOU- THE LAWYERS
PROVIDED FOR YOU I ASSUME ARE
PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND PAID FOR
BY. SOME JURISDICTION RIGHT.
YES THEY'RE THEY'RE PAID THAT
THE FUNDING GOES THROUGH CDC
ARTS OF THE BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARINGS WHICH THEN ALLOCATES A
STATE APPOINTED PUBLIC OF THE-
PAROLE BOARD HERE ATTORNEYS. NO
I WON'T HOLD YOU TO IT BUT WHEN
WE SAY ADDITIONAL TIME WHAT
WHAT'S WHAT'S THE INCREMENTAL
ADDITIONAL TIME DO YOU THINK AS
A STANDARD. THAT WOULD BE
NECESSARY TO MAKE PROGRESS.
RIGHT NOW STATE APPOINTED
PAROLE BOARD ATTORNEYS MEET
WITH A AN INDIVIDUAL SCHEDULED
FOR THEIR FIRST HEARING FOR ONE
HOUR WITHIN THE FIRST THIRTY
DAYS. WE THINK AN ADDITIONAL
HOUR STRICTLY FOR PREPARATION
FOR THE COMPREHENSIVE RISK
ASSESSMENT. WOULD HELP A LOT.
AND HIS IS ANYBODY A SISTER
BARB. TRIED DESPERATE THE COST
OF THE DIVISIONAL OUR ACROSS
THE SYSTEM. FROM EVERYTHING
THAT WE'VE SEEN IT WOULD IT
WOULD BE RELATIVELY MODEST FOR
INSTANCE LAST YEAR THERE WERE.
WELL AN ADDITIONAL HOUR FOR THE
FOUR THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED.
PEOPLE GOING FOR WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR WORD IS I'M
SORRY MR KING WE LOST YOU MIGHT
HAVE MISSED YOU A BIT THERE SO
IF CAN. GO BACK A FEW SITE WHEN
HE WAS GETTING GOOD GRIEF CUT
OUT. YES I WAS JUST SAYING THAT
THAT- LAST YEAR THERE WERE FOUR
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
NINE PEOPLE WHO HAD AN INITIAL
HEARING THAT WOULD HAVE
BENEFITED FROM THIS THIS.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SO IT'S
RELATIVELY SMALL GROUP OF
PEOPLE. THAT THEY CAN HAVE. A
LARGE IMPACT TO EVERYTHING
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FIVE
THOUSAND NATIONAL HOURS AT AN
APPROXIMATE GROWTH. I WOULD SAY
HE ROUGHLY AROUND A HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR
THAT MIGHT BE HIGH. MY POOR.
SURE THAT DOESN'T DOES NOT SEEM
SEEMS LIKE A GOOD INVESTMENT TO
ME THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. FOR GREED BECAUSE THEY
KNOW NOTHING TO SAY I AGREE
WITH- SO SHE MIGHT COME AS WAS
THERE NEWMAN OKAY- AND IF YOU
COULD JUST SUM UP WHAT YOU
THINK. OF THE OUTCOME WOULD BE.
IF WE ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AS AS
YOU RECOMMEND. WHAT WOULD THAT
MEAN TO PEOPLE OR WHAT I WOULD
DO MEASURE. THE OUTCOME IF WE
PROVIDED THESE ADDITIONAL HOURS.
I THINK THE. THE FOREIGN THE
FOUR THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED IN
EXETER PEOPLE WENT TO THE
PAROLE BOARD LAST YEAR FOR THE
FIRST TIME- RIGHT ROUGHLY
AROUND FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE WERE
FOUND SUITABLE- THE GAP IS NOT
THOUGH IN THE WORK OF PEOPLE
ARE DOING TO PREPARE FOR THEIR
RE ENTRY IT'S IN A LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING OF THE PROCESS
AND WHAT'S EXPECTED OF THEM SO
HAVING ACCESS TO AN ATTORNEY IN
ORDER TO WALK THEM THROUGH THE
PROCESS ILLUMINATE THE- THE ON
DIRECTOR SEES THAT HAVE BEEN IN
PLACE. TO HELP THEM UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S EXPECTED OF THEM I THINK
WE HAVE A LARGE IMPACT ON EVEN
IF AN ADDITIONAL- FIFTY PEOPLE
PER YEAR WERE FOUND SUITABLE AS
A RESULT OF THIS. THAT WOULD
SAVE THE STATE. OWNED I THINK
EVERY PERSON RIGHT NOW COST THE
STATE ROUGHLY AROUND A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR TO
INCARCERATED. SO JUST FIFTY
PEOPLE WOULD HAVE A TREMENDOUS
IMPACT. YEAH UNFORTUNATELY
SOMETIMES IT'S A SOME PEOPLE
ARE MORE FOCUSED ON THE
DOLLARS- AND I THINK THAT'S
VERY IMPORTANT TO. TO INCLUDE
BUT I THINK IT'S ALSO WHAT'S
THE WHAT'S THE IMPACT ON THOSE
INDIVIDUALS- AS HUMAN BEANS. I
AGREE IN THE END AND APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION- YOU KNOW FOR ME
WHEN I WAS GOING TO THE PAROLE
BOARD PROCESS I WAS VERY
FORTUNATE TO HAVE A LOT OF
SUPPORT- BUT OFTENTIMES WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN INCARCERATED FOR TWENTY
FIVE PLUS YEARS. AND SO. GEN
WHO ARE THERE TO HELP SUPPORT
YOU AND PREPARE YOU FOR- FOR
SAFE RE ENTRY INTO SOCIETY
MEANS THE WORLD TO PEOPLE I
KNOW IT IS WRONG TO ME I WAS
TALKING IN THE LAST PANEL
ABOUT- JUST A MENTAL HEALTH AND
SO SEEN THE COMMUNITY SUPPORT
AND KNOWING THAT THE STATE IS
DOING EVERYTHING IT CAN TO
DEMYSTIFY THE PROCESS AND HELP
PEOPLE FEEL SUPPORTED IN A RE
ENTRY. IT WOULD HAVE A HUGE
IMPACT. IF I COULD NOT YOURS
WHY DO THE QUICK MATH BASED MR
KING'S COMMENTS SO IF FIVE
THOUSAND HOURS GIANT TIMES
UNDERSERVED FIVE DOLLARS AN
HOUR. THAT WOULD BE PRICE EIGHT
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IF IT WOULD GET FIFTY
PEOPLE BACK ON THE ROAD AND
SAVE THE STATE A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER EACH
THAT'S FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
EACH IN THAT SAVINGS OR FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS- SO THAT'S
PRETTY COMPELLING MATH. YES
THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN. WELL
MISTER KING AGAIN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOT ONLY FOR BEING
WITH US AND SHARING WITH US
TODAY BUT WERE POORLY ALL THE
WORK THAT YOU DO EVERY SINGLE
DAY AT THE ELEVATOR CENTER
APPRECIATE YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IS WORTH. OKAY THAT WAS
INFORMATIONAL MOVE ON TO ISSUE
FIVE. ISSUE FIVE IS ON THE
STATE FUNDS APPROPRIATED TO THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION OF MISS LEE WILL
DISCUSS THE BURKE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF FUNDING- THEY GO TO CD
EIGHT A. AS WELL AS DISCUSS THE
RESULTS OF BY. LOCAL AUDIT OF
THEN CAN SPENCE SENIOR POLICY
ADVISOR AT NEXT GEN POLICY AND
ASHLEY WERNER DIRECTING
ATTORNEY AT LEADERSHIP COUNSEL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
THE STAFF NOTES THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION WAS INVITED TO
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S HEARING
BUT FORMALLY DECLINED. DUE TO
AN ONGOING DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE INVESTIGATION WE WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING US
TODAY AND WE'LL START WITH
MISLI. THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I AM GOING TO
SHARE THE SCREEN AGAIN WITH
YOU- IS LET ME KNOW IF YOU DO
NOT SEE A COUPLE OF HANNAH ON
BEFORE YOU- BUT STILL WE HAVE
BEEN ASKED TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF STATE FUNDING. TO
CDA AS WELL AS TO SUMMARIZE
AUDIT FINDINGS- THAT WAS
COMPLETED RECENTLY AS OF
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY SO
USING THIS CANNOT AS A GUIDE
FOR COMMENTS. ON WHICH IS ALSO
AVAILABLE ON THE ONLY A WEBSITE.
THE TURN TO PAGE ONE OF YOUR
HAND OUT ON CDA IS A MEMBERSHIP
DRIVEN ORGANIZATION NOT FOR
PROFIT ENGAGES IN VARIOUS
ACTIVITIES AND DOES RECEIVE
FUNDING FROM DIFFERENT SOURCES.
INCLUDING MEMBERSHIP DUES STATE
AND FEDERAL FINES AND
LITIGATION PERCY. THE KEY THING
FOR IN THIS HAND OUT AND WE'RE
GONNA. TALK ABOUT THIS ONE IS
THAT SOME OF THESE FUNDS ARE
RESTRICTED WHICH MEANS THAT
THEY ARE REQUIRED TO USE FOR
SPECIFIC PURPOSES. TURNING TO
PAGE TWO OF YOUR HAND OUT. WELL
FIRST PROVIDE A SUMMARY OF
STATE FUNDING PROVIDED TO CDA
IN RECENT YEARS. PRETTY BROAD
DEFINITION OF STATE FUNDING
THIS INCLUDES ANY MONIES FOR
WHICH THERE IS AUTHORIZATION
UNDER STATE LAW ON ANY GRANT
FUNDS THAT WOULD NOT HAVE
OTHERWISE BEEN AVAILABLE
WITHOUT THE STATE AS WELL AS
ANY LITIGATION PROCEEDS- THAT
COME FROM CASES THAT ARE
RESOLVED BY STATE ENTITIES. AND
SO INERT LOOK IN THIS AREA WE
IDENTIFIED APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
FUNDING STREAMS. THE FIRST IS
THAT STATE LAW SPECIFIES OR
PROVIDES THE CDA WITH- MONIES
TO PROVIDE STATEWIDE TRAINING
TO PROSECUTORS ARE BY MENTAL
REGULATORS ON THE ENFORCEMENT
OF STATE AND LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS. CDA LAST
RECEIVED AROUND FORTY EIGHT
THOUSAND FOR THESE ACTIVITIES.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. I CAN'T STATE LAW
CREATES AN PROJECT BETWEEN
CALLUM. AND CDA KNOWN AS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CIRCUIT
PROSECUTOR PROJECT WHICH IS
INTENDED TO SUPPORT THE
EFFECTIVE IN UNIFORM
ENFORCEMENT OF ENVIRONMENTAL
LAWS AND REGULATIONS WHICH DOES
INCLUDE ASSISTANCE TO DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ARE PURSUING CRIMINAL
PROSECUTIONS AND SINCE CA LAST
RECEIVED AROUND SIXTY THREE
THOUSAND FOR THEIR COSTS. IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THIRD STATE LAW REQUIRES THAT
1% OF PROCEEDS FROM STATE AND
LOCAL DRUG RELATED ASSET
FORFEITURES GO TO A PRIVATE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION COMPOSED
OF LOCAL PROSECUTORS WHICH IS
TRADITIONALLY THE CDA- FOR
STATEWIDE TRAINING ON ASK
FORFEITURE. AND SEVEN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TO GIVE YOU
AN IDEA ON CA RECEIVED AROUND
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM- THESE FUNDS. TURNING TO
PAGE THREE OF YOUR HAND OUT THE
FOURTH STREAM OF FUNDING IS
RELATED TO THE HIGH TECHNOLOGY
THEFT APPREHENSION AND
PROSECUTION PROGRAM. STATE LAW
PROVIDES AROUND A HUNDRED AND
NINETY TWO THOUSAND IN A
REALIGNMENT FUNDING- TO MARIN
COUNTY FOR USE BY CD EIGHT FOUR
STATEWIDE TRAINING AND RESEARCH
ON DETERRING INVESTIGATING AND
PROSECUTING THESE HIGH TECH
CRIMES. CDA HAS RECEIVED GRANT
FUNDING FROM VARIOUS STATE
AGENCIES OVER TIME THE AMOUNT
WILL FLUCTUATE DEPENDING ON
WHETHER OR NOT CA. SEEKS AND
ACTUALLY RECEIVED THE GRANTS
YOU'VE GOT EXAMPLES BEFORE YOU
ON THAT PAGE JUST FOR EXAMPLE-
THEY RECEIVED ONE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL AND
STATE FUNDS- TO PROVIDE
STATEWIDE TRAINING ON
PERFORMING. YOU AND USING ABUSE
AND SEXUAL ASSAULT MEDICAL AND
ENSURING EXAMINATIONS FOR
EXAMPLE. TURNING TO PAGE FOUR
OF YOUR HAND OUT. THE SIX
STREAMLINING IS MONIES THAT ARE
RECEIVED PURSUANT TO
SETTLEMENTS OR JUDGMENTS IN
CASES THAT ARE FILED AND
RESOLVED BY THE STATE FOR
EXAMPLE CDA RECEIVED AROUND A
HUNDRED AND SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM IT CONSUMER
PROTECTION CASE THAT WAS
RESOLVED BY DOJ. FINAL STREAM
OF FUNDING IS BASICALLY
PAYMENTS FOR A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT SOURCES TO CDA FOR
DIFFERENT PURPOSES SUCH AS
TRAINING FEES AS WELL THE
PUBLICATION CAUSTIC CENTER AND
THIS CAN VARY FROM YEAR TO
YEAR. AND SO C. AS AN EXAMPLE
CITY A RECEIVED NEARLY SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND IN THESE TYPES OF
PAYMENTS FROM DIFFERENT STATE
AGENCIES IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TWENTY. TURNING TO
PAGE FIVE OF OUR HAND OUT WE'RE
GONNA SHIFT YOUR ATTENTION TO
THE AUDIT- SO IN DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY AND EXTERNAL
AUDIT COMMISSIONED BY CDA. WAS
COMPLETED AND IT WAS A LINE
ITEM AUDIT OF SETTLEMENTS
JUDGMENTS AND GRANT MONIES
PROVIDED FOR ROUGHLY SIX
ENVIRONMENTAL AND WORKER SAFETY
RELATED CD EIGHT PROGRAMS SINCE
TWO THOUSAND TWO SO THIS IS A
SUBSET. OF CTAS BROADER
PROGRAMMING. UNTIL IN THE SCOTT
AND THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
FINDINGS. THAT CAN REALLY BE
CATEGORIZED IN FOUR IN THREE
KEY AREAS. THE FIRST IS THAT
CDA ROUTINELY BORROWED FROM IS
RESTRICTED FUNDS AND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND WORKER SAFETY
RELATED AREAS AND THAT PRACTICE
WAS INSTRUMENTAL. TO ITS
FINANCIAL LIABILITY SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR. SECOND BODY
FOUND THAT AS OF JUNE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO POINT NINE MILLION
WAS STILL OWED TO CTAS
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKER SAFETY
PROGRAMS. FROM UNRESTRICTED
GENERAL PURPOSE ACCOUNT. AND
THIRD THERE WERE A NUMBER OF
CONCERNS WITH THE INTERNAL
ACCOUNTING PRACTICES INCLUDING
THE AUDITED FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS EACH YEAR SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE INACCURATELY
REPORTING FINDS ASPEN
RESTRICTED. AS WELL AS JUST
INTERNAL FINANCIAL REPORTS AND
PRACTICES RESULTING IN A LACK
OF INFORMATION ON WHETHER FUNDS
ARE RESTRICTED. AS WELL AS
FINANCIAL REPORTS BEING
INTERNALLY. INCONSISTENT WITH
ONE ANOTHER. CARRIED TO PAGE
SIX HAND. CA BOARD TOOK FOR. IN
JUNE OF TWENTY THE AUDIT BEGIN.
INSTANCE IN THE BOARD. DIRECTED
THAT ALL FUTURE MONIES RECEIVED
BY THE CDA ENVIRONMENTAL AND
WORKER SAFETY PROGRAMS BE
DEPOSITED INTO A SEPARATE
RESTRICTED FINANCIAL ACCOUNT
AND THAT COPIES OF THESE BANK
STATEMENTS BE PROVIDED. TO ITS
CO CHAIRS OF ITS ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMITTEE. THE BORDER ALSO
COMMITTED TO PROVIDING FISCAL
SUPPORT FOR THE CDA
ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAMS FROM ITS
UNRESTRICTED GENERAL PURPOSE
SOURCES WOULD NOT BE AVAILABLE.
AND FINALLY THE BOARD- DECIDED
TO SET ASIDE AT LEAST 10%
UNENCUMBERED OTHER RESTRICTIONS
GENERAL PURPOSE ACCOUNT MONIES
AT THE END OF EACH FISCAL YEAR.
IN ORDER TO RESTORE THE FUND
BALANCES TO THE. ENVIRONMENTAL
AND WORKER SAFETY PROGRAM. WHY
PAGE YOUR HAND. THE AUDIT NEED
FIVE ADDITION RECOMMENDATIONS-
BUT YOU SEE ELAINE ON LATE ON
THIS PAGE BEFORE YOU IS
INCLUDED TAKING PROACTIVE STEPS
TO IN TO ELIMINATE ANY
AMBIGUITIES ON WHETHER
RESTRICTED FUND ANY RECEIVED
FUNDS WERE RESTRICTED I'M SORRY
ABOUT THAT- IT ALSO INCLUDED
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR IMPROVING
AND INCREASING BOTH EXTERNAL
AND INTERNAL REPORTING. TO MAKE
SURE THAT MONIES WERE TRACKED
APPROPRIATELY INCLUDING WHETHER
OR NOT THEY RESTRICT IT. AND
FINALLY ACTUALLY RECOMMENDED
IMPROVING ACCOUNTING PRACTICES
AND COMMUNICATION IN PARTICULAR
WAYS IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
FINANCIAL REPORTS WERE
INTERNALLY CONSISTENT AND THAT
THE MONIES WERE BEING TRACKED
APPROPRIATELY. SO WITH THAT-
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. YOU FOR A GREAT TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH. O. K. WILL
MOVE START IT. WE'LL MOVE ON
NOW TO- KEN SPENCE AT NEXT GEN
POLICY. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS KEN
SPENCE AND I'M A SENIOR POLICY
ADVISOR AT NEXTGEN POLICY
CENTER FIFTH HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
WHILE WORKING JUSTICE AND
CONSUMER FINANCIAL PROTECTION
WHICH- ALTHOUGH DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE POLICY IS NOT MY COURT
AREA NEXT JUNE IS THE JUSTICE
IN EQUITY CENTERS NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION. FOUNDED BY TOM
DYER THE FOCUS IS ON A DIVERSE
ARRAY OF POLICY AREAS FROM
HEALTH AND EDUCATION. THE FOOD
SECURITY ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
THE VOTING RIGHTS TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. AND SO GIVEN OUR FOCUS
THIS ISSUE REALLY STRUCK US
WHEN EQUITY AND JUSTICE
STANDPOINT. THIS PUBLIC
TAXPAYER MONEY WAS INTENDED TO
DO JUST THAT. TO PROVIDE EQUITY
AND JUSTICE. PROVIDE SUPPORT
FOR COMMUNITIES ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS THEY NEED
THIS TYPE OF LEGAL SUPPORT AND
ASSISTANCE TO GO AFTER THOSE
WHO VIOLATE OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION LAWS INPUT
ARCHIMEDES IN HARM'S WAY. IN
THE FUNDS WERE LARGELY. THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
A VENOM BARMAN POLLUTION AND
DEGRADATION. AND THAT'S THE
REASON THAT WE ALONG WITH TEN
OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS FELT COMPELLED TO
SIGN ONTO A LETTER REQUESTING
THAT DECISIVE. AND SWIFT ACTION
BE TAKEN HOLD CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
ACCOUNTABLE FOR HIS MISDEEDS.
WHAT WE WOULD LIKE RESPECTFULLY
FUNDS LEGISLATURE IT IS THE
FOLLOW. ONE CAN SURE THAT THESE
ENFORCEMENT AND TRAINING FUNDS
NO LONGER PASSED THROUGH CA. TO
HEAR THAT THERE IS A REAL FUSS
INVESTIGATION IN ORDER TO
DETERMINE THE FULL SCOPE OF
THEIR NAFISA. AND THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT HAS BEEN MISUSED OR
MISAPPROPRIATED OVER THE YEARS.
THREE HEY WE PAY HIM IN FULL
ALL THE MONEY BIXEL. AND
FINALLY GOING FORWARD THE CITY
AB PROHIBITED FROM DISTRIBUTING
FOR RECEIVING GRANTS INTENDED
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL PUSHING
SHRINK. IT'S CRITICAL DOLLARS
SIXTY FOUR BUT WE CONTEND THEY
GIVEN CAT'S DEMONSTRATED
UNTRUSTWORTHY HAS. THE FUND
SHOULD INSTEAD BE OVERSEEN BY
RESPONSIBLE GOVERNMENT ENTITIES
CAN GO DIRECTLY TO THE LOCAL
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OFFICES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
DOING THIS CRITICAL WORK. IN
THE FINAL THING I LIKE TO SAY
IS THAT YOU KNOW AT A TIME WHEN
PUBLIC TRUST LAW ENFORCEMENT.
PRESENCE THE WINTER MARC. WHAT
WE HAVE HERE IS YET ONE MORE
EXAMPLE OF A LAW ENFORCEMENT
ORGANIZATION. FLAGRANTLY
IGNORING BOTH THE WORLD'S
LEGISLATURE. THE BEST INTERESTS
OF OUR MOST ON THE TEAM. FOR
USING RSOURCES PROVIDED TO
PROTECT OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AND
FAMILIES COMPARTMENTAL MARC.
TWISTING CHAMPION POLICIES THAT
SUPPORT MASS INCARCERATION. AND
STAND IN THE WAY OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE RECORDS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND TO ANSWER THIS
QUESTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR SPENCE- WE MOVE ON NOW TO
ASHLEY WERNER. I AM ACTUALLY
WARNER AND THE DIRECTING
ATTORNEY WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK WITH FOR
YOUR COMMITTEE TODAY AND FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING ON
IMPORTANT TOPICS. LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL WORKS ON SITE RESIDENTS
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND HE'S
COACHELLA VALLEY. MOST OF THE
COMMUNITIES WE WORK WITH
EXPERIENCED SEVERE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEGRADATION
RESULTING FROM POLLUTING LAND
USES LOCATED WITHIN AND
SURROUNDING THIS COMMUNITIES.
IN MANY CASES THE ENVIRONMENTAL
HARMS CAUSED BY THESE LAND USES
EXCEED LIMITS SET BY LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS AND
OFTEN RESULT FROM LANDOWNERS
AND FACILITY OPERATORS. FAILURE
TO TAKE REQUIRED STEPS TO
REDUCE IMPACTS ON THE
ENVIRONMENT IN NEARBY HOMES.
HE'S AYE LESIONS AYE UNDERMINE
PUBLIC HEALTH HOUSING QUALITY
AND WELL BEING IN OUR STATE'S
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND
DEEP IN DISPARITIES ALONG RACE
INCOME AND GEOGRAPHIC LINES
THAT SCAR STATE. I WILL SHARE
WITH THE COMMITTEE TWO EXAMPLES
FROM FRESNO FOR WHICH DISTRICT
ATTORNEY INTERVENTION COULD
HAVE CORRECTED ENVIRONMENTAL
VIOLATIONS AND BENEFIT THE
PUBLIC. THE FIRST EXAMPLE IS
THE DARLING INGREDIENTS MEAT
RENDERING PLANT LOCATED IN THE
HEART OF THE WEST FRESNO
COMMUNITY. WEST FRESNO IS
COMPRISED ALMOST ENTIRELY OF
BLACK LATINO AND ASIAN AMERICAN
RESIDENTS AND RANKS AMONG THE
MOST POLLUTION BURDEN
NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA EPA'S CALOMBARIS
SCREEN TOOL. DARLING PLANT IS
LOCATED ACROSS FROM A COMMUNITY
PARK AND YOUR HOMES AND EDISON
HIGH SCHOOL AND PROCESSES EIGHT
POUNDS OF MEAT PER DAY. ODORS
FROM ITS OPERATION SATURATE THE
AIR IN RESIDENTS YARDS IN
PUBLIC SPACES INVADE HOMES ARE
OPEN WINDOWS IN EACH FAX
SYSTEMS AND BECAUSE RESIDENTS
TO EXPERIENCE NAUSEA HEADACHES
AND STRESS. I'M TOO MANY
OCCASIONS TRACKSUIT LEACHED
ANIMAL JUICES AND SPILLED
UNCOVERED ANIMAL CARCASSES ON
THE LOCAL ROADWAYS. DESPITE THE
PLANTS. SIZE AND SEVERE IMPACTS
ON THE LOCAL COMMUNITY THAT
FACILITY HAS OPERATED FOR FIFTY
YEARS WITHOUT EVER OF TEEN A
LAND USE PERMIT REQUIRED BY
LOCAL MUNICIPAL CODES EVER
UNDERGOING ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW.
THANKS TO THE DEDICATION OF A
GROUP OF COMMUNITY LEADERS
CALLED CONCERNED CITIZENS OF
WEST FRESNO WHO DISCOVERED THE
PLANTS LACK OF A LAND USE
PERMIT AND TWO FIVE FOR MORE
THAN FIFTEEN YEARS TO ADDRESS
THE PLANTS VIOLATIONS. THE
PLANT WILL SHUT DOWN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. HOWEVER
INVESTIGATION ENFORCEMENT BY
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
COULDN'T SAVE THESE RESIDENTS
COUNTLESS HOURS OF FREEDOM
NONPROFIT LEGAL COUNSEL AND
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL TO PURSUE
OTHER VIOLATIONS. AND HELP
SECURE JUSTICE YEARS EARLIER.
THE SECOND EXAMPLE I'LL SHARE
IS RELATED TO THE DEVELOPMENT
OF AN AMAZON WAREHOUSE CENTER
IN THE SOUTH CENTRAL FRESNO
COMMUNITY. AND ITS IMPACTS ON
NEARBY HOMES IN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL AND THE MOST POLLUTION
BURDEN CENSUS TRACT IN THE
STATE. DURING THE FACILITIES
AROUND THE CLOCK MONTHSLONG
CONSTRUCTION DUST CLOUDS FROM
CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITIES
COLLUDED RESIDENTS HOMES
TRIGGERING ASTHMA ATTACKS AND
UNRELENTING NOISE KEPT
RESIDENTS AT THE NINETY. ONE
RESIDENT WE WORK CLOSELY WITH
WHO LIVES ACROSS FROM THE
DISTRIBUTION CENTER EXPERIENCE
DEAFNESS IN ONE NEAT IN ONE
YEAR. SINCE THE FACILITY
STARTED ITS OPERATIONS AND
IMPACT UNDERMINE RESIDENTS
ENJOYMENT OF THEIR HOMES AND
THEIR HEALTH. FOR EXAMPLE
ANIMATED LIGHT SPILLS INTO
HOMES TWENTY FOUR SEVEN AND
INTERRUPTS RESIDENTS SLEEP. HE
FROM ENORMOUS CONCRETE
STRUCTURES RESULT IN HIGHER
LOCAL TEMPERATURES FORCING
RESIDENTS TO RUN THEIR AC'S
HARDER AND PAY EVEN MORE CREE
CHILIES AND FRESHNESS HOT
SUMMER. AND TRACK SPEED BY
LOCAL ROADS CREATING SAFETY
HAZARDS FOR KIDS WALKING TO
SCHOOL AND KICKING UP DUST THAT
MAKES IT HARD FOR RESIDENTS TO
BREED. THESE IMPACTS EXACERBATE
DISPROPORTIONATELY POOR PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE OUTCOMES IN THIS
COMMUNITY OF COLOR. MANY OF
THEM ARE APPARENT VIOLATIONS OF
LOCAL OR STATE ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS AND SEE WHAT
MITIGATION MEASURES APPLICABLES
OF THIS PROJECT THE WEST FRESNO
DARLING INGREDIENTS PLANT IN
SOUTH CENTRAL FRESNO AMAZON
WAREHOUSE. ARE JUST TWO
STRIKING EXAMPLES OF INSTANCES
WHERE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
INTERVENTION COULD PROVIDE
PROTECTIONS TO IMPACTED
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHILE
ENSURING COMPLIANCE. WITH THEIR
STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS.
SAMPLES LIKE THIS ABOUT
THROUGHOUT THE IN RULE REGIONS
AND WHICH WE WORK. WE HOPE THAT
THE STATE LEGISLATURE TAKES
APPROPRIATE ACTION TO ENSURE
THE INTENT OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
ENFORCEMENT AND TRAINING ACTORS
REALIZED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THANK.
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THIS GROUP I DO IF WE
SEND A NEW ONE SO IT JUST-
JUST- KENNETH PICKING UP ON A
MISTER SPENCER'S COMMENTS SO I
LOOKING AT THE- ELIAS'S
RECOMMENDATIONS ONE
RECOMMENDATION THAT DOES NOT
APPEAR TO BE THERE IS TO- IT
WILL RENDER THIS. A INELIGIBLE
FUTURE FUNDS- IF THAT'S THE
CASE WITH ROOM WHY AND HOW HOW
WHAT'S WHAT'S- HOW IS THAT THE
ACCOUNTED FOR. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION CENTER. ARM AND
ARGUE ON TRUSTWORTHINESS AND A
TRACK RECORD SHOULD PLAY OUT
THANK HEAVILY. INTO WHETHER OR
NOT- ENTITY IMMUNITY. IS A
CONTINUE STATE FUNDING. WE SEE
HERE IS I THINK OVER. FOURTEEN
YEARS. THE CONSISTENTLY TO ONE
OF DOLLARS THE USER FOR THE
HOME FOR. SO IT SEEMS LIKE
EITHER. IN A CALLING ATTENTION
FOR MURPHY WITH ISAAC IT CALL
INTO QUESTION WHETHER NOT TRUST
WITH ADDITIONAL. SO I THINK
WHERE- ARE WORKING COMES FROM
IT OR OTHER ORGANIZATIONS- THIS
WORK FOCUSES. ABOUT
ORGANIZATION TO DO THIS WORK
AND I THINK WE A MORE. FEES DO
SO IN A MANNER THAT WAS
INTENDED. I'VE YOUR COMMENTS
SHOULD BE TO BE- I THINK GOOD
OF THE L. A. O. COULD RESPOND
TO THAT. I NEED ONLY OF THE L.
L. SO THIS IS THIS IS AN AREA
THAT WE KNOW THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IN BOTH HOUSES ARE
INTERESTED AND- WE HAVE BEEN
PROVIDING ASSISTANCE WHO
GENERALLY AND A TECHNICAL.
ASPECTS AND DEPENDING ON WHAT
THE LEGISLATURE GOALS ARE WE
ARE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE- IN EFFECTUATE A
MATTER WHETHER IT'S CHANGED A
STATE LAW CHANGED BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE ETCETERA. WE DON'T
HAVE A FIRM RECOMMENDATIONS ON
THIS ISSUE AND SO OUR HAND OUT
WAS REALLY PROVIDING A SUMMARY
OF WHAT THE AUDITOR- SOUND
RELATED TO CDA ETCETERA SO. I
I'M NOT SURE OF THE ANSWERS
YOUR QUESTION I'M HAPPY TO
LEVERAGE FOR NO I THINK IT DOES
I THINK IT GIVES US CONTEXT FOR
MOVING FORWARD SO I. APPRECIATE
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOUNG. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER IS THERE
ANY WAY THAT YOU COULD TELL
WITH WHAT'S DISTURBING NOW HERE
IS THAT NEARLY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IS OWED. TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL OR WORKER SAFETY
PROGRAMS THAT C. D. A. A. WAS-
IN CHARGE OF OR YOU KNOW HAD-
AND THAT C. D. A. DOES NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES TO REPAY THIS AMOUNT.
I AM A I DON'T QUITE GET. THEY
GOT THE MONEY. BUT THEY DIDN'T
OF ITS SOMEHOW MISSING I DON'T
KNOW WHAT HOW TO. I DON'T HEAR
A CLEAR EXPLANATION ABOUT THE
TWO POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
AND THAT THEY'RE GOING TO MAKE
UP FOR IT BY. FUTURE FUNDS THAT
THEY GET BUT WHAT. WHAT
HAPPENED TO THIS TWO POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS. SO THE BEST
AND EASY ANSWER MADAM CHAIRS
QUESTION WOULD BE CA- IN
LOOKING AT THE AUDIT- THE
AUDITOR WAS THE ONE THAT
IDENTIFIED THAT THERE WAS
APPROXIMATELY I WAS LOOKING AT
THE AVAILABLE PLANS THAT THAT
EXISTED AT THAT TIME IN TERMS
OF CASH AND ACT AND ASSETS. AND
BASICALLY SAID THAT THEY DIDN'T
THINK THAT CA HAD THE
HURRICANES OF THAT TIME THERE
COULD BE A COUPLE REASONS FOR
THIS- SOME OF THE FUNDING THAT
COMES INTO CA CAN FLUCTUATE
FROM YEAR TO YEAR SO WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SOURCES OF STATE
FUNDING FOR EXAMPLE- THE GRANT
FUNDS LITIGATION PROCEEDS
ETCETERA. CAN VARY FROM YEAR TO
YEAR AND SO ORGANIZATIONS
OUTSIDE OF CDA THINK ABOUT YOUR
STATE DEPARTMENT ETCETERA THE
SENATE YOU'RE MISSING SOME OF
THOSE DOLLARS WILL MANAGE
ACCORDINGLY RIGHT NOW ALL
MANAGED TO THAT FLUCTUATION SO
THAT'S ONE ISSUE- THEY HAVE A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF EXPENDITURE I
DON'T KNOW TO WHAT EXTENT DOES
EXPENDITURES ARE ONGOING OR
TEMPORARY IN NATURE AND SO THAT
COULD LEAD. TO SOME OF- THAT
FISCAL ISSUE THERE THE FINAL
THING THAT I WOULD JUST
HIGHLIGHT IN TERMS OF KIND OF
THE REPAYMENTS IS- THAT CDA
DOES HAVE OPTIONS IN TERMS OF
MAKING MONEY IS AVAILABLE AND
SO SOME OPTIONS INCLUDE CUTTING
THEIR EXPENDITURES IN TERMS
ACTIVITIES THAT THEY'RE DOING
ELSEWHERE. WE WOULD ALSO SAY
THAT- FOR LEGISLATORS
CONSIDERATION THAT CDA COULD
ALSO LOOK AT THEIR REVENUE
GENERATION SOURCE AND SO ONE OF
THEIR SOURCES OF REVENUE FOR
EXAMPLE IS MEMBERSHIP DUES I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE ARE OTHERS-
BUT THOSE DOLLARS COULD ALSO BE
YOU KNOW ACTUALLY INCREASED TO
GENERATE REVENUE IF THE
LEGISLATURE- AND CDA FOR
EXAMPLE WERE INTERESTED IN
HAVING THOSE. DOLLARS REPAID
FASTER. I NOTICED THAT YOU TERM
BAR MONIES REPAY. BORROWED MY-
I'M- AGAIN I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT DID THIS MONEY
DISAPPEARS SO IS A MINOR AREAS
OR IS IT JUST MOVED AROUND
SOMEWHERE ELSE NINE ISSUES THEY
THEY SPENT RESTRICTED MONIES
AND OTHER PURPOSES IS THAT
RIGHT MOSTLY TO ENSURE THAT
MONEY'S GONE IT WAS SUSPENDED
FOR PURPOSES OTHER THAN THE
THAN THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF THE
RESTRICTIONS. AND SO BUT THEY
CLEARLY DON'T HAVE THE FUNDS AT
THE MOMENT TO REIMBURSE THOSE
FUNDS TO THE APPROPRIATE COUNTY
SAID CORRECT. AS A THINKING
ABOUT SO WHEN YOU'RE CANCELING
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT THE STATE
BUDGET RIGHT THERE IS THE
GENERAL FUND WHICH IS. WHICH IS
SORT OF UNREST. AND TO SEE HAS
AN UNREST GENERAL AS WELL. THIS
LEGISLATURE ALSO CONSIDER THE
WHOLE RANGE OF SPECIAL AND
DOLLARS FROM THERE AND DOLLARS
FROM SPECIAL FUNDS GENERALLY
HAVE SOME DEGREE OF
RESTRICTIONS SOME BIGGER AND
SOME LAST. AND SO FOREST ON THE
CDA SIDE FOR THESE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAMS OR STATE
FUNDING SOURCES OR OTHER
FUNDING SOURCES IF THEY GET
THEM FOR VERY PARTICULAR
PURPOSES THEY SHOULD BE GOING
INTO THESE. HEALTH PLANS. AND
SO WHAT HAS BEEN HAPPENING IS
THAT THE AUDIT FOUND THAT
DOLLARS WERE BORROW. FROM THE
B. IS RESTRICTED. FROM THE
LEGISLATURE VIEWPOINT YOU WOULD
THINK OF THEM AS SPECIAL PLANS
AND USING THEM FOR ON. GENERAL
FUND PURPOSES. I DON'T KNOW
THAT EXAM HOW- BUT- THAT
PROVIDES A LITTLE BIT MORE
CLARITY. YOUR YES CENTER
KICKING HIS FIFTH CAN I JUST
ASK YOU FINISH THE BOOK BY THE
SAME UNGREASED. PURPOSE SUCH AS-
WHAT I MEAN IF I AM AS MICHAEL
BEST QUESTION OF BECOME A
SENIOR. I THINK WE HONOR THE
BETWEEN GENERAL FUND TO
RESTRICT FRIENDS SO FOR THAT
THE REALLY SMALL. LAKE WHAT THE
HECK WAS MONEY USED. WE
UNDERSTAND FROM THE TO THAT
THEY WERE OF OUR- THE FUNDS
THAT WERE YOU FOR SOME ELSE BUT
I THINK WE HEARD WHAT THE
SOMETHING ELSE WAS. AND I THINK
THAT THERE'S A SORT OF A PUBLIC
POLICY INTEREST IN IN UNDER.
WAS IT USED FOR CONTINUE THAT.
FOR THE BAR FOR IT USED- FIELD
TRIPS. YOU KNOW. DISNEYLAND AYE
AYE WE DON'T WHAT IT WAS FOR.
THAT THAT IS ABSOLUTELY A FAIR
QUESTION AND SO- WHEN WE
REVIEWED THE AUDIT AND I SIGNED
A VERY CLEAR THAT NEED WANT TO
THE AUDIT THIS WASN'T. AUDIT
DONE BY A PRIVATE COMPANY-
HIRED BY CDA. THE AUDIT FAN
THAT IT WAS READ READER OR
BORROW- AND NOT SPECIFIC
SPECIFY HOW IT. THE DOLLARS.
WERE USED THAT BEING SAID WE DO
KNOW THAT CA HAS ENGAGES IN A
WIDE RANGE OF ACTIVITIES
RANGING FROM. MY TRAINING TO
LOBBYING ACTIVITY- IN TERMS OF
HOW SPECIFICALLY THE DOLLARS
ARE USED TO THAT IS A QUESTION
THAT IS BETTER ANSWERED BY CDA
AND UNFORTUNATELY I'M NOT ABLE
TO PROVIDE KIND OF THE
PARTICULAR DETAILS. OF HOW
THOSE DOLLARS REAIS I HAVE ONE
LAST QUESTION AND SO TO THE
EXTENT THAT YOU MENTION THAT
CITY AREAS IT DOES NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES ON HAND. TO REPLENISH
THOSE FUNDS IT DID THAT MEANS
THOSE FUNDS EXCEED CTA'S OTHER
RESOURCES M. IS THAT CORRECT IS
WHICH TO THAT'S KIND OF
ALARMING IF THIS WAS FIRST
GOING TO A SPECIAL COUNTY
ADDITION SYSTEM. OTHER USES AND
I GUESS THE BETTER NOW TUNES
AND CORTESE'S LAWYER IT'S YEAH
IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A CONCERN.
WHO SEEMS TO BE SPENDING IN A
ONE CLIENTS FUNDS FOR OTHER
PURPOSES- AND SO. TO THE EXTENT
THAT THIS DOESN'T SOUND GOOD
WITH HIS WAS IT REFERRED BEYOND
THE AUDIT MISLEAD SEEMS LIKE IT
MIGHT JUSTIFY. ADDITIONAL
EXAMINATION. EVEN BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE. HE
STILL IS RE QUESTIONS. ABOUT
OTHER FIVE. THAT BEEN PROVIDE
TO CDA FOR OTHER PURPOSES SO AN
EXAMPLE ON THEIR IT RELATES TO
THE YOU KNOW THE HIGH TECH
CRIMES THAT WE GET IS AN
EXAMPLE OF A STREAM OF FUNDING
THE ASSET FORFEITURE DOLLARS
ETCETERA. AND SO OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THOSE
FUNDS ARE NOW- POTENTIALLY
UNDER SCRUTINY WE ARE NOT AWARE
OF AN AUDIT SIMILAR TO WHAT WAS
CONDUCTED ON THESE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKER SAFETY
FINES HAVING BEEN TIME. BUT WE
ARE AWARE THAT THERE IS
POTENTIALLY SCREWED ME OUT
THERE FROM BOTH CA. AND MAYBE
OTHERS. PRESHEAF GO TO THE
MINISTRY BE WORTH OF. SO ELSE
THANK YOU FOR. YEP I FOR THE
QUESTION FOR ME IS WEEKLY. AS
BUT IS THE EIGHT AND OUR TRUST
AND- TO SPEND THINGS A CERTAIN
WAY THEY DON'T GET ALL OF THEIR
FUNDING FROM US BUT THEY GET A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FUNDING
FROM US WITH VERY SPECIFIC.
RESTRICTIONS OR CONDITIONS ON
HOW THEY'RE SPENT AND SO YOU
KNOW THIS IS NOT JUST A SORT OF
A GENERAL BIG TRUST IT'S THERE
IS A REAL DOLLARS AND CENTS
HERE AND IT GETS YOU KNOW
THROWN INTO THIS IN GENERAL ALL
OF FUND. AS FAR AS YOU KNOW
USING OUR TERMINOLOGY FOR THEM
AND THEN WHO KNOWS HOW IT GETS.
SPENT AND THEN- YOU KNOW. WHO
KNOWS HOW THAT COULD COULD BE
USED OR NOT USED A- EVEN
AGAINST THE STATE'S INTEREST SO
YOU KNOW I DON'T WANNA REYES
AND THE- SPECTER YOU KNOW
SPECTER HERE BUT- WE DO HAVE I
THINK A RESPONSIBILITY. TO GET
TO THE BOTTOM OF I THINK IT'S
WORTHY OF OUR CONSIDERATION- TO
UNDERSTAND THE MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS IN WHICH WE COULD HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE TO OUR DOLLARS
AND TEN CENTS. AND WE'LL HAVE
TO GET DIG DEEPER INTO THAT.
OKAY THAT MAKES SENSE IN VERY
ANNA. ALL RIGHT WELL I WANT TO
THANK THANK MISLEAD MR SPENCE
AND MISS. WARNER FOR BEING WITH
US TODAY- I'M SORRY JUST ONE
LAST THING- MISS WARNER ARE
THERE ANY OTHER SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT YOU WOULD
MAKE. SURE THANKS SO MUCH I
THINK WE GET THE QUARTERBACK.
THAT MR SPENCE MADE AND YOU
KNOW I WOULD JUST POINT OUT AND
THERE ARE AT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
NONPROFITS THAT DO YOU
ENVIRONMENT OF COURSE NETWORK
IDEALLY BASIS THAT'S CRITICAL
IN THAT SERVICE. DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND OPENING UP
TRAINING PROGRAMS TO THEM WITH
THIS MY I THINK WOULD BE REALLY
USEFUL AND FURTHER THE
OBJECTIVES OF THE STATUTE AND-
AND IN ADDITION OPENING UP
ENFORCEMENT MONEY TO
POTENTIALLY BE ABLE TO FLOW TO
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL.
THANK YOU OKAY GREAT THANK YOU
AGAIN THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR
THIS VERY VERY IMPORTANT AND
INFORMATIVE PANEL PRECIADO-
THIS IS A- JUST FOR DISCUSSION
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON. NOW TO
ISSUE SIX. THIS LAST MONTH.
FULL YES. OKAY OUR FINAL THIS I
IS ON THE IF WERE DUE TO
RECENTLY. WE HAVE A CAR GARCIA
THE L. A. COUNTY SHE PUBLIC
DEFENDER AND TRACY OLD YOUR
COUNTY CHIEF PUBLIC IF HERE ON
TO PRESENT- MAKE PRESENT MISTER.
GOOD AFTERNOON HOW CAN USE FEEL
HERE. FORTY COMMITTEE CHAIR
NUMBERS FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
SPEAKING BUT I'M SORRY MISTER
GREG FLEW BIT HARD TO HEAR USER
TO OR ARE ARE FOR HELPFUL.
GARCIA I AM THE PUBLIC DEFENDER
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND WE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND MY STAFF I WANT
TO THANK YOU. FOR TAKING THE
TIME. TO ALLOW STUDENTS TO
ADDRESS. THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE IS THE
LARGEST. AND IT'S THE OLDEST IN
THE NATION. I HAVE A STAFF OF
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED
ATTORNEYS IT SERVE A COMMUNITY
OF TEN MILLION PEOPLE. IF YOU
EXAMPLE OF WHAT THAT MEANS TO
CONTEXTUALIZE THAT SIZE THE
NEXT LARGEST PUBLIC DEFENDERS
OFFICE AND STATE IS A PARTY
THREE HUNDRED IN TOTAL STAFF TO
MY TWELVE HUNDRED TOTAL STATEN.
AND SERVES A SIGNIFICANTLY
SMALLER POPULATION BASE. IT'S-IMPORTANT UNDERSTAND BECAUSE
THE WORKLOAD THAT WE NOW ENGAGE
IN RELATIONS ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
DEFENDER PRACTICES HAVE BEEN
GOING ON FOR. ALL PUBLIC
DEFENDER OFFICES ACROSS THE
STATE HOWEVER. ALL THE DEFENSES
CHANGE CONSIDERABLY AS JUST
REFORM LEGISLATION HAS ADDED
RESPONSIBILITIES. PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ACROSS OUR STATE.
THERE WAS A TIME FOR QUESTIONS
OF GUILT AND THE WEIGHT OF
EVIDENCE WHO ARE STILL
RESPONSIBILITY. BUT THAT IS NO
LONGER THE CASE. WELL OUR
PRACTICE ONCE FOCUSED ON TRYING
CASES BEFORE A JURY. TO GET A
BETTER CASE OUTCOME. IS A BALK
AT HOLISTIC ADVOCACY TOWARD
TEAMS WORK THE GAME BETTER LIFE
OUTCOMES FOR CLIENTS. WHAT THIS
MEANS IS IT AT TIME PASSED WE
FOCUSED ON WHAT WENT ON IN THE
COURTROOM. AND THE LEGAL
BATTLES AND MOST PEOPLE ARE
FAMILIAR WITH FROM YOU THEIR TV
SHOWS BOOKS OTHER OWN
EXPERIENCE IN CRIMINAL LEGAL
SYSTEM. HOWEVER THE CHANGING
LANDSCAPE HAS MADE SOCIAL
WORKERS. AS CRITICAL TO CLIENT
CENTERED HOLISTIC
REPRESENTATION AS PARALEGALS
ARE TRADITIONAL LITIGATION.
WHAT I'M TRYING TO EXPLAIN AT
THAT IS THAT AS WE'VE EXPANDED
OUR WORK TO INCLUDE ADDITIONAL
PARTS OF WHAT WE DO TO NOT JUST
SIMPLY TRIAL WORK TO LOOKING AT
THE WHOLE CLIENT. EXISTING ON
THE ENTIRE INDIVIDUAL. FROM
TRADITIONAL BUT LEGAL ACTION WE
NOW WORK WITH. SOCIAL WORKERS
TO EXPAND OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT BRINGS OUR CLIENTS INTO
THE SYSTEM. OKAY PUBLIC DEFENSE
DEFENDERS ARE BURSTING IN
ADDRESSING THE REASONS WHY
PEOPLE FIND THEMSELVES IN THE
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM. THATIS
WHAT DRAWS PEOPLE INTO OUR
SYSTEM. IN TRYING TO ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS BEFORE THEY GET
IT IT'S AN ADDICTION MENTAL
ILLNESS POVERTY OR OTHER ISSUES
THAT AFFECT FAMILIES ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES AND IN PARTICULAR
CALIFORNIA AND ARE INDIGENT
CLIENT BASE. I TO MITIGATE THE
COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES OF
CONTACT WITH THE LEGAL SYSTEM.
AND BY THAT IS THINGS THAT MOST
OF US TAKE FOR GRANTED THE
IMPOUNDING OF A CAR. A LOSS OF
RENTAL HOMES THE LAWSUIT
CLAIMING THESE MATTERS
IMPACTING INDIGENOUS USUALLY
ARE CARSON SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
TODAY. AND WE ARE DRESSING
THOSE CONCERNS BEYOND WHAT
WE'VE DONE IN THE PAST. BUT
MORE IMPORTANT. TO OUR
CONVERSATION TODAY. WE'RE
WRITING THE DEVASTATING EFFECTS
OF MASS INCARCERATION. SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
ADDRESSES THE INJUSTICE OF
FELONY MURDER WHICH WAS USED
ACROSS OUR STATE WITH YOUNG
PERSONS OF COLOR IN PRISON FOR
LIFE EVEN WHEN THEY WERE NEVER
INTENDED. TO HURT OR KILL
ANYONE. AB TWENTY NINE FORTY
TWO WHICH ALLOWS MEN AND WOMEN
HONEST BUT HE BY FRANCONIAN
SENTENCES. THE HOPE OF FUTURE
NOT BEHIND BARS THAT IS AN
ABILITY TO REDRESS THE CONCERNS
OF BACK OUT. HAVE SECURE
RELEASE. MANY BILLS A CREATED
THE YOUTH OFFENDER PAROLE
PROCESS WHICH GIVE MEN AND
WOMEN SENTENCED TO DECADES IN
PRISON AS CHILDREN THE CHANCE
TO SHOW THE PAROLE BOARD. WHAT
DATE WE ALL KNOW THAT THEIR YOU
WHICH PLAYED A ROLE IN THEIR
CONDUCT SHOULD NOT BE USED TO
KEEP THEM IN CAGES. AND A
SERIES OF BILLS THEY GIVE
IMMIGRANTS SIAPA THIS STATE IN
THE COUNTRY. AND NOT. THERE DUE
TO APART WITH THE CHILDREN INTO
SYSTEM FOSTER. OR DEPENDING ON
PUBLIC GATE WHEN INCOME EARNERS
OUR RECORD. ALL THESE CHANGES
ARE WELCOME REDIRECTION HANDED
AND LYFT APPROACH TO WRITING
THE PAST WRONGS AND BRING THEM
CLOSER THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS AND PUBLIC
DEFENDER. WE ARE THANKFUL THERE
ARE ADVOCACY AND EDUCATION AS
FOR FRUIT AND WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE TO CORRECT
THE DEVASTATING IMPACT OF MASS
INCARCERATION. AFFECTED BE
WORKING TO REDUCE THE BLOATED
STATE PRISON POPULATION AND
BRING FAMILIES TOGETHER TO
REBUILD COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
HOWEVER THE NEW WORK IS
RESOURCE INTENSIVE. ATTORNEYS
AND SOCIAL WORKERS ARE
ESSENTIAL SOCIAL HISTORIES AND
RE ENTRY PLANS FOR PEOPLE
RELEASED FROM PRISON AND EXPAND
OUR ONGOING WORK AROUND
RESENTENCING AND POST
CONVICTION IMMIGRATION RELIEF.
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S ABILITY TO
CHANGE THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM I DIRECTLY CORRELATED
TO THE RESOURCES WE HAVE TO
ENGAGE IN SYSTEM CHANGES ATTICS.
TAKING ON THOUSANDS OF
PETITIONS THAT REQUIRE CAREFUL
WORK YOU GIVE A PERSON THE BEST
OPPORTUNITY I RELEASE. AND
OFTEN A SINGLE OPPORTUNITY
RESUSCITATES GREATER RESOURCES
THAN THOSE CURRENTLY SEEN IN
OUR BUDGETS DEFEND AGAINST
PROSECUTION. OUR OFFICES ARE
MOST OFTEN FUNDED TO ADDRESS
THE TRADITIONAL LIBERTY MODEL
OF FIGHTING ACCUSATIONS
ADVOCATE FOR JR. ADULT DEFENSE
FUNDING HAS REMAINED TO WORK AS
COMPARED TO PROSECUTE. DISTRICT
ATTORNEY BUDGETS HISTORICALLY
INCLUDES STATE AND FEDERAL
FUNDING SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU
HEARD RECENTLY. SUPPORT SPECIAL
PROSECUTION PROGRAMS. THEIR
INTERNAL SUPPORT TEAMS ARE
OFTEN DOUBLE THE SIZE OF PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ORTIZ THIS IS NOT
INCLUDE THE PROSECUTION'S USE
OF LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
INVESTIGATIONS IT FOR THEIR OWN
INVESTIGATIONS. THERE'S NOT
BEEN A COMPATIBLE NOR EQUITABLE
RESOURCE ALLOCATION FOR PUBLIC
DEFENDERS TO PROTECT OUR
CLIENTS AGAINST THE WELL QUICK
PROSECUTION. NO SPECIAL STATE
OR FEDERAL FUNDING TO HELP US
RESPOND TO THE PROSECUTION'S
WELL FUNDED SPECIAL UNITS.
HOWEVER IF THERE'S A SILVER
LINING THE DAY THE FUNDING
REQUEST BEFORE YOU BEGIN TO GET
PUBLIC DEFENDERS THEY NEEDED
ECONOMIC CONFUSION. TO CORRECT
THE IMBALANCE OF THE PAST AND
HELP MEN AND WOMEN.
PREDOMINANTLY MEN BLACK MEN AND
BROWN BACK AND WOULD REGAIN THE
FRAGMENT OF THEIR LIVES YOU CAN
BUY A SYSTEM DESIGNED AND
FUNDED. IN THE PAST THE CASE
ALL. GET DEATH. ONE YOU FOR
THIS TIME AND NOT TURN OVER
TIME TO MY COLLEAGUE TRACY
OLSON. THANK YOU. HERE ARE MY
NAME'S TRACY OLSON AND IT'S MY
FIRST. IT IS THE HE S. THAT
BEEN HAPPEN. ONE I HAVE ASKED
YOU SEE MORE- CENTER YOU ASKED
WHETHER OR NOT IT WAS. I'M
SORRY HOLD ON MISSILE AND- WE
OKAY NOW. OKAY GO AHEAD WE WERE
HEARING LOT OF FLAK THAT GO
AHEAD. IN ISSUE I FORCED NEWMAN
ASKED WHETHER I WAS ABOUT TO
FIND THAT WERE REPRESENTING THE
QUESTION PERSON THAT PROGRAMS
IT IS NOT PUBLIC DEFENDERS.
THERE'S A GOVERNMENT
CONSTRUCTION AUTHORIZES THE
PUBLIC UNDERSTANDING AND IT
DOES NOT INCLUDE. AND STATUS
ACCORDING TO THE WRITING. THAT
ARE GOING THE- WALL HEARINGS
LEVINE IT'S VERY NEED TO ACCESS
CONTRACT I THINK. I JUST WENT
IN THE BACK TO BACK. BUSINESS
FOR YOUR GREAT ASKING YOU THE
JUSTICE OF CENTER TALKS STATE.
YOU HEARD THAT L. A. COUNTY IS
OF ABOUT SEVEN I HAVE NO IN
FIVE WHICH A LOT OF.
THOUSAND
SO. SLEEPING WITH THE STRIPPERS
OFFICE IN THE PORTS THAT ARE.
ELIGIBLE BUT READY FOR WEEK. IN
A COMBINATION OF THOSE WORKED
THE REASON WE BLACKED AND
SUCCESSFUL IS BOATS ARE
FOUNDATION OF SUCH AS- THIS
PART IS I CAN AREN'T WORKING
THANK YOU THANKS YEARS THE
MERIT. REALLY AREN'T MISTAKEN
SOMEONE ON THE QUESTION WHICH
IS. IMAGE AND MY POINT SYSTEM
THINK IS THAT THAT'S GOING TO
PASS. SAY YES OR THIS SPRING
SUPPORT. AND HE'S. AND THAT'S
THE WORST ANSWERED THEY ARE
EXPERTS STARTER MARC NEED. A
USER VAST KNOWLEDGE OR SOURCES
OF ENERGY FINANCE AND THERE'S A
PLAN THAT ABLE MY FRIENDS A
SUPPORT. SENATE AND SUCCESSFUL.
IF I REQUEST IS FUNDED BIT OR
OF ALL THAT. IS GOING TO GO TO
HIGHER SOCIAL WHAT HAPPENED.
WE'RE ASKING THAT YOU TO STATE
AND- UP SMACKS PARKS. THAT'S
ONE IT'S- NEVER CROSS. BIG
DIFFERENCE FARM ON YOUR
NINETEEN STOP. SPECIAL MY THAT
DISCUSSION EARLIER. SINCE
BEFORE BACK. THANK BUT YOU VERY
MUCH MISS OLSON ARE APPRECIATE
YOUR- I USE HOW A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS- WHAT IS IT THAT THIS
THE STATE DO ABOUT WORKFLOW-
WOULD- YOU KNOW WHAT IS IT
THAT'S NEED TO A THE WORK. ARE
YOU MEANT A SOCIAL. UP OF MY
BIGGER THAN THEY HAVE- IN THE
PAST- HOW MANY SOCIAL WORKERS
ARE ARE ARE THERE NOW ACROSS
THE- OF A PUBLIC DEFENDER
OFFICES AND WHAT WHAT ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF
NUMBERS AND OF ABILITY TO
AFFECT THE WORKLOAD. WHERE I
KNOW THIS. VETERANS OFFICES DO
NOT HAVE. I HAVE TWO ADULTS
OBSERVERS WHEN NETWORK PLANS
WHEN. I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY LA
AT THE OTHER SIDE BUT IT'S NOT
ENOUGH AND SO I THINK WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR IS CURRENTLY
EXPIRED TO SOCIAL WORKERS. MARK
EVEN THE TERMS ARTS DOCKS OUT
SOCIAL WORKERS ALL THESE PLACES
ARE SERVICE AND ALWAYS THIS IS
A STARK PATCHWORK AND VERSUS
STRUGGLING STRUGGLING TO GET
THAT KNOWLEDGE OF THE BUSINESS
I WAS YOUNGER SB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN BUT THAT DOESN'T.
BUT SECTIONS THAT GREAT ESCAPE
YES. AT THAT I WOULD TO THAT
COMMENT BY THIS AND IS THAT
THEN. VARIES FROM COUNTY TO
COUNTY BUT CASE WORKLOADS YES
POP TO BUY. WITH A UNIT NUMBER
AND I WOULD SAY THERE MORE OR-
BECAUSE THIS WOULD IS LOOKING
AT THE RATE. OF DEBT- IS MORE
PRO DAY ON THE K. SIDE. RETURNS
PRESIDENT. RICHARD HAS DONE TO
CORRECT THE WRONGS OF MASS
INCARCERATION BY GIVING THOSE
PEOPLE IN PRISON AN OPPORTUNITY
TO REDRESS HARM TO PETITION FOR
RELEASE TO ADDRESS JUVENILE
INAPPROPRIATE JEWS OUT
SENTENCING AND SO I WAS THOSE.
NEED TO COME BACK TO THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE ACROSS THE
STATE IT DEPENDS ON HOW MANY
CLIENTS A HAT THIS IS WORK THAT
LAWYERS HAVE TO BEGIN TO DO
AGAINST SOME. OF THE BEGINNING
WHILE STILL HOLDING ONTO THEIR
EXISTING. CASELOADS THEY HAVE
ACROSS THE DIFFERENT PARTIES
ACROSS THE STATE SO SOCIAL
WORKERS. ARE A KEY FACTOR
HELPING MITIGATE THE CASELOAD
FOR THE ATTORNEYS BY ALLOW BY
TAKING ON THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
CREATING REENTRY THERE TRULY
EXPERTS OF LOOKING AT THE
MITIGATING FACTORS AFFECTING A
YOUNG PERSON WELL HERE SHE WAS
SO CALLED ENGAGE IN CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY. AS A CHILD IT LED
THEM TO A PRISON SENTENCE WHICH
WAS FACULTY WHICH IS DRUG.
TESTED THE SOCIAL WORKERS ARE
TRULY THE INDIVIDUALS
COMMUNICATE WITH FAMILY MEMBERS
NOT JUST OF OUR CLIENTS BUT IN
IN REAL WAYS FAMILY MEMBERS OF
THE PAST VICTIMS- OR- SEARCH
FOR RECORDS UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF PSYCHOLOGICAL
STUDIES ABLE. SUPPORT THE
TENSION RELIEF BECAUSE ALTHOUGH
FOR EXAMPLE UNDER ELEVEN
SEVENTY D. OF THE PENAL CODE
THIS RETURNEES HERE IN LOS
ANGELES FOR EXAMPLE HAS PARTY'S
CRAZY KID HE'S GOING TO. PRISON
FOR TWENTY THOUSAND RELEASES
IT'S STILL UP TO THE COURT TO
DECIDE WHETHER THE INDIVIDUAL
QUALIFIES YOU TO OPEN THE GRANT
THAT RELEASE NOT. AND SO PUBLIC
DEFENDERS WITH THE HELP OF
SOCIAL WORKERS HAVE TO
LITIGATE. IN AN ADVERSARIAL
SETTING THAT REALITY AND. A
JUDGE MAKES YOU. THE
INFORMATION NEEDED BY THE
COURTS MAKE IT. TO TURN WHETHER
OR NOT. A PERSON WILL BE REALLY
OR WHETHER THERE'S WILL BE.
IT'S VERY. ON THE CALL OF THE
INFORMATION THEY'RE PROVIDING.
AND THAT QUALITY INFORMATION
HAS. ARRIVED AND LIFE AND LIFE
ENHANCING SO TALK ABOUT THE
PERSON SOMETIMES EVEN FROM
BIRTH TO THE CURRENT SITUATION
I GOT INTO. IT BECAUSE YOU
THAT'S WHY I MENTIONED THE
REASONS WHY PEOPLE ARE. GETTING
FIND THEMSELVES IN THE CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM AS WELL AS
COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES OF THAT
CONCEPT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY VERY MUCH- COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THIRD
CORTES A BROCHURE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IN I JUST WANNA
SAY- M. S. MAYBE THIS IS A- TO
BROADER QUESTION FOR THIS LATE
IN THE DAY SO WE JUST ASK FOR
AN INITIAL RESPONSE AND
CERTAINLY SOMETHING I GUESS. I
COULD TAKE OFF WONDER THERE WAS
THE COMMITTEE COULD. I SUPPOSE-
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF EMPHASIS
ON THE CHANGING NATURE OF THE
WORK THE NEED FOR SOCIAL
WORKERS ALL OF WHICH- I
ACCEPTED I BOUGHT INTO- BUT I
HAVEN'T HEARD MUCH ABOUT. THE
IMBALANCE IN ITS IMPACT ON THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS OF THE
ACCUSED OF AND IT SEEMS TO ME
AND YOU KNOW COMING FROM OF A
FAIRLY BIG COUNTY ANSWER SANTA
CLARA COUNTY KNOWING. WITH THE
WITH THE DIFFERENTIALS WERE IN
HUMAN RESOURCES ARE AN
ATTORNEY'S- CAN YOU SPEAK TO GO.
YOU KNOW THE VULNERABILITY OF
THE STATE WITH THE I'M NOT
ASKING TO CREATE A ROAD MAP FOR
LITIGATION HERE OR A CIVIL
RIGHTS ISSUE BUT- AT SOME POINT
YOU KNOW GIVEN THE
DISPROPORTIONATE. THE
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE- OBVIOUSLY IN POVERTY
REALLY WOULD BE THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE IN THE FIRST
PLACE BY QUALIFICATION PEOPLE
OF COLOR. MAKE UP A
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF
FOLKS THAT YOU'RE REPRESENTING-
IF YOU'RE- OUT GUN FROM HUMAN
RESOURCE STANDPOINT AND WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN IN TERMS OF. THE
PROTECTIONS IN THE UNITED
STATES CONSTITUTION IN THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION IN AN
AND NO THAT'S NOT THE ANSWER
BUT I'M JUST ASKING YOU. I I'M
JUST I JUST I FEEL LIKE I NEED
TO ASK A QUESTION BECAUSE I
DIDN'T WATCH ABOUT IN THE
PRESENTATION. FOR ILLNESS
DURING THIS. I APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTION AND I APPRECIATE THE
CONCERN ABOUT CREATING A ROAD
MAP AS AS YOU CREATE I DON'T
WANT TO DO THAT I THINK WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT IS TO-
SEPARATE ISSUES THE FIRST IS AS
I DISCUSSED IN MY PRESENTATION
THERE'S A TRADITIONAL- INDIGENT
REPRESENTATION THAT MOST PEOPLE.
C. N. UNDERSTAND WHICH IS WHAT.
WE CALL THE LIBERTY MALL WHERE
INDIVIDUALS YOU KNOW IS ACCUSED
OF THE- CRIME OR ACTED. THEIR
CHARGE BY DISCONCERTING AND WE-
REPRESENT THE BECAUSE OUR
INDIGENT AND IT'S TO GO TO
TRIAL. THAT PART OF OUR
PRACTICE IS ALWAYS BEEN A
DISPROPORTIONATE- BECAUSE OF
RESOURCES AS I'VE INDICATED
BEFORE. HAVE COME. TO THIS
COUNTRY'S OFFICE. VARIOUS
RESOURCES NOT JUST THE COUNTIES
IN WHICH- THEY RESIDE OUR
RESOURCES HAVE PREDOMINANTLY
COME OVER HISTORICALLY FROM
JETSTAR COUNTIES. AS A STATE
HAS DELEGATED RESPONSIBILITY
FOR INJURED RESPECT THE FENCE
OF THE STATE- EXISTENCE THE
COUNTY- DEVIZES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND SO THAT IS ONE
MODEL AND I THINK WHAT WE HAVE
AT TIMES FELT. AND STILL
COMPUTER STILL. THE RESOURCE
ALLOCATIONS IS UNBALANCED- WHAT
WE HAVE IS QUITE FRANKLY AND I
DON'T THINK CANDIDLY INCREDIBLY
DILIGENCE- COMMITTED. PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND WHEN I SAY PUBLIC
DEFENDERS I DON'T MEAN ME I AM
COMMITTED TO THE WORK I DO BUT
I MEAN THE LAWYERS THAT
MISSILES AND I HAVE IN OUR
OFFICE WHO- SPARE NO TIME
ENERGY OR PART OF THEIR LIVES.
TO PROTECT THEIR CLIENTS
PROTECT OUR CLIENTS. WHAT'S
CHANGED NOW AS I MENTIONED
DRASTICALLY IS. THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF PUBLIC
DEFENDERS WELL IGNITED. IS
RESPONSIVE WE TAKE ON GLADLY TO
ADDRESS OF THE LAWS OF THE PAST
THAT CREATED MASS INCARCERATION.
THAT WE NOW HAVE A SECOND BITE
AT THE APPLE SO TO SPEAK TO BE
ABLE TO HELP THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT WE WORKED WITH BEFORE DO
YOU HAVE AN OPTION TO COME
HOME. TO SPEND TIME WITH THEIR
FAMILY A RATHER THAN THE REST
OF THEIR LIFE IN PRISON THAT
TYPE OF WORK. WE ARE WE WILL
HAVE BEEN PREPARED FOR THAT
WHEN THE LEGISLATURES PASSED.
NEW LAWS ALLOWING THAT TO
HAPPEN THEY COME AND FIND IT-QUITE HONESTLY AND SO WE HAVE
HAD TO TAKE IT OUT OF HIGH FOR
LACK OF A BETTER TERM.
EFFECTUATEWHAT WE CONSIDER TO
BE OUR OBLIGATION AND QUITE
FRANKLY I THINK THAT WE WOULD
BE DIFFICULT FOR MISSILE CENTER
MYSELF OR ANY OF OUR PEERS TO
CONVINCE OUR ATTORNEYS YOU
THOUGHT IT WAS RIGHT NOT TO DO
THIS. IT IS A COMMITMENT TO
HELPING OUR CLIENTS. BEFORE
DURING AND AFTER. A CONVICTION
AND SO I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWERS
A QUESTION WITHOUT AGAIN I
DON'T WANT TO CREATE A ROAD MAP
FOR ANYONE. BUT THERE IS NO
QUESTION ABOUT THE YEAH YOUR
BALANCE LAST YEAR I. THINK IT
WAS IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN HERE
BEFORE. THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
OFFICE PREPARED REPORT. A
REGARDING THE- FUNDING. AND
RESOURCE ALLOCATION FOR PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ACROSS THE STATE AS
COMPARED THIS RETURNS. AND ONE
OF THE- THINGS THAT OUT TO ME
THE MOST WAS THE SUPPORT STAFF
ALLOCATION SO THEY'RE FINDING
WAS APPROXIMATELY SIXTY
PERCENT. OF THE STAFF THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICER
TOURNEY WHILE 40% OF THAT
STAFF. ARE SUPPORT STAFF AND
THE INVERSE IS TRUE DISCOVERIES
40% ARE CHINESE AND 60% OUR
SUPPORT AND BY SUPPORTING ME
INCLUDING SOCIAL WORKERS
PARALEGALS HE ELEMENT. IT LEGAL
PRACTICE. BECAUSE OF THAT
INVERSION FOR PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ARE. I'M FORTY FORCED TO DO
MUCH OF THE NON PUBLIC DEFENDER
WORK THAT IS CLEAR OR THE
RESEARCH IT COULD BE BETTER
DONE BY EXPERTS SUCH AS SOCIAL.
AND THEY COULD FOCUS OUR ENERGY
ON THE LORD WHICH IS. WHAT WE
WANT TO LARGER. I HOPE THAT WAS
pDANCE ON OUR TUNES ROY YOU KNOW
APPRECIATE THE DILIGENCE- IN
THE PASSION AND I'VE SEEN IT
AND I CERTAINLY WASN'T CASSIDY
IS PERSONS ON THAT- IT JUST
SEEMS TO ME THAT. THERE SHOULD
BE MORE DILIGENT AND PASSIONATE
PEOPLE AND I DON'T THINK IT
WOULD DIMINISH THE PASSION OF
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ALREADY
THERE TO HAVE SOME HELP- YOU
KNOW IN TERMS OF OTHER
ATTORNEYS. YOU KNOW DAVID
VERSUS GOLIATH IS. A GREAT
BIBLICAL STORY BUT- I DON'T
THINK ONE GUY WITH A SLING SHOT
YOU KNOW AGAINST SOME AGAINST
THE GIANT. PASSES
CONSTITUTIONAL MUSTER AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT I WAS
GETTING HURT YOU KNOW. THE
PEOPLE. THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
TAKE CARE OF DESERVE- EQUIPMENT
RESOURCES TO THOSE WHO TO THE
STATE CONSTRUED SUBSTANTIALLY
TRYING TO PROSECUTE THEM. ON
THE OTHER SIDE SO THAT'S ALL IT
WAS SEEN IN- AGAIN IDEA I
APPRECIATE RESPONSE IN. YOU
KNOW I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
YOUR- SERVE YOUR DEFENSE OF THE
HARDWORKING FOLKS WHO DO THAT
WORK I'VE I'VE SAT IN
CONFERENCE ROOMS WITH MANY OF
THEM- FOR MANY MANY HOURS IN
BRIEFINGS AND HIM SEEN HOW HARD
YOU KNOW OUR PUBLIC DEFENDERS
WORK SO. I DO APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU. THIS IS WHAT I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THAT
STATEMENT- IT REALLY DOES SPEAK
VOLUMES ABOUT THE WORK THAT WE
DO. AND THE DEDICATION AND I
AND I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PERSONALLY AND ON BEHALF OF MY
ENTIRE TEAM. WELL I ALSO WANT
TO THANK YOU MR GARCIA AND MISS
MISS OLSON- AND PLEASE. EXTEND
OUR APPRECIATION TO ALL OF THE
STAFF ATTORNEYS AND SUPPORT
STAFF FOR ALL THAT YOU DO. I DO
WE DO BELIEVE WE HAVE TO FUND
THE LEGISLATION THAT WE PASSED
UP HERE AND I THINK THAT'S THE
CORE ISSUE THAT. WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
AND YOUR PATIENCE AND MAKING
YOUR PRESENTATION TO US IT WAS-
BELIEVE ME IT WAS WORTH IT FOR
US. IF YOU WERE HERE THANK YOU-
ALL DISCUSSION. AND DEBATE ON
PARTS A AND B. HAVE ENDED WE
MOVE NOW ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
OF ANYONE WANTING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT REGARDING. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS-
TODAY OF WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE INTO THAT AS A REMINDER
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS THREE THREE
EIGHT ZERO FOUR SIX SEVEN. DUE
TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
PRESENTATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS THE CHAIR- WE WILL
HAVE A LIMIT ON TESTIMONY I'M
GOING TO ASK THAT EACH MEMBER
OF THE PUBLIC. PROVIDING
COMMENT KEEP YOUR REMARKS
WITHIN HALF A MINUTE- AND JUST
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHOEVER HAS
BEEN WAITING HOURS TO HAS THE
TIME TO GET THEIR POINT ACROSS.
NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM- WE SEE NONE ANY WITNESSES
AND ROOM ONE TWELVE. WHICH TO
PROVIDE COMMENT SEEN NONE. OF
THEM. WE DON'T SEE ANY IN THE
OVER OVERFLOW ROOM WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WANTING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT- VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WERE WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THEN WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS WIDEN AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MODERATED CAN YOU
PLEASE GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY.
YES WE CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT
THIRTEEN IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATE PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES AND CALL THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
RIGHT FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANKS VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
MIKE YOU'RE A WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY THANK
YOU FOR THIS VERY ENLIGHTENING
HEARING TODAY- I'M- CALLING IN
TODAY TO COMMENT ON THE- THE
TRAFFIC ONLINE TRAFFIC
COMMUNICATION PROPOSAL BY THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL- WE WISH TO
ASSOCIATE PURSER COMMENTS WITH-
MR GREEN FROM THE ACLU TODAY-
AND IN. SPECIFIC OUR POSITION
ON- THE TRAFFIC PILOT IS THAT
WE REALLY FEEL THAT- THAT THE
L. A. REPORT I THINK ACCURATELY
POINTS OUT THAT WE HAVE A SAYS
WE'VE JUST GOT TO MUCH COSTS ON
LOW INCOME FAMILIES THE
ACCUMULATION OF FINES AND FEES
OVER TIME- MEANING THAT OUR
POOREST CITIZENS ARE THE ONES
FROM THE OUR COURT SYSTEMS
RIGHT NOW. AND THAT IS NOT
SUSTAINABLE AS IT SHOWS THROUGH
THE REVENUE WE REALLY ARE
URGING THE LEGISLATURE TO
ELIMINATE THE FINING THE FEES
THAT ARE BEING SPENT ON TRAFFIC
VIOLATIONS. ARE CRIMINAL
VIOLATIONS. THERE ARE VERY
IMPORTANT FOR YOU FOR THE FUN
THAT- THE WHITE. THINK NEED TO-
WE SHOULD FUNDING THE THROUGH
CHEN FUND ARE OTHER REVENUES
SIR RIGHT NOW WOULD BE A GOOD
TIME FOR US TO BEGIN THOSE
TRANSITION. AND SO- WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO REALLY TAKE A
STRONG LOOK AT ELIMINATING FEES
FINES AND FEES. IN THE CURRENT
COURT SYSTEM- WE LIKE THIS IDEA
OKAY FINE THAT WAS BROUGHT UP
AND WE THINK THAT. IS WORTHY OF
FURTHER EXPLORATION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR FIVE THANK
YOU. NEXT THANK YOU RAIMES.
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE FIVE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONLY BE SANTANA'S ON BEHALF OF
ENERGY YOU CALIFORNIA CALLING
IN TODAY TO REGISTER STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE PROPOSAL THE
FUNDING SOCIAL WORKERS AND
ADDITIONAL STAFF AT COUNTY
PUBLIC DEFENDER AUTHORS. WE
HAVE SEEN DRAMATIC AND- IN
OUTCOME AND REDUCTION IN
RECIDIVISM IN COUNTY OFFICES A
PUBLIC DEFENDER WHERE ARE
SOCIAL WORKERS ARE PLACED AND
ARE USED TO HELP RIGHT BY
SUPPORT NOT ONLY TO ADULTS BUT
JUVENILE. IT'S AN IMPERATIVE
PROGRAM AND ONE THAT IS VERY
COST EFFECTIVE YOU GET THE
BIGGEST BANG FOR YOUR BUCK
WE'RE ALSO CALLING INTO
SUPPORT- ELIMINATION OF
CRIMINAL. FINES AND PENALTIES-
PARTICULARLY WITH OUR STATE
GENERAL FUND BOX BUILT IN SURE
THAT COURT ARE NOT FINANCIALLY
DISADVANTAGED. BY THE PROPOSAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUCH.
THANK YOU I'M SIXTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER I'M
ALSO CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA AND
WE'RE BOTH CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF THE PROPOSAL AND TO SUPPORT
AND PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND SOCIAL
WORKERS- SOCIAL WORKERS IN
PARTICULAR HAVE A SPECIAL
SKILLS THAT THAT THAT HELP THEM
WORK. IN THESE OFFICES TO WRITE
BY PROFESSIONAL HISTORY BASED
ON THE CLIENT RECORDS AND
INTERVIEWS WITH FAMILY AND
FRIENDS BUT WE'RE ALSO
PRIMARILY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
SUCCESSFUL REENTRY AND WRITING
THOSE REENTRY PLANS- AS THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER SAID- WE'VE
GOT A LOT OF BANG FOR YOUR BUCK
WITH SOCIAL WORKERS IN THESE
OFFICES BUT LIKE I SAID THEY
REALLY HAVE THE SKILLS THAT
HELP MAKE THESE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORMS. WORK THE NEW.
PUBLIC ARE THAT HAVE BEEN FIND
FOR A VERY LONG TIME AND SO WE
JUST WANT TO ADD ARE STRONG
POINT FOR THE PROPOSAL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOSH DUGGAR
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
THANK YOU FOR THE INFORMATIVE
DISCUSSION ON THE STATE EFFORT
TO ELIMINATE OR REDUCE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE RELATED FINES AND FEES
WE AGREE THAT IF WE REBUILD THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TODAY
WE WOULD NOT RELY ON THE OVERLY
COMPLEX SYSTEMS CHARGING COURT
INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS FIND
COMPETE TO FINANCE PROGRAMS. WE
ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT FIND
BEEN PETE HAVE ON LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS WITH SB. ONE FORTY
FOUR EIGHTY EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE
ABILITY TO PAY AND NOW SB FIVE
EIGHTY SIX WE'VE TRIED TO
PARTNER IN THIS IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION AND NOT OPPOSE THESE
EFFORTS ON A POLICY BASIS. WE
ONLY RECOGNIZE THAT WE ONLY ASK
THAT THE STATE RECOGNIZED THE
REVENUE IMPACT BUT THESE
EFFORTS HAVE ON COUNTIES AND
PRIORITIZE BACK SO FUNDS TO
CONTINUE THE IMPORTANT PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES CHINESE ARE
PROVIDING AND WE APPRECIATE THE
COLLABORATION. TO DATE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
SIX FOUR PLEASED AHEAD. THE
AFTERNOON ONE PACKAGE FOR ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND THE ELLA
BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
IN SUPPORT OF THE REPEAL OF
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES THAT BURKE
LOW INCOME FAMILIES THE
FAMILIES THANK YOU TO COLOR.
ALSO SUPPORT THE INVESTMENT IN
PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND SOCIAL
WORKERS TO. HELP REINFORCE OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND LASTLY TO
FIND ATTORNEYS TO HELP PEOPLE
PREPARE FOR ALL PHASES OF THE
POOL PROCESS AS DESCRIBED BY
JAMES KING POLITIKER CENTER
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS ELIZABETH
ESPINOSA ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
WORLD COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO SPEAKING ON
ISSUE ONE REGARDING COURT
RELATED FINES AND FEES I
LARGELY WANT TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF MY
COUNTERPART AT SEA FACT WE DO
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE IS DISCUSSION OF
THE REAL LIFE IMPACTS THE FINES
AND FEES AND- REGRETTABLY THE
RESULTING DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT ON LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. WE RECOGNIZE THE
CASCADING FINANCIAL LEGAL AND
EMPLOYMENT IMPACTS THAT FLOW
FROM WHAT OFTEN AMOUNTS TO
CRUSHING THAT. A COUNTY
PERSPECTIVE WE- URGE THAT AS
THIS MULTIFACETED CONVERSATION
GOES FORWARD THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONTINUE TO
RECOGNIZE THE LOCAL FISCAL
IMPACT. ASSOCIATED WITH ANY
ELIMINATION OF THE FINANCIER
FORTY AS WELL AS- THE CASE WITH
EIGHTY EIGHT POINT SIXTY NINE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE. PASSED IN
TWENTY TWENTY- GIVEN THE
ASSOCIATED PERMIT REVENUE LOST
WEEK THAT WE COUNTIES CONTINUE
TO ADVOCATE FOR REVENUE BACK
BILL TO ENSURE CONTINUITY OF
LOCAL PROGRAMS AND SERVICES. WE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS KEITH AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
MA'AM SURE AND- COMMONS
LICENSING IN PERSON FOR A
LITTLE BIT LIKE TO COME ON PART
A ITEM SEVENTEEN THE INDIRECT
COST RATE- THE SOCIAL COUNTY
THAT YOU KNOW INVEST IN THE
STATE HIGHWAY AND THEN-
CHARGED. DIRECT RATE IN AN
INDIRECT COST RATE FOR THE WORK
THAT WE DO ON THE HIGHWAY THE
ONLY TIME THAT WE CURRENT
INDIRECT COSTS YOU MORE MAKING
INVESTMENTS IN THE STATE
HIGHWAY SO. I JUST WANT TO
CORRECT THE LITTLE BIT OF THE
ANALYSIS AND SAYING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT LOSES MONEY WHEN
THEY DON'T COLLECT AND
INTEGRATE COMPACTOR COLLECTING.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS INVESTOR
THE STATE. AND CHARGING US AND
INDIRECTLY FOR. ADDRESS AND
THAT ILL PUTTING IN SO. WE
SUPPORT THE CONTINUATION OF THE
CAP ON THAT INDIRECT COSTS AT
TEN PERCENT.IT SAYS. THE
ENCOURAGEMENT FOR A COOPERATION
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT AND SELF
HELP COUNTIES TO WHICH- YOU
KNOW LOS ANGELES ORANGE COUNTY
SANTA CLARA OR SOME OF OUR
STRONGEST MEMBERS. AND WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ALSO WOULD BE
USED TO ASSIST COALITION- FOR
THE CONVERSATIONS PARTICULARLY
WITH THE- SHE ROLE ON C. UP IN
DIFFERENT SERVICES AND ALL THAT
I SPEAK FROM SOME BEEN IMPACTED
BY ALL OF THESE ISSUES- THE
STAND HERE IN MY TO SHOOT. AND
ALSO WHEN THEY AT SEVEN. DIDN'T
COME UP I MET THIRTY AND
BECAUSE SB. TWO SIXTY. I'M
GONNA CHEN OUT FUNDS UNDERSTAND
ALL THE ISSUES. ALMOST FORTY
FROM ON THE PHONE I. SO AFTER
THAT NOT TO GET INTO ALL THAT-
THANK YOU DISCLOSURE THE IMPACT
OF FINDING. ALSO SUNDAY. THE
FULL SOCIAL. I SEE SO WHAT DO
YOU DO A BLACK OF THE WHETHER
THAT'S UP IN COULD LEGAL BUT TO
MAKE DECISION THERE'S ABILITY.
NOT CHANCES ARE EVEN IF CUT IT
LITTLE BIT. EXPRESSING DO BOTH.
SO YOU PLACE IN THE BETTER. I
JUST AS ANY OFF TIME OR MOTHERS
AT A COST OF IN THE LEGAL
SYSTEM ETCETERA THANK MANY
OTHERS CRINGE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE CALL AND THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MARK TO WORK ON BEHALF OF
THE- PUBLIC DEFENDER SYSTEM.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND CO THE
THANK PUBLIC SOCIAL. URGES THE
WHITE. TO OUR FUNDS TO A FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES ON AND BASIS TO
PROVIDE ONE TIME SUPPORT FOR
AND DEFENSE IN PARTICULAR
PUBLIC DEFENDERS AND SOCIAL
WORKERS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
IMPLEMENTING RESET POST
CONVICTION CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
IMMIGRATION REFORM STATUTE.
FULLY IMPLEMENTED WILL LOWER
CALIFORNIA'S PRISON POPULATION
KEEP OUR COMMUNITY SAFE AND
PREVENT THE UNJUST DEPORTATIONS
OF NON SERVICE BRAND THANK. YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS STEVE BAKER
WITH ORDINARY THE SIMPSONS FOR
PRESERVING THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT COMMENTING ON AGENDA
ITEM AGENDA ITEM SEVENTEEN IN
THE GENDER A ON THE INDIRECT
COST RATE RECOVERY WE AGREE
WITH THE SELF HELP COUNTY
COALITION THAT IT DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO. BUILD SELF HELP
KILLINGS FOR COSTS THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PROJECT WE
BUILT THE CURRENT AUTHORIZATION
EXPIRES JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND SUPPORTED. SIX
INCHES THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK ARE INSURED FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS SEAN
YOUNG AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE FINANCIAL JUSTICE
PROJECT OF THE OFFICE OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO TREASURER- THANK
YOU TO SENATORS DORADO ON YOU
MANY CORTES IAN STOPPER
CREATING SPACE HERE THE
CONCERNS OF. JUSTICE INVOLVED
PEOPLE I'M CALLING IN TODAY THE
PORT I'M NOT A COMPLETE REPEAL
CRIMINAL ADMINISTRATIVE FEES
WHICH DISPROPORTIONATELY
BURDENED WITH JUDGES OF ALL
PEOPLE AND THEIR FAMILIES WITH
THAT ON THE CITY'S ROUTINELY
FORCED TO DRAW PEOPLE IN THEIR
LOVED ONES TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
PAYING DOWN THEIR DEBT AND
PAYING FOR GROCERIES RENT AND
OTHER NECESSITIES AGAIN THESE
FEES ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
LEVIED. ON LOW INCOME BLACK AND
BROWN FAMILIES WHO HAVE BEEN
HIT HARDEST BY THE PANDEMIC
BUT- WE ALSO KNOW AMERICAN
HEARING THE GOVERNMENT THAT THE
MATH DOESN'T ADD UP. ALL THESE
FEES YOU KNOW THERE IS
SOMETHING THAT. ALL ONE TO
COLLECT RATE ON THE CEDAR THE
SINGLE DIGITS. THIS IS STORY.
ON THAT HAPPENING NOW ALL. HOW
ARE LARGELY. BECAUSE PEOPLE
CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY. THANK YOU
WHILE DOCTORS INVOLVED PEOPLE
IN THE FAMILY STRUGGLE EVERYDAY
WITH THE DECORATE BY FEET I
STRONGLY URGE YOU. TO CALL THE
ELIMINATION FORGET THAT
PRIVILEGED COMMUNITIES. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RANGE. SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
WEIGHED ASK YOU FROM LEGAL
SERVICES OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WE SUPPORT THE ELIMINATION OF
CRIMINAL FEES INCLUDING
ELIMINATION OF THE CIVIL
ASSESSMENT AND URGE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO PRIORITIZE THE
ELIMINATION OF THESE FEES GIVEN
THAT THEY WILL HAVE A MUCH MORE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY
BLACK AND BROWN CALIFORNIANS.
AND EXPANDING THE ABILITY TO
PAY PILOT WE REGULARLY SEE IN
OUR WORK TO WAYS IN WHICH FEES
CRIPPLE LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
TO RAISE BARRIERS TO RE ENTRY
WE ALSO SEE THAT ABILITY TO PAY
PROCESS HE'S REACHED TO FEW
PEOPLE WHO NEED RELIEF
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE. ABILITY TO PAY
PROCESS THESE ARE
INCONSISTENTLY IMPLEMENTED FROM
COURT TO COURT AND JUDGE TO
JUDGE LOW INCOME RESIDENTS
WOULD BENEFIT MUCH MORE
PROFOUNDLY FROM ELIMINATION OF
FEES THAT EXTENSION OF THE
PILOT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT. THANK YOU RYAN FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE CENTER HIS
ANTHONY DIMARTINO ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY DRASTIC
CARDS ARE VIRUS RESEARCH INTO
THIS I HAVE OVER NINE THOUSAND
ORGANIZED CRIME SURVIVORS DRESS
STATE AND WE'RE CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ISSUE
THIRTEEN AGAIN NAY THE GARDEN
ALL THE WAY BACK TO THE OLD
RESTITUTION FUND WE UPON THE
GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE FOR
THE SUPPORTING VICTIMS. WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO SUGGEST THE
COMMITTEE EXPLORE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES SUCH AS FUNDS
FROM ASSET FORFEITURE TO
BOLSTER THE WORKER CAL BCB IN
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF NEW
JERSEY'S ARE ALSO SUPPORTED BY
PEELING PINE THE P. AS WELL AS
FUNDING FOR PUBLIC DEFENDERS
AND SOCIAL WORKERS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS YOU IT
TIME. OKAY PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES AND CALLED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AGAIN. FOR THE FINAL
TIME. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE A OMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THINK
YOU'LL ACTUALLY WE DO HAVE ONE
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT WHITE NUMBER.
THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE JUST ONE MORE
MOMENT. SIX POINT SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM HERE
BROWN CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
ELLA BAKER CENTER FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS IN OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE PROPOSAL TO REPEAL
CRIMINALS USE THAT BURDEN LOW
INCOME FAMILIES THE TREES ARE
NOT RESTORATIVE AND ESSENTIALLY
ACT AS ANOTHER FORM OF
PUNISHMENT THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR DRIVING
PEOPLE DEEPER INTO POVERTY AND
FURTHER ENTANGLING THEM IN THE
CRIMINAL SYSTEM. ELIMINATING
THESE FEES ONE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S STOPS USING THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
GENERATE REVENUE ON THE BACKS
OF CALIFORNIANS MOST VULNERABLE
FAMILIES THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF NOW HAVING HEARD
FROM ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
SENATORS HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS NONE THREE NINE WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE VOTE
FIRST VOTE WILL BE ON ISSUES
ONE THROUGH THIRTEEN DO WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THESE ISSUES TO
APPROVED THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION- SENATOR. NEW
AND WILL CALL THE ROLL CALL
VOTE- THE MOTIONS OF APPROVED
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS
CENTER DORADO. I RAZA AVE
CENTER GROVE. SENATOR CORTEZ HE
RETURNS HE HI CENTER NEWMAN AYE
NEWMAN AYE. THREE EYES NO ZERO
THREE EISNER ZEROS WE WILL NOW
TAKE A VOTE ON ISSUE TWENTY THE
CAL STIRS MULTI YEAR INVESTMENT
STRATEGY MOVED MOVED BY SENATOR
NEWMAN WELL THE CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
RAZA HI THERE ALTHOUGH I CENTER
GROVE. SENATOR CORTEZ HE- SAYS
HE AYE CENTER NEWMAN. NEWMAN I.
ZERO ICE THREE NO ZERO THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH OF THAT- THE
PROVED AND I JUST WANT TO END
BY THANKING THAT DR FRANCES ALL
OUR STAFF EVERYONE WHO'S BEEN
HERE TODAY FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND- ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING- OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
FACIAL HEARING RECORDS. THANK
YOU ALL HAVE A GOOD AFTERNOON
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. ALSO.